foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome to the Julius bear generation
cup playing I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me is Grandmaster Daniel
narodiski this is the fifth leg of the
Champions chess tour we've already had
four awesome tournaments in the books
Dania how pumped are you for number five
incredibly rubber these are some of the
most hotly contested hotly debated
fought tournaments with so many
different GMS that we can Spotlight what
is there not to like it's pretty early
in the morning for me but I cannot wait
to jump into a couple of hours of
incredible chess it's never too early to
watch some of the best players on the
planet Slug It Out For A spot in The
Knockout the main event of the Jewish
bear generation cup but we've had four
events already take place let's remind
you of the tour schedule it happens all
throughout the year Magnus Carlson he
won the everything's Masters Hikaru
Nakamura took down the chessful Masters
nordierbeck abdusa tarab the star from
Uzbekistan wins the chess kid cup Magnus
Carlson back to his winning ways at the
aim chess rapid and here we are we're in
the Julius bear generation Cup right now
the plane is today the main event will
be August 30th to September 3rd they're
trying to qualify their way to that
division one that's what all the players
want to be in four players already
locked in for that competition so Donna
we eventually get to the finals in
December but each and every event it
promises so much excitement
indeed it does Robert and each and every
event has its own unique signature yeah
some events are convincingly won by the
best players in the world by Magnus
Carlson and we watch Hikaru Nakamura but
the last event the finals which I
commentated in Norway Hikaru got knocked
out pretty early and you never know
exactly what you're going to expect it's
not formulaic it's not just the top
players qualifying and winning sometimes
if qualifying players the top players
they meet their end at the hands of
someone incredibly unexpected I'm
talking people like Dennis lazovic and
Vladimir fettisev and Robert these
tournaments have really allowed us to
Spotlight a lot of players that
otherwise just wouldn't get the air time
that they deserve Eduardo was a great
example of that from the last event and
you know if you're in this competition
you want to win but it's not going to be
you you're rooting for Magnus or Hikaru
or a business harp and the reason why is
tor standings play a huge role in
determining who makes it to the finals
at the end of the year you see three
names locked in filled in Magnus Carlson
abdusitarov Hikaru Nakamura they for
sure are going to be in the CCT finals
at the end of the year carwana Wesley so
they're very likely to make it based on
tour points throughout the season but
there's a third spot up for grabs and
you see Jordan van Forest well behind
Wesley so it looks like Fabian wessie
they're well on their way but after that
Daniel who are some of the names that
say that's you who might make it via the
leaderboard
well I mentioned Dennis lazovic uh just
now not a coincidence that guy is a
beast he just competed in a small event
that event featured some retired players
and commentators Robert I forget who was
commentating or what that event was you
might have to remind me oh yeah it was
the bullet Chess Championship and Dennis
lazovic acquitted himself pretty well
I'm also looking at some of the people
on the right column you mentioned
Eduardo rizaga about Sam sebi in one of
the most promising American Juniors uh
to play on the tournament circuit right
now Alexi serrana needs no introduction
after his performances in Rapid
tournaments Robert there are just so
many of these young Grandmasters in the
2650 to 2700 range that can bite and
they can punch above their weight and
regularly do
like you were going to talk about names
forever and I was really enjoying
listening because it's true so many
players have a chance and while there
are many players who are going to have a
chance today to qualify for division one
here at the jewel is bear generation cup
and today is the playing stage what does
that look like for those of you who
forget it's been a while we had nine
rounds of 10 minutes plus two seconds
added per move that increment is
necessary so you don't flag here in the
Swiss stage where the top 72 Advanced to
match play and when we get to match play
you get two games of 10 minutes plus two
seconds added per move
52 players will ultimately advance to
the Julius bear generation cup which is
going to be held August 30th to
September 3rd so Donya some big names
will enter today
only four will make it to division one
we know that this format nine rounds of
Swiss then that match stage it gets
really heated
it does indeed it gets heated from the
very early rounds because you can't
afford I mean you can't afford a loss
and generally in our experience
commentating the qualifying score that
the top group is something like six and
a half and you might think well six and
a half out of nine that's a lot more uh
leeway than we're used to from
tournaments like the title Tuesday but
when you see the first round pairings
you start to realize how hard it
actually is to rack up points in this
event I think a lot of people just don't
get that someone like Alexander grishock
might face Ray Robson in the first round
we have GM on GM action from the very
first games and that's what makes this
tournament really magical is that
there's no such thing as a lost round
and every round we have action we have a
lot of top guys losing and uh that's a
magical formula and you can almost say
they're pretty much are no upsets I mean
sometimes you'll see a real top player
lose to a GM that doesn't have the same
name recognition but in this field that
is really so strong everyone has a
chance and let's dive into the actual
players who are taking part today and
okay look at this we have artemiev as
the highest rated Fabiano caruana Maxima
Sherlock Janda palmchi Eduardo eturizaga
he was the hero of the last event my
monitor is glitching
like it's really grainy for some reason
yeah these two names I can't really see
is that a former world champion and
perhaps a future world champion Vladimir
krummick alireza farusia and then Jose
Martinez well known as jaspam online
he's a popular streamer and you see his
chess.com rapid rating is 26.63 so if he
beats somebody who's 27.50 we won't be
surprised but it does look like an upset
on paper
yeah and honestly the uh complete
demolition of what we think of as upsets
has been one of the products of online
chess these last couple of years you
look at someone like Jasper as he's not
on my stream
and you look at a performance that he
puts in he gets six out of nine or six
and a half out of nine and he qualifies
and we barely bat an eye so it's just
genuinely amazing how a lot of younger
players particularly are making a name
for themselves as 2700s in the context
of online chess it's a 10 plus two time
control Blitz and time scrambling
ability is very important and that's
what gives uh a lot of these non-super
GM's a serious chance as I said earlier
to punch above their weight and we will
see who is up to the challenge here at
the Julius bear generation cup and there
are a few descriptors that stood out to
me you know young almost 2700 superstars
in Blitz and this one name that comes to
mind he didn't take part in the bullet
Chess Championship he was invited he
decline but nihal sarin is here to play
today so there are even more names than
we listed from the notable players
that's how many notable players actually
take part in these events that nihal
sarin is in Dennis leswick not here
today because he's already made his way
through uh to the Julius bear generation
cup division one he won division two
last time but as you mentioned sam7 he
lost the Dennis he did unfortunately
earn his ticket into the top division
via the last event but hey maybe today
will be his day so this Swiss stage
format Dania nine rounds really all up
for grabs it's open to GM's and the top
three from each Monday qualifier as you
mentioned 10 minutes plus two seconds
added per move you need to be Speedy
with the mouse you need to think very
quickly in critical moments and it's
typical chest scoring the standard
scoring of one point for win half a
point for a drawing a donut zero for
yeah already cut and dried stuff
obviously the player is a lot more
violent in the early rounds and then the
leaders for the end uh some of them
start to take draws and there's a lot of
match strategy and tournament strategy
involved in securing a qualification
spot for yourself uh but the games are
about to begin we always have a very
wide menu Robert of fascinating players
so we're gonna toggle between a lot of
the interesting top games I vote that we
Spotlight Vladimir kramnik uh for a
little while we have alireza farusha one
problem we definitely do not have is the
situation where there's one game left
it's a long end game and we have nothing
to talk about we will always have
something to talk about in this event
yeah because just looking through the
list of players a names that I didn't
mention a means have to buy
the list really does go on and on that's
no exaggeration Jeffrey Zhang is playing
Yvonne sarich who is in the grand chess
tour uh Jordan run Forrest minlay Anish
giri got akomski we really can keep
going with the names in this field I'm
stoked for on Dimitri on draken
georgmeyer Alexis Serrano but I can't
wait for the games to take off
yeah me neither and we already have some
crazy head-on matchups in the first
round gawaine Jones taking on Fabiano
caruana just looking at the list of
games my my mouth starts watering
unfortunately we can't cover every game
at the same time but I just think it's
so interesting how many different
players we get to Spotlight in the
course of the event and think about Fabi
you've got the black pieces against a
top opening expert somebody who's
written books on a coffee house chess
repertoire for white it's not going to
be an easy path to the top for Fabi and
he is looking to avenge himself after
the bullet Chess Championship where he
played well but obviously uh he met a
lot of bullet addicts who spend their
days and their nights fine-tuning their
fast chess crafts now he's in a Time
control that he feels a little bit more
comfortable in yeah I think that's
important to note that Fabi he did
struggle on the bullet Chess
Championship he prefers to have time as
clock to calculate and he's one of the
best calculators on the planet everyone
compliments him that and it's just a
fact that he is number three in the live
ratings but he was at his Peak
28-44 that's pretty nuts to think about
uh where he was just I just crushing
everybody that sinkfield cup 2014. so
yeah we are waiting for moves to come in
but as you mentioned gawaine Jones five
night car that's a first round matchup
what is this the Olympiad
it basically is then given how many
countries are being represented I'm
going to read off some of the other
pairings Robert while we're going to
wait for the moves to come in and they
should be coming in very soon we've got
Levon aronian against an Italian
Grandmaster Sabino Brunello uh Cena
mobile head now this is a very
interesting name that we are going to
hear a lot more of in the coming months
and years I've played him a lot in
online Blitz he's an he's a fide master
from Iran he is unbelievably talented
and he basically plays on even terms
with all of the top GMS he has white
against Vladimir fedesev I'm very
curious to see how that game goes I've
never seen Cena I've never seen a him uh
play a longer game but you know there's
always a first is he the next alireza
faruja that remains to be seen
that remains to be seen up then we also
have Sam Sevin once is enough isn't it I
squeezed that sponge out to its I run it
out you know while when no more water
comes out
yeah that scene upon is more common than
the name John so I'm gonna have to
wrestle with you later Dania but I am
stoked for the games to begin and you
just mentioned some of these names here
and and something interesting about
someone like Cena Muhammad is really
really strong in Blitz but sometimes I
feel like when fans they see people
thrive in Blitz they assume that that
can also be done in longer time controls
and we see the name on this list right
if you're seeing a Mojave it's just an
honor to get to play against someone
like Vladimir krumnik but we shouldn't
put that weight of their Blitz success
into expectations for them in Rapid
chess we all hope that everyone has a
good day we don't roof for anybody as
commentators but I guess what I'm trying
to get across is that these younger
players especially who are really good
when there's three minute plus zero
second increment and they are flagging
people in Blitz it doesn't always
translate to when you're playing it's
Fabiano caruana or Vladimir kremnik when
they have increment to you so they get
additional time which each with each and
every move make
you're very right and just the role of
class
um the role of depositional
understanding obviously increases in
this time controlling ten plus two is
the time control I like because it
really straddles the bridge between yeah
it has a blitz component on the one hand
particularly toward the end of games but
on the other hand it really does allow
you to make very very deep moves to
display your opening preparation and
that's what I love about online chess in
general top players take it as seriously
as they do in over the board tournaments
so we see top Grand Masters a game when
it comes to their opening when it comes
to their deep thinking and that is I
think part of the reason younger players
who feel like they're you know hot stuff
after their title Tuesday performance
they score three and a half out of nine
and they begin to see that there's just
a couple of things left to learn until
they're able to perform to the level of
the top guys uh in the rapid time
control so definitely I think people
like Cena these young International
Masters even young Grandmasters are
looking at this like a stepping stone
like a learning experience on their very
very long path uh to chess Olympus
and you see in the tour standings and
there are some younger players like
Dennis lazovic tied for eighth with
Levon aronian uh but all the way down to
a player like Min lay that's somebody
who has really benefited from chess and
having more and more tournaments online
just more access for somebody who's from
a very strong chess country you actually
see another player from Vietnam lamlay a
super Grand Master former World Blitz
champion on this list but there's not
always great access to tournaments so
being able to play the elite players
from the comfort of your own home that
actually is something that is truly
amazing and it's not a hundred percent
the same because there are different
tensions when you're sitting across from
a player over the board but there's also
fewer pieces getting thrown off the
board in time scrambles when you play
online you can pre-move and hey guess
what a piece doesn't get swiped off the
board when you accidentally hit a rook
and it flies over to the next table
yeah it flies over over to Nevada
although I was watching uh an
interesting Blitz video with a Time
scramble from the 80s and I was shocked
at how cleanly a Victor korchnoy and I
think Gary Kasparov are time scrambling
so I'll talk about that more but I'm
pretty sure Robert we have a lot of the
moves coming in so we can click into one
of the games and we can start going
around the horn and seeing if the top
guys are already suffering and he
defeats okay and here we go we see that
gawaine Jones you mentioned that match
up against Fabiano caruana so relatively
early stages but the Queens are off the
board white is temporarily up a pawn and
white can protect that pawn with the
bishop going out to F4 that would help
the pawn E5 but black is probably ready
to soon increase the pressure maybe a
knight E6 type of jump and bring that
Knight out into the white camp and
create some threats so I I just look at
this position and I think at first
glance Donya people count material white
has to be better up a pawn but that pawn
does stick out like a sore thumb on E5
that's very true and from E6 the Knight
could also Transit over to D4 obviously
pressuring the bishop and attacking C2
so I actually think black's Knight is a
blessing in disguise it's sitting there
on d8 and it's so easy to dismiss a
piece that's on the last ring but you
have to examine its potential energy so
I think Gawain is trying to make a more
General choice right now between playing
principal chess and clinging to the pawn
which a lot of players would play
automatically but when you're playing
Fabi maybe you're also thinking about
playing a move like Knight C3 and giving
away the pawn and that's exactly what
Wayne Jones did he went Knight C3 he
allowed Abby to take the pawn back on E5
and he's more or less bailing out but
this isn't exactly a draw black still
has to make one or two careful moves and
then I think the piece of chord can be
signed yeah though knowing Fabiano and
the speed with which he's playing he
feels quite comfortable that pawn on B7
can be captured but the Rook will slide
over to B8 hitting the bishop and behind
it the pawn on B2 and that starts
getting into those types of positions
where you can't be too comfortable you
can't relax too early because if you
think it's for sure a draw from either
color honestly and then you know you may
Overlook a little something and now
you're slightly worse and you have to
find the draw once more so I think that
if you're fobby you are slightly worse
here White's pieces a bit more
coordinated and active but he is playing
natural looking moods bring his King up
the board B7 Pawn still should not be
captured and it was but I think that
just helps it's going to help Black's
cause
uh what a poor quality game I'm looking
at their accuracy scores it's 97.7 to
97.9 and we perhaps look at a game that
doesn't feature a mistake on every move
oh wait what whoa
what is happening here
whoa do you see the top engine move
Robert I don't have it open but I can
click you are you sitting on your chair
like firmly
the top the top engine move in this
position for black is Knight E6 to G5 I
thought it was a glitch
that is the top engine move sacrificing
the Knight and then trapping The Rook on
G5 with F5 and H6 that would have been
crazy no that that is one of those moves
where you're like um Fabiano I know we
say your engine like but I think we have
to do another fair play street by the
way all players have multiple cameras on
the new fair play sweeps before uh being
allowed to be in the competition so I'm
just joking on that front but Knight G5
there that would have been absolutely
ridiculous
and Gawain Jones playing H4 but I can
guarantee you he didn't just play H4 to
stop Knight G5 this is just a very
common Pawn structure Arrangement across
all end games you want your pawns
arranged diagonally the way my coach
explained it to me many years ago is in
the event of a rook end game where both
sides are taking each other's pawns when
you put your Pawns in a staggered
position like this it's harder to
capture them in all in one Fell Swoop of
course you're also grabbing important
space and restricting the pawn mobility
of your opponent so the position remains
pretty equal Robert but with both Rooks
active there's a certain tactical
component to it and if one side loses
their a pawn then we'll have stuff to
talk about yes but that's you know maybe
a little bit far away it does seem
pretty level so do you think we have a
moment done it perhaps to change games
and look at one of the other superstars
in the competition
we absolutely do we've got a pretty
crazy position on the top board between
artemiev and narianan but I'll give you
the final say some positions are still
in their middle game stage but okay Cena
mobile head I got excited I thought he
was up a piece but then I realized he's
down in exchange so the young Iranian
will lose his first game to Vladimir
fedesev
yeah so let's just just shoot that new
game Donna you choose and okay it seems
like you picked artemiev against nariana
that whoa the evaluation is going up and
up and up and is that because there's
some kind of Knight G4 Knight H6
checkmating threat
oh Knight G4 and then Knight H6 and
queen h8
yeah so what's the material count right
now what yeah what happens if black just
plays Knight takes C6
um oh it's Knight takes G6 and queen h8
made oh my gosh you know it's funny and
I saw it I would I was so like looking
forward to that Knight G4 Knight six
trying to see if it's actually a mate
that yeah Knight takes G6 is a one move
tactical shot that's it oh my goodness
I'll show this on the board Robert just
for uh the Tactical Fanatics Among Us
Knight takes C6 looks like a draw right
if white plays Knight takes C6 black
doesn't recapture the Knight black takes
the Rook first then recaptures the
Knight and it's basically a dead drop
but no after Knight takes C6 whoop
Knight takes G6 lpdo and if you play
Rook takes E3 a Checkmate on h8 really
beautiful how these combinations arise
out of nowhere and that is why Gladys
love artemi have put his work on E3 so
that when he moves the Knight black
cannot capture The Rook with check it
would have been a check if the Rook were
still on E1 crazy stuff stuff that we're
expected expecting from a player like
Gladys love artemiev but we got a whoop
out of it so I'm pretty pumped that we
went to that game uh but yeah this does
look like at this point uh pretty clear
should be a clear win for our team now
Knight G4 uh probably leads to Checkmate
although there is Rook D1 check so I
maybe I'm speaking a little too soon
because that would actually be a mistake
as after maybe we can just quickly point
out that 19451 drags the king up to G2
and queen takes C6 the follow-up is
check forcing the Queens off the board
just in time so then white wouldn't be
able to deliver the main
yep and I'm trying to make an illegal
move three times in a row just
just to show everybody how effective a
check can be the queen trade is forced
and this is how thin the margins are
right you think the game is over but you
need to demonstrate tactical vigilance
really until the very end of the game so
vladislav is going to take a little bit
of time
he does in fact convert his Advantage he
played C takes B7 converting a tactical
Advantage into a material one he will be
up a full Pawn in the end game but
Robert I really think the big reason
Black's position is indefensible has to
do with the long-term weakness of the
king white has so many prospects for his
Knight the queen can jump into E5 I
don't see Aryan on defending this in the
long run no I don't either so we can
trust our temmie Evan I thought we could
trust the game between gawaine Jones and
five in the Quran it's just be a draw
but I'm not so sure anymore so things
have happened in that game done if you
want to go back to see what Fabi is up
to because he's down upon but he is the
initiative against that white king
unbelievable black is better here how do
these top players always seem to do that
edron position symmetrical first he act
as Rook now he sacks the a pawn now
Robert I said that the first side to win
the opposing Apon is gonna be on the
winning end I think the opposite might
be the case so what's going on here not
only are blacks three pieces Ultra
active but the F2 Pawn is hanging and
what Gawain might have missed from a
distance is that if he had played King
G2 there was a very very nasty check on
F3 and he played King G1 that's another
blunder Abby's winning
no way I mean look at this King on G1
right it looks like oh it's safe it can
always go to H2 or G2 but I think right
now the after this white is going to
play Rook A4 and that would hit both
pieces in a row on the fourth rank then
the Knight slides in F3 would check and
bat over to E5 and then Bishop slides
into F3 and then all of a sudden we're
seeing the Contours of a mating attack
with that Rook on C2 ultimately landing
on H1 that would deliver the death now
and now he's gotta find one more
maneuver he's got to play Knight F3
check Circle back to E5 in order to keep
the bishop protected and then the
mechanism you just described Robert is
going to sound the death now for White's
King so best move here is to play Knight
F3 Chuck don't play Bishop F3 because
White's Bishop could still cover a first
ranked check on F1 but Abby's gonna find
this he's got no other choice
um yeah I'm trying to come up with other
ideas for black and oh
wait he threw you rushed to check
yeah and I maybe you want a knight E2
check here because if white takes the
Knight then Bishop takes wins material
but of course white would not take that
92 and it said move the king away so we
see in the game the Knight went to uh is
going to F3 instead of to E2 but yeah
this position is just messy and somehow
white would hold on White's surviving
here I was just showing what happens
after 92 check Fabi might have assumed
that white has to take the Knight but no
he doesn't because the lateral attack on
the bishop so you're pointing out Robert
Knight F3 check was played King G2
Bishop back to D7 so Fabi clearly still
playing for a win still trying to set up
a mating pattern along the long diagonal
but white it appears can block this
attack with Bishop B5 that's exactly
what Gawain Jones just did this is the
live position and Fabi is running out of
attacking ideas
yeah it's one move can change the entire
nature of the position and the
complexion really has changed where
black look coordinated and ready to
deliver a Checkmate and now Black's
pieces are all over the place there's
like a knight on E1 a rook on the C1 the
bishop on D7 uh there's trades being
offered both of whites minor pieces can
be captured but if you take the Knight
on C3 you lose the bishop on D7 and
let's not forget that white is up a pawn
so if Fabi has more imprecision that
could really be a problem for him
wow yeah Fabi might want to consider
repeating moves here Robert precisely
for that reason you make one in cautious
move like Rook takes Knight you allow
Bishop takes bishop and gawain's the one
who's gonna be declining a drop because
at that point white could even give up
is F2 Pawn Without Really fearing uh
that he will succumb to a checkmating
instruction but oh Fabi continues to
play for a win he plays Bishop E6 he had
a repetition in his pocket there he
still does with Knight F3 and 91 but I
think he's gonna keep it going right a
milk White's clock down even further
Gawain down now to two and a half
minutes and the less time you have the
harder it is to defend a position like
this
yeah and 92 The Rook slides over to B1
please don't blunder your rook and now
that Bishop B5 is loose so uh both sides
have pieces on squares that may not be
optimal but I don't see the mating net
anymore and I do think that going is
done a really nice job of
you know being on the verge of fully
surviving this
indeed if he moves his Bishop which
hopefully he will do he defended it with
his Knight I'll be continuing to Chisel
into White's position hither and thither
Goes The Rook it goes back to the second
rank but at this point it's one move
threats and Gawain should be able to
deal with them although I would still be
terrified here Robert after something
like King G1 black and go Bishop H3 and
set up more mating threats I think the
biggest X Factor here might be White's
box situation he's down in 90 seconds
now and every move is taking him a good
chunk of time
and that becomes a problem but there is
a two second increment you get two
seconds added to your clock with each
and every move you make but that's just
two seconds and you may need two minutes
to calculate some of the tactics and
right now going is burning more clock
and down in the F2 Pawn it's loose The
Rook at A4 can slide over to F4 but
maybe your knight in Bishop
configuration over there on the queen
side they are protected for now but
maybe if you're going Now's the Time
just secure the draw and say I I will
realistically not win this game I just
need to make sure I don't lose
for sure I really like the look of Rook
F4 forget the Apon you're not you're
very unlikely to win this game I think
King G1 is a viable alternative I'm not
sure what's worrying him it might be
Bishop H3 it might be Knight F3 check
you start seeing ghosts when you're this
low on time and you're facing someone
this strong but I think Owen is knocking
on the door of a very solid round one
draw not a big upset he's got the white
pieces but just a couple of moves away
here from from signing those Peace
Accords after all
okay well I'll keep an eye on this game
or the Wayne Drop into 20 seconds uh are
there any other games that are catching
your eye there's a crazy game between
lamenti sichev and Maxima shellegrab not
sure who that is it's a relatively new
Young up-and-comer Grand Master so I'm
gonna flip to that game where Clementi
is playing on his last seconds but
Robert he is up in exchange and he is
definitely better on the board
okay so he has four seconds and went all
the way down to zero for uh Split Second
there everybody must have made a quick
move to gain a couple and what is
happening the I'm counting pieces really
quickly white is up in exchange but
black has
two pawns for that exchange so black has
Knight and two pawns for a rook and
whose King is weaker I think White's
King is weak
White's King is definitely weaker
although he put his King on G2 which I
think is a very reasonable move given
the clock situation although you have to
be very careful Bishop takes F2 and
queen takes G3 is a possibility once
this Rook moves out from C2 and it looks
like Clementi with his last seconds is
just kind of trying to make moves and
avoid blunders and that's a very
dangerous strategy because Maxime is
continuing to improve his position you
might go H5 you might go D4 at some
point you got to be really careful about
opening up the diagonal for a White's
Bishop really hard to assess this
position
yeah and the Knight back to D6 it looked
like it received a question mark not the
best move but maybe a good move in your
opponent's time trouble because you know
also I love the standings I see them
flipping as people uh gain a victory and
we see new names entering the top of the
leaderboard but the Knight back to E4
and
what is happening here down here
I'm just as clueless as you are okay D3
is not possible and VL plays H5 which is
a move I really really like you give
your king a Luft Square on H6 so Queen
F7 isn't as scary of a threat but I
would still play Rook f8 and White's
running out of helpful moves so you
might see Clementi just sort of going
Rook D3 back to F3 instead he drops back
to C2 he's still very much playing for a
win Robert trying to Target this Knight
maybe The Rook should slide to E8 and it
does but there goes White's Rock up it
goes and Bishop takes E4 is a deadly
threat
yeah because now what is all the
Firepower aiming at that 994 and by the
way Maxime is down under uh 30 seconds
himself right at this moment so yeah
it's a tough position for him I don't
like his chances anymore
how do you defend against Bishop takes
E4 and F takes E4 Rook takes E4 if black
has to give up his Queen I think the
king is a little bit too wide open for
Black's position to be defensible veal
down to 10 seconds he doesn't know what
to do
how can he I mean this position is
really really rough and hope the moves
have come in very fast but white has a
Winning Edge
and he's given up his Knight on e4 he's
still down in exchange he's got to try
D3 here only source of counter play is
that past d-pawn but Clementi takes the
pawn and Bill drops his Bishop back and
he resigned and what a result
yeah I mean Maxim he was ahead in the
clock his position was hanging on by a
thread and you know he can't play for
time in these events because the two
second immigrant does add up and
clementi's uh sidechev he is like a 2900
plus Blitz player he can play on just
his winning seconds
you can indeed and I'll flip to one of
the last remaining games where Sam sevy
and another favorite is also struggling
mightily against another one of those
good Blitz players solid GM's auntie
berkich and burkich is completely
winning up two Pawns in this end game
about to force the Queens off the board
and with plenty of time to convert the
ensuing Knight vs Bishop end game Robert
whoa
yeah it just looks great although
and there's no other I'm trying to come
up with some hope yeah there's although
nothing
the king will run around to G7 you don't
have a Perpetual maybe you can try Queen
A3 check he's trying Queen E3 check but
that's not good enough the king's just
gonna circle around to G7 this is
resignable
yes and berkich made a name for himself
in the last fide World Cup the next one
is starting in like a week from now but
berkich eliminated some higher rate
opposition in previous World Cup so he's
a very strong Grandmaster even if his
rating is not as high as Sam sabians so
Robert the only thing for black to avoid
here is to stalemate whites King every
Schoolboy knows that you want to avoid a
situation where you put your queen on G3
when White's King is on H1 why can maybe
try Queen G3 Queen takes G3 King H1 here
I would try a Rosen trap here
shamelessly if I were Sam sebian
yeah he's not gonna get the opportunity
to do that but here at Knight G4 queen
of two and I was at Queen H2 to trade
Queens but Queen F1 looks like Checkmate
and that's what was played
that is a brutal loss suffered by sam7
with the white pieces but the good news
that's a pretty long event Robert you
can lose round one we've seen
hikaranakamura lose round one in RCC
type events and then come back with room
to spare and qualify to the top group so
these top players they're used to
adversity they're not gonna cry over a
single loss
no they won't cry but it hurts and your
tie breaks suffer so if there's a big
tie like when you said with six nap
points or six points fighting for that
eighth spot so you can get into the
match for division one your tie breaks
won't be good if you lose the first
round but there is time to come back
Maxine vashilograph he can go and win
seven games in a row the competition is
fierce but he does have a shot
and we like to focus on the games where
the top guys are having difficulty but
there were also a lot of smooth wins a
lot of Mercedes as I pointed out very
smooth victory over a difficult opponent
the young Iranian Fina Phenom Cena
mobile head and Vladimir kramnik you ran
through
that was like a Mack truck running over
a small car that was not even close the
Vladimir off to a one out of one start
will definitely Spotlight him in round
two or he's gonna face a very difficult
opponent with the black pieces this time
and I just caught the uh I thought the
round was over but there was just one
game going and I saw Alexi Serrano beat
Neil's granddelius with black I mean
think about that matchup serrana
grendelius Niels Grand dealius 2650 plus
Alexis Serrano 2680 plus like these
players are very closely rated and those
first round matchups as you said before
the show began uh very juicy from the
start and now we're in round two with
even juicier matchups yeah I was gonna
say we've got Nicholas theodoro up on
the top boards I flipped on Frederick's
vane not Rasmus vane which is a more
household name but his brother recently
became a GM as cross 2600 and is
incredibly promising as a very different
style Robert this is what I think is so
amazing Rasmus his brother
superpositional always plays 1d4 Ryder
Rick is a crazy player one E4 to his
dying day and Vladimir kramnick saying
you want to play E4 young man I'll give
you a sicilian how about that how about
them apples yeah and krummick you know
he's venturing into a more combative
territory it's an early round here he
has done well in Rapid online events uh
you know he does not like it when
there's no increment the moral
degradation hurts his soul but we're
back in a Escape in England sorry Bick
uh we can't pronounce this very well
I did a YouTube video recently and I got
a lot of comments like I'm from scriven
again and you mispronounced it Young
American fellow we don't have that sound
in our vocabulary but we try our best
and it's a classical Sicilian and now
chromica decided to strike with E5 so
this is a critical moment in this game
because black often wants to carve that
E5 Square out for his pieces but after
this night trade this Pawn on C6 even
though it might be isolated after fb5de5
then the Knight on C3 is dominated by
the pawn three squares away so they're
always pluses and minuses to each and
every trade
there most certainly is and white can of
course push the pawn over to F5 I think
a lot of less experienced players are
tempted by that this king's Indian
attack style idea with G4 G5 the problem
and another benefit of this Pawn on C6
is that it can support the pawn break D5
so white isn't gonna even get off the
ground before black starts massacring
him in the center so I think Frederick
can keep the tension he can play up take
C5 and you often see white playing Moves
Like Queenie one Queen G3 the king
sometimes slides over to H1 so that if
black ever brings his Queen out to B6
that move no longer comes with a check
and it takes a lot of the sting out of
the attack against B2
right yeah B2 is one of those pawns that
you're happy to grab but not if it comes
at the cost of your king side and so I
look at these positions F takes E5 very
tempting but after d takes E5 black has
to isolate C Pawn white has the isolated
E Pawn I typically like having more
Pawns in the center but an open f file
is often worth it to White so yeah Diana
these decisions these little moments
they may seem insignificant but they
actually might tell the tale of who will
have the upper hand in this game and not
to change the subject but one thing that
struck me Robert I played Vladimir in a
three plus two Bliss match uh a month or
so ago and it's that he actually plays
quite fast in Rapid chess and Blitz
chess yeah when we get down to a Time
scramble that might not be his favorite
aspect though uh online chess to put it
mildly but when you actually watch him
in early middle games what struck me is
how much I was down on the clock almost
every game Vladimir has such a good
understanding of so many different types
of positions and he harnesses that to
build up a big time Advantage he's
actually very difficult to play and I
think Frederick sensing that he's not as
familiar with these positions bailing
out with a queen trade but the end game
is obviously still very combative very
unbalanced and I think you put it very
well is Black's poor Pawn structure
going to be the deciding factor or is it
blacks relatively uh well-placed night
and the fact that White's Knight on C3
is tremendously restricted really
interesting Rich end game here
can we just talk about how instructive
that was you may think what did Vladimir
do why didn't he take that Queen on d8
sooner he was really calculating which
pieces are better because it is Bishop
we're on d8 maybe that Bishop would
slide to B6 to offer a trait of dark
Square Bishops and fix Black's Pawn
structure taken with a rook on d8
challenges for an open file so that
makes sense as well so I just really
want to give a shout out to Vladimir for
not rushing that decision a lot of us
would take instantly we would have
pre-moved but that was a moment that was
worthy of calculation I think that's
what the best players do is they don't
take any position for granted it's not
just like okay whatever it's equal no
matter what it's like well let me see
how I can possibly get an interesting
chance if I take with one piece versus
another so I thought that was pretty
cool to see from Vladimir right there
and I'm always trying to learn when I
come dude I'm trying to help the
audience learn but I myself feel like
that kind of moment where I wouldn't be
sure necessarily but I probably would
just rush a decision because who cares I
like to see that from the top players
automatic moves right we don't even
realize how many assumptions we make I
pause on this position because I think a
big reason kramnik didn't take with the
bishop consists in this move Knight C3
to A4 trading on White's own terms and
unfortunately after Knight takes E4 no
white doesn't take the Rook that's
illegal white takes the bishop first
hits the other Rook with the Knight and
unfortunately black can only recapture
one minor piece at a time and both Rooks
are hanging so I'm pretty confident that
this is the line Vladimir kramnik
calculated and this swayed him in the
direction of Rook takes d8 but your
point Robert is very well taken these
top players they don't make any
assumptions they never take anything for
granted and they realize that the moment
we make an automatic move is oftentimes
the moment that we miss a good
opportunity to turn the game around and
guess what Second Time Around ramnik
took with the bishop and I think we're
gonna see that Bishop land on B6 I think
black is doing really really well in
this end game at this point
yeah Bishop B6 fixes Black's Pawn
structure in the event of a trade Bishop
A5 goes right after the E4 pawn and you
try to compromise White's Pawn structure
on the queen side so multiple options
for that darkship the A7 Pawn is
actually under attack if you give white
a free move Bishop takes A7 is actually
a threat because the bishop on d8 is
loose Only The Rook on a defending it
indeed and Vladimir with another think
in this critical moment trying to figure
out the best way to employ his bishop or
perhaps to trade it off of course white
can meet Bishop B6 with King F2 and we
start getting this tug of war Battle
where both sides are trying to engineer
the trade on their own terms so as
Vladimir kramnik Ponders uh his next
move we will keep checking back into
this end game as it heats up further but
we've got a lot of other amazing
matchups Aviano caruana I think won his
first round against gawaine Jones uh who
got a little bit too low on time and he
faces Russian Grandmaster Alexander
rahmanov in a very interesting Sicilian
so I flipped that game no this is not a
sicilian This was oh it was but it
wasn't a conventional one you won't
believe what Sicilian this was a
nimsovich variation which is E4 C5
Knight F3 and then Knight F6 a favorite
weapon of this uh Grand Master Alexander
rahmanov and uh
has played that before it's quite tricky
but you can trick yourself because if
you look at this position White's King
there it's got bubble wrap around it
with all those pawns four of them
effects but the black king is stuck in
the center and Fabiano is thinking how
do I improve my position uh one move
that comes to mind or Irish is an idea
is H4 to H5 just to cement Black's Pawn
structure in place another move is Rook
to G3 saying to that Bishop on f8 are
you sure you want to develop because G7
would be loose and so I feel like there
are several ways to play this position
for white you could also think about
playing G4 and then try to get G5 later
so there are several options for white
and he starts with Rook G3 I like that
the most because I think freezing your
opponent is a really good idea
especially in quicker time patrols but
what is actually Black's plan because if
you play A4 as black white happily plays
B4 and shuts that side of the board down
and to piggyback off of your bubble wrap
analogy Robert is Queen C7 is played oh
that blunder's Rook takes D5 Rook takes
D5 wins the game on the spot because of
this devastating follow-up check on the
all my how long did that take him one
second two seconds Fabiano's like I eat
this kind of stuff for breakfast
yeah he doesn't even have the eval bar
at his disability he just has his big
old brain and he takes the Knight opens
the E file and you can't take that's
clear because Bishop takes D6 Pawn takes
is checked both to the king from the
queen on E2 and to the queen on C7
thanks to that pawn and D6 and actually
you might just get checkmate I might
even take your queen but yeah like
that's it makes matters worse but if you
go King E7 I don't think you take this
Rook on CA a lot of us are attempted to
get our material back sure what would
have an advantage there but I think
white can play with like Queen F3 and
just go straight for the black king
because look there are no Defenders
around it the Rook on h8 not playing
apart the bishop on f8 stuck at home and
this looks like a very one-sided affair
Queen takes D5 going to be the follow-up
this is happening Knight King E7 played
Alexander Romanov does not want to
suffer uh anymore I think he's going to
resign if Fabi finds when Fabi finds
Queen F3 obviously Queen H5 is also
possible but black can meet that with G6
you could drop back to F3 then if you
really want to be clinical that opens up
another pathway for the queen and that's
the kind of stuff we see top players do
Robert right we could roll our eyes at
that and say well what's the need to be
that precise doesn't Queen F3 win and it
does these top players are so used to
demanding Perfection from themselves
Bobby particularly for younger players
he's taking his time he sees Queen F3 he
knows it wins the game but he's spending
that extra 30 seconds making sure that
he's not allowing any unnecessary
chances I tell that to my students who
play a little bit too fast when they
sent the win as close at hand even
people like Fabiano caruana take more
time than they need to make sure that
they don't let the win slip from their
grasp yeah I think this is super
instructor active and they just don't
play without thinking maybe sometimes
they calculate very quickly so they
think in half a second but it's not just
making a move with their hand they are
using their brains and so Queen H5 it
may be more precise based on what you're
saying G6 Queen back to F3 now you also
have the F6 Square to infiltrate so I I
like that point by you Dania I think
that Fabi is going to try to be
completely accurate here and that way he
can end the game in say four moves
rather than going down a path that will
require 20.
and obviously he's not going to take
forever he's going to leave himself a
good amount of time and he does in fact
play Queen F3
yeah rahmana responds with F6 as we
expected and now the simple Queen takes
D5 just poses Unstoppable threats to the
black thing if I may show one really
pretty line Queen takes D5 already on
the board if black plays F takes C5 oh
okay Queen takes C5 check is made into I
was thinking you go Queen F7 check Rook
G6 check and Bishop B3 but isn't this a
slightly prettier mate and Robert I
always love in these situations to point
out the role played by a seemingly
random Pawn were that pawn not on C3
where that bubble wrap not in place
black would have been living to fight
another day after King to B4 as it
stands
black is checkmated but obviously we
need five and Knight F7 is another
pretty mating construction look at
Black's pieces Heming in his own gang
lacking development and that move Rook
G3 that Fabi played just as we tuned in
that was want to keep that Bishop on f8
stuck at home and now Queen oh he takes
on F6 oh it's good everything's good
enough he's gonna go rookie three check
uh then rookie eight same idea I think
he's just so winning Donya that pretty
much every move that didn't drop a queen
would have won him the game
and another instructive point a lot of
people when they watch these types of
games with the engine they think of
Moves Like EF as a huge mistake but
after King D Knight F7 blackened
resigned because black is down a full
minor piece in the end game there's
nothing left to play for and so rahmanov
is going to let his King get checkmated
he's going to resign in this position
what a game what an attacking game a
Fabiano caruana so instructive
and so different from his first round
game where he probably shouldn't have
won that he wasn't really better it was
he was down to pawn but it's pretty much
even material and then in game two he's
like let's change up the style I have
the white pieces and he went for the
crush so a nice game from Fabi we'll see
more of him in this event uh where to
next you picked Pharaoh save against
Theodore ruin the eval Bar says equal
slightly better for black but I'm trying
to equal
wait what okay Black's up a pawn someone
vomit all over the chessboard I'm like
whoa let out all the minor whoa oh
double Knight takes F2 just happened
explain that to me Dunder what's going
on here
uh my guess is as good as yours
originally I thought his ideas Queen
takes D2 check and it is
okay so it's a long-term peace Sacrifice
by Nicholas Theodore I think actually
his logic is very simple he was up a
pawn when we tuned in so Knight takes F2
offers him sorry no material is equal so
he's won two pieces uh two pawns for the
minor piece right yeah
and he was up a pawn so he's not looking
for anything specific yeah this is how
complicated the position is can't even
calculate material what a commentator
but I think he's just gonna play Bishop
takes C2 drop his Queen back let's say
to D6 and he's gonna say listen gotta
pass b-pawn I've got the four on two on
the king's side and white has long-term
problems with his King
very practical there we go yeah and
actually we tuned in like just a move
late in the sense because black took
upon but walked into a pin so all of
this was more or less forced from
Theodore he had to find this series of
moves but now that we're in this
position so we've finally done our math
three pawns extra for black a night
extra for white that's about even right
each Pawn worth a point a night worth
about three but as we look at the clock
in particular and I'm looking at the
remaining pieces on the board I do feel
like Federal save is very good chances
to win the game despite the eval bar
being completely unbothered saying it's
level I look at this and say well what
is black going to do black kind of has
to sit still I don't see an actual idea
for theodoru maybe you want to trade one
pair of knights but I'm I'm thinking
that it's more difficult to play from
Theodora's perspective in this position
especially when you're down under two
minutes
that's a great point and if black ever
loses the beep on that still might be a
salvageable position with a four on two
but you're gonna have to suffer uh to
hold that for many many moves and with
only a two second increment you're never
going to be able to build up more time
than you have he's down to a minute 40.
better safe can also try to pose threats
on the king side you can see him
sticking a knight in the center pretty
menacingly he's already threatening
Knight C4 which will in fact allow him
to win that B6 spawn but you could also
Envision Robert the other night
potentially coming out to H5 and The
Rook could almost play a defensive role
blocking a check with the queen on T2 uh
from E2 and blacks Knight at the present
moment is fully restricted by White's
pieces I really like the way that
Vladimir is coordinating his pieces and
starting to pose very unpleasant threats
both to the b-pawn and to Black's King
Nicholas as a tough defensive task ahead
of him and even Knight C3 can be
considered in this position yeah it's
difficult to answer this question what
trades does black want a queen trait
probably helps the defensive task but
you probably want a queen trick and a
nitrate after that because two nights
can be very very tricky not just because
you might miss a fork and a scramble but
because they can team up on certain
squares and pawns so I I do think that
the ideal set of trades for black is
getting those Queens off the board and
then also getting a pair of knights off
the board and then finally I think
Nicholas can feel more comfortable in
his quest to make a draw
and he's also an excellent Blitz and
bullet player so you know he will really
make these minute and 22 seconds count
we'll keep an eye on this game but I'd
like to return Robert if we made to the
kramnik game because we have major
developments there and these
developments I thought were favoring
black but upon closer examination I
actually think that Frederick savane
might be the one uh who is pressing for
a win I saw this Rook on B2 I saw this
Pawn in F4 and I saw the pressure of the
black and exert down the second rank so
can I be forgiven for thinking that
kramnik is winning and I'm biased of
course always in favor of the higher
rated player
you're completely forgiven and look at
how crumma just played that by the way I
was thinking wait what's wrong with Rook
takes C2 and things like that he says
it's more important for me to keep that
white Rook away from the defense of the
king if there was a rook takes G7 at any
point the G2 Pawn will be defended but
now in this position there's gonna be a
rook take C2 and maybe an F3 or a bishop
F3 or Bishop F1 and that white king
could feel exposed and a great reaction
from Frederick here because H4 if that
Bishop were not hitting the pawn on F4
G4 for black would be so scary but you
can't push the Jeep on without losing
the f-pawn so that's really really good
news for Frederick he wants to take on
G5 play Rook G7 to follow and get rid of
those black Pawns
yeah kramnik really trying his best to
generate winning chances but all of his
attempts were in Spain
and he's the one who has to worry about
holding a draw how are we gonna how is
the game gonna unfold here kramnick now
down to a minute yeah I said that he
plays fast but sometimes even the greats
need to spend some time to think he
plays F3 which I think is a good bailout
move he's trying to trade as many pawns
as possible he's gonna play Bishop takes
F3 Bishop takes E4 and when When the
Smoke Clears Robert I think we're likely
to get a c and an a pawn against a c
Pawn but with the opposite colored
Bishops should be a holdable position
for black but I'm starting to worry When
Vladimir falls behind a minute because
you know what that means oh
I jinxed him didn't I no I think you
just called it you said that it should
be this but you're worried about his
time and he took on H4 now white has
connected passwords and it's not just
that F5 F6 F7 a very direct Plan and
there's also pretty as long as you get
your Pawn to F6 white has great chances
to win the game because perhaps black
will have to sacrifice a bishop just to
stop that pawn from promoting this is
very worrisome for Vladimir here but I
think this is a big moment for Frederick
what move do you make I would move my
king but King G1 then Bishop F3 that
doesn't stop anything yeah you could get
made it I guess King H3 but that also
looks kind of scary because your king
doesn't have so many squares to go to
from there
yeah and you could be forgiven for
thinking that like King H3 walks into a
Checkmate but Frederick calculates the
variations King H3 on the board and F5
look at how precisely he is handling
this position he uses the F Pawn pushes
it up to F6 ties down Black's Bishop to
D5 and at that point the job isn't done
white might have to rely on his past a
pawn to really over extend Black's
defensive forces but definitely the
correct move here is F6 yes and you're
gonna win a piece I think by force
because even if the bishop comes a D5
yeah you get your Rook G7 check D6 check
then a rookie seven check it's actually
a very forcing sequence and
unfortunately for Vladimir
Frederick has two pawns remaining if you
could get that last Pawn rook and Bishop
versus Rook that is a theoretical draw
unfortunately a pawn will remain on the
board and that is why Frederick should
get this victory
and pausing at the right moment the
winning move and I won't make it on the
board we'll wait for him to carry out
the winning sequence it's pretty basic
Betty here yeah oh and he missed it he
played A4 which is the move I was
initially relying on it's still winning
but I guess I do have to show the
winning line at this point Robert I'm
pretty surprised he found the hard moves
and he and he missed the easy winning
sequence Bishop D6 rookie seven now you
can't go to f8 because the Rook drops
back with a discover check and after
King D and F7 no that's not the move
that's not the move because black can
eliminate all of White's pawns as you
had indicated so maybe that's the reason
rhetoric didn't go for the line you have
to throw in another check then come back
to E5 and only then you're ready to push
F7 yeah that would have been very hard
to find and instead the position we
currently have is this one
should still be a win for white what
work still required and he trades the
Rooks we like that decision I I think I
understand why he did it but the fact
that he's thinking after offering the
trade is strange you think before making
that trade and vitamin doesn't have time
so he probably will in fact lose this
game uh but that that
I think we're biased to an extent by the
eval bar I thought it was just winning
for white because eval bar off the side
said oh white just has this in the bag
but there was much more than met the eye
that I guess white could not actually
keep the Pawns in that variation we were
showing now white is essentially two
pawns ahead while black is one Pawn
ahead on the H file white is two pawns
ahead on E7 and A5 and that Bishop on E2
I think it has too much to do and that
way we can't handle everything
but what do you do what's the winning
strategy because the moment you inch
your king over to the other side of the
board black is going to use his h-man as
a deflection to get that E7 upon and one
spot gets C7 the king might be able to
make it to the promised land in time I
think Frederick is Treading Water kind
of his engine is idling he's trying to
find a zoo but King F6 always met with
H4
where's the win
okay so can I I want to put my king on
F6 but
yeah you're right this is very difficult
stuff
maybe you go C4 maybe you intercept the
bishop then take on H5 and maybe you've
got just enough Breathing Room between
these pawns but he takes the other route
and apparently that gives away the win
now c4 was an amazing move I think in to
some extent it makes perfect sense
you're trying to eliminate the past H
Pawn but it's also counterintuitive
because you want more pawns remaining at
least that's what you think of opposite
colored Bishops if I only have two pawns
remaining oh they probably should make a
draw but when you have split pawns and
bowling it stinks to have a split in end
games like this it's great to have a
split because it means that Black's
pieces cannot easily defend against A6
A6 he blundered A6 what an instructive
tactic that's a deflection of White's
own and the King going to circle around
to f8 when promotion will be unstoppable
Robert kramnik had to make a very
difficult move he had to play C5 with
the King still on E8 and putting the
pawn on a dark Square always a hard
thing to do with your last seconds A8
equals Queen is gonna follow and a
beautiful view beautiful winning tactic
that is a deserved Victory by Frederick
savane it wasn't smooth but I think he
earned it yeah you don't have to be
perfect in this time Patrol so he almost
let it slip but at the end he got the
job done he gets a victory over former
world champion Vladimir kramnik so a
nice win for Frederick he did have the
upper hand throughout he played some
really nice ideas and done it with me
with that in this round two is coming to
an end and we've seen some great chess
we have indeed and a couple of games
still trickling down to its conclusion
we have uh Nicholas theodoro who did
manage to hold that position uh against
Vladimir fedesaf so already crazy GM on
GM matchups Robert and the best news is
that we're only two rounds in we've got
seven rounds to go in the main
tournament oh yes we do so Dynamite will
take a short break some of these players
they'll stretch their own legs and get
ready for more action here at the Julius
bear generation cup playing we'll be
right back
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Julius bear
generation Cup this is the playing stage
as players buy for division one and the
other two divisions of the knockout
which will happen at the end of August
I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me
is Grandmaster Daniel narodiski done yet
we've had two excellent rounds in the
books and round three promises more
excitement as it's just Grand Master on
Grand Master action non-stop today
it's almost like a tournament Robert
where any Grandmaster is allowed to join
and you've got actual combative matchups
as early as round one I mean wouldn't
that be a pretty good series of
tournaments to hold maybe with like a
final somewhere after the tournaments
are completed I don't know just some
ideas that I had this morning while
waking up
your ideas are excellent on and off the
chessboard clearly and while we are
seeing that the third round is
commencing we saw some players like
Fabiano caruana go to two out of two
Frederick savane beat Vladimir krummick
to also join at the top of leaderboard
and you've chosen the matchup between
Lavon aronian and Alexi drev so it's
good to show Lavon for the first time
today he won his second round I was
keeping an outside eye on that it was a
really close game it was a tough battle
for him but he got the job done and now
he remains in a perfect score
he does indeed but that perfect score is
in Jeopardy at the hands of the very
experienced Russian GM the opening
expert Alexi drev who is no stranger to
online chess he played in almost every
RCC event last year and a two out of two
score is not easy to achieve in this
tournament I'm having a hard time
identifying the opening in this game
this was a sicilian believe it or not I
don't think that's obvious given the
pawn structure we have but this was an
opening that we know very well Robert a
delayed allopin which both of us are
pretty partial to
yeah it's funny because it looks like a
French defense based on Black's Pawn
structure the bishop on C8 but there's a
white Pawn on C4 how did that get there
usually it's back on C2 but it's because
it was an alapin with C3 Sicilian and
then the pawn did go up to C4 to kick
the black queen back so drayv you
mentioned he's an opening expert he's
been a second for uh Shakura mamajarov
and others he himself has been over 2700
he's well known for his prowess both as
an opening theoretician but also as a
speech as demon and here in this game
with the black pieces he's a bit stuck
and I think the reason he's stuck is
that Bishop on C8 not a very good piece
not a very good piece and if you try to
secure employment for the bishop with B6
then you're going to be resigning that
game after Bishop F3 the other Bishop is
making contact with the Knight so I
think it's a combination of two factors
the first as you said is the bishop the
second is your general lack of space and
your general lack of good squares for
your other minor pieces
in terms of fixing the situation I would
consider starting with the Knight B to
D7 obviously creating a one move threat
of E5 but white could simply drop the
bishop back to G3 and anytime you push
upon if B6 you open up the long diagonal
if you push E5 prematurely you give the
Knight a beautiful spot on F5 so instead
Alexi putting a bishop on D7 and I think
preparing to develop his Knight to C6 a
Black's position is solid but it's
definitely very cramped and rather
unpleasant and you know people think of
Lavon aronian as being this Maestro
tactical genius that he and he is that
but you know what's really annoying
about playing Lavon is he often plays
very quickly and his blistering pace is
especially problematic when he is
actually better he doesn't have to Bluff
he doesn't have to go for anything
speculative he just has more space his
Bishops are on excellent squares uh this
Knight on B8 is undeveloped it now has
moved up to C6 but now white can trade a
bunch of times and black has a bad end
game because if you just take on C6
twice you leave black with these split
pawns on the queen side and those are
isolated weaknesses that white can try
to exploit
and he can exploit it from different
directions right you can play Queens you
want to F3 you can put the queen on A4
and long term that's the key word when
you try to examine this position I don't
like having long-term weaknesses in
Rapid time control games because you're
gonna have to worry about them or many
many moves to come they're gonna have to
burn a lot of clock but Lavon taking a
fundamentally different approach he says
I'm the side of this base Advantage I
want to keep as many pieces on the board
as possible but Robert I still think
Alexi drev is breathing a small sigh of
relief he's crossed one hurdle he's
completed his development but now he's
got to guarantee better spots for his
pieces because Lavon he can stick a
bishop on D6 and he has a very simple
plan of putting a rook on D1 that's
exactly what Alexi Drive is trying to do
but can Lavon sneak in a little Bishop
takes C6 action here is that upon it
definitely is important I think we can
understand why Lexi went for this that
Grandmasters do not like to Suffer
Without space they'd rather give up
material and say at least I have some
activity for my own pieces but Bishop
takes C6 Bishop takes C6 from black
Bishop takes E5 objectively white is
better and this is why Lebron plays
Bishop G3 he's saying that the threat is
strong in the execution that this E5
pawn it sticks out maybe I can grab it
later I'm not at all claiming that that
was the best decision it's clear that
Bishop takes C6 but Bishop E5 was better
but I think that it just goes to show
that these high level players they just
want to control the Dynamics they don't
even want the material if it means that
their opponent is struggling to find
ideas Bishop V6 was a good idea Dania I
think that black is fixing the problems
of the position but the D5 Square the
light Square diagonal from F3 down to B7
Pawn I do still like White's position
agreed I think white can consider that
old plan of Queen E2 and Rook 81 but one
problem that Lavon faces here is that
the immediate Knight D5 is just not as
good as it looked because it doesn't
pose any threat so let's say he goes 95
Alexi doesn't have to overreact Bishop
takes D5 would be a terrible idea white
recaptures with the c Pawn You're Gonna
Lose the e-pawn the diagonal for the
white Bishop is expanded but Alexi can
play a move like Rook C8 here and guess
what Robert Knight C5 is on the board
Andrea does take a more drastic approach
he plays E4 and now you gotta be really
careful because Queen takes C7 might run
into Bishop D6 even that is not the end
of the story when the queen drops back a
lot of White's pieces are hanging but I
would sidestep that I wouldn't touch
that with a 10-foot pole and I would
just recapture with the Knight and the
fact that Alexi is thinking tells me
that he senses the danger here and he
does Recapture with a horsey but this
illustrates exactly what I've been
saying is that look at levon's position
he has the bishop pair the bishop on 3
now has a fully open diagonal and that's
why the Knight came out to F5 but what
Levant really wants and I think I'll
trade queens and play Bishop F4 maybe
bishop F4 first I'm not sure which is
better but he just wants to keep his
Bishop pair he'll play a rook to C1
maybe that Knight will go out to A5 or
C5 at the right moment but I feel like
in this kind of position that the bishop
pair that feels like a legitimate
Advantage even though the evaluation Bar
says come on and Black's not really in
big danger it's just slightly better for
white I think from a practical point of
view that the players look at this and
say no White's definitely better they
don't have the evaluation bar to look at
great call by You Queen takes d8 the
reason I think being Lavon wanted to
sidestep the possibility of Queen d8 to
B6 Alexi could have kept the Queens on
the board in the event of the immediate
Bishop F4 so he does exactly what doctor
has prescribed he takes his medicine he
keeps his Bishop pair and like you said
very easy ways to improve the position
for white eight super important
consideration in Rapid time control how
easy is it to make helpful moves that
make my position better here much easier
for white than it is for black I guess
black could play Rook ac-8 but maybe
that runs into Knight A5 whites rook's
just more effective because they play in
concert with the bishop pair and
particularly this dark squared Bishop
that really Lords over both sides of the
board white is squarely uh in the
driver's seat here and Lexi's still
suffering even though he's got a little
bit more space so the evil Bar says what
0.3 better for white is that what is
that 0.3
exactly you looked at this position like
let's say we were just playing a game I
feel like I would think and you can give
me your response but I would think that
white is like 0.7 better like this just
looks that good for white to me and I
think that's why Lavon went for this he
does not have the evaluation bar but he
knows that it's easier for him to play
he has a bishop pair no weaknesses and
that's why he decided not to take the
pawn because that position looks at
least a little more comfortable for
black even if objectively that was the
quote-unquote correct decision
and an excellent move by Lavon this is
where the bread is buttered for these
top players how many people would
automatically go Rook ac-1 I mean
including myself I thought that move was
automatic but no he plays Rook F to D1
now you might look at this and say it
doesn't matter he's just putting a rook
on a square but there's a lot of
tactical Precision that stands Behind
These mundane looking decisions in this
case he understands that the pawn is
Untouchable because of the back rank
mate white just takes on C4 delivers
made on d8 so draf has to waste the
tempo playing H6 now we're likely to see
Levon putting a knight on D4 a different
tactical way of defending the C4 Pawn
exchanging black strongest piece and
this is how you keep your advantage uh
to the size of what it currently is
I think it's growing because I think
black's decisions are becoming
increasingly difficult for instance if
you swap on D4 and The Rook lands on D4
E4 is loose that nine out of six where
do you think you're going if you move
anywhere you drop a pawn uh the C1
square is covered which is essential
because if black has any ideas of some
funny business of B5 you're not going to
deliver a background Checkmate there
thanks to the bishop on F4 I look at
this position I say clear Advantage for
Lavon and I think that this type of
position is one where white wins a very
good percentage of the time and a black
plays absolutely perfectly draft can
make a draw but he's down nearly three
minutes on the clock and he his opponent
is a bishop pair and there's going to be
an outside pass Palm potential for white
in fact you could just take on B5 twice
right now and black is in some danger
because the Bishops just thrive in this
command game
and White's always going to have
something to bank on that B2 Pawn which
can even sit on B2 but still terrorize
black for a very long time to come so I
would call this a 50 50 position I would
say maybe maybe even 60 chance that
Lavon wins given the time situation but
we'll keep a close eye on Alexi drive's
attempts to defend the position we've
got a couple of crazy positions Robert
on some of the other top boards if I can
flip to one of those crazy positions and
I'm trying to figure out if it's crazy
or if it's just losing for white maybe
you can help me out this is a game of
Eduardo to rizaga who you pointed out in
the pre-show as one of those dark horses
who can always punch above their weight
in these types of events and Igor
kovalenko really needs no introduction
incredibly strong Grand Master uh 2700
feet a and a great Blitz player as well
he's got the whole package and he's got
an extra piece but it's not the end of
the story is it no but I like what you
were saying there he's got the whole
package and an extra piece so if the
whole package wasn't enough uh then
thank you for the night in the center
but I think that white is relying on
some tricks and move like Bishop B7 is a
great one because you're just kicking
that Knight out of there and if the
Knight moves maybe black can throw in a
rook C8 start trading up pieces white
doesn't really have an attack white only
has one pawn and the pawn on G5 does
look pretty nice but what you really
need is that pawn to go up to G6 and
then the White Queen to somehow get on
the H file but that's just not happening
in fact Queen takes G5
but E4 is loose
and you might get checkmated on the H
file here I didn't even notice that the
H file is open there's no Pawn on H2 and
even if there was a Pawn on H2 this plan
would still be pretty effective
kovalenko though very patiently puts a
rook on E8 now he's ready for Queen
takes G5 and nothing remains of what
looked like an imposing initiative a
couple of moves ago but that was only
due to the placement of the Knight on C6
once it's gotten kicked away the
illusion of compensation has dissipated
and this should be a straightforward
tactical win for Grandmaster kovalenko
here and he'll go to a perfect three out
of three and one of the names that goes
under the radar but is able to thrive in
a competition like this he's a great
speeches player as you mentioned
formerly over 2700 In classical chess as
well so Rook C7 nice try you know there
are some tags here but it doesn't
threaten anything besides the A7 Pawn
because like everything is defended in
Black's position
I was playing Blitz with my friend Sasha
Bortnick a couple of weeks ago and he
made a move like that right a move that
makes a lot of noise and we were both
looking at it in awe and then about a
minute later I said wait there's no
threats like yes the move looks very
impressive but what does it actually
threaten and you know the funny thing is
I think the best movie is A5 you just
defend against the only threat that this
move poses and it's very important Rook
takes D7 was not a threat because the
black queen defends the Knight but
govalenko probably an even better move
get the bishop out of the purview of the
rook and now get the Rook off of the
seventh rank I think this is a
reasonable way to play but I'm not
enthralled with it Robert I think black
white can take and play Rook C1 and
maybe the other Rook can take a dip to
C7 whoa dg6 girl careful now afraid of
nothing and look at the C file the white
Rook has only the C1 square and none
others to work with because everything
look at that is under Black's control so
I think that
um if you're playing B3 just to kick the
bishop back I mean you can tell that
black is well ahead here so I'm good
with this one Donya I'm happy to move on
and I just wanted to point out that with
one I'm saying only in air quotes one
now for the two yes a panko is playing
the promise she they drew a game so
they're not even a perfect score and
they're playing each other that is how
ridiculously strong this competition is
and yeah looks to be winning with the
black pieces despite being down a couple
Pawns in the position
yeah it looks like a very young type of
position where he sacked a bunch of
Pawns what does he have in return first
of all you've got this incredibly
menacing past spawn on D3 but more
pressing or white is the fact that the
E7 Knight is teetering on the brink of
death if you play Knight takes G6 check
black simply slides up to H7 too many
threats Robert the queen will be hanging
the Knight will be hanging I think you
have to go Queen E3 and then black can
try to use the d-pawn in order to kick
the Rook away from E1 black can do that
here as well D2 and if the Rook moves up
from the first rank I think this classic
Rook C1 and Bishop C2 idea is going to
be decisive and
Jan has five minutes on the clock which
is absolutely typical absolutely typical
for napomnushi just plays Super quickly
and super well and here D2 that looks
like the game Ender
or rookie two sorry to cut you off
Robert he's just played it what a move
of course he did right he's trying to
win the Knight on E7 if you take on E2
it looks like black just blundered the
queen but black it's a new Queen with
check and then picks up that Rook on D7
so that was a great find by you and yeah
no problem she played it a half second
after you saw it
and Knight takes G6 just a single check
doesn't do anything we've pulled up the
analysis board here but that's basically
it you might say well White's obviously
not going to take on E2 but if white
takes on F5 then the Rooks are connected
this is the second idea of rookie 2 and
again it's an intermediate capture then
black captures on F5 Andre estepenko
with absolutely no moves is likely to
resign and with 50 seconds on the clock
this is what yanapanushi does too or you
have no position no time it's almost
blakey's World Champion Challenge
and he was almost world champion there
was a disappointing finish to that match
for him but he's won the candidates
twice he's an absolute monster and he is
about to get a victory against Andre
yesapenko nice win for Jan so we trust
him I think we can scoot on over to
another matchup by the way Jeffrey Zhang
is at two and a half out of three so I
see him there but what matchup is
catching your eye I'm sure some of these
games have changed quite a lot whoa well
I'm looking at Fabiano caruana who's
about to finish off Armenian GM shot
sarkison with black to get to three out
of three I'm looking at this position
and I was searching for an extra piece a
Pawn on the seventh rank for a shot I
didn't find neither the first thing nor
the second what I will find is a big
zero on the tournament cross stable for
black jot though he's still fighting
he's trying to manufacture threats
against the black king but look at that
defensive role played by the bishop I
love pieces like that minor pieces that
are so faithful both to the king and to
the pawn on D3 of Fabian bringing the
hammer down with a retreating move yeah
you were pointing the bishop 187 it
defends and attacks in a way by
protecting the D3 pawn and the C2 Square
after it as a Queenie does the same it
defends that last rank but also attacks
H5 with check black is only up two pawns
it looks like Black's up like four but
this is a completely winning position
and what would be very sad for white is
if you play King G1 because then black
would swap works like Queen E3 check at
the end and oh you know that would have
been devastating so here we see Bishop
E4 Fabi improving the location of his
Bishop putting pressure on G2 and I
think Sean relying on some time trouble
for Fabi to stay in this game I just
don't see how far we can go wrong here
he has plenty of time and he gets the
increment
yeah I think F5 comes to mind slicing
off the Queen's connection to the H5
fund once you pick up H5 it's all she
wrote I'll be taking a more head-on
approach he pushes the other F1 over to
F to F3 opening up White's King but also
after GF Bishop F3 the H5 Pawn would
have fallen shot doing his best to keep
as many pawns on the board as possible
but Fabi he can consider F5 even here
slicing off the connection between these
two pawns I like F5 a lot because
Black's King is actually quite safe
whites King is exposed and there are
many pieces around it threatening it so
F5 looks good I'm sure there are many
other winning moves but Fabi dropping oh
by the way shun offer to draw at some
point in this game which Fabi declined I
don't know when that draw was offered it
probably was earlier in the game because
around here it wouldn't even make sense
to offer it's clearly winning for black
that would be slightly obnoxious
wouldn't it and it really helps that you
can't Envision any scenario where white
gets a Perpetual check because even if
flax King asked to Hideaway NH 7 the G6
square is protected by Black's bishop
and black is a monopoly on the light
Square so Fabi can move the queen away
from the eighth ring it's done its job
and you never have to worry about any
sort of shenanigans along the eighth
rank or on the G6 Square this one should
be over momentarily it should be and by
the way Frederick's funny beat Min late
to go to a perfect three out of three so
beating kromnik and Min back to back
it's a great start but we're only a
third of the way through in this Swiss
part of the plan
yeah and Min late actually blundered a
night fork in one move so he moves on
the two out of three uh kovalenko still
converting that extra piece against
Eduardo youtubersaga I think we will
leave uh Fabiano caruana to play the
last couple of moves of this game he's
got 20 seconds but that does not add to
the Intrigue of this game he could win
this with two seconds on his clock and
he's used to doing that from all of his
title Tuesdays so I'm gonna flip on to
maybe the game of Joker a mamidyarov who
is in a rook end game alireza farouza uh
also won his game against Constantine
lupulasco so I'm pretty sure he's got
two and a half out of three as well
Valkyrie art and I have a hard time
converting this extra Pawn against
craftive I think this one's a draw
and that it was a crafty last move there
by Martin because H6 was a really good
move because it looks weakening just you
know to some extent the G6 Pawn now can
become a Target but the problem is the
white Rook is frozen because the E3 Pawn
would fall with check and if you take
the B3 Pawn which is what white wants to
do then black plays G5 so he does does
go for the G6 Pawn black does 10 seconds
and that's oh oh
he tricked that was a mistake he had to
go G5 first to be able to play B2 later
Robert Now The Rook can capture on B2
travel upwards to B6 and basically Force
Black's King onto an awkward spot
there's a very instructive
zigzaggy kind of mechanism that I think
uh Fabiano Jacques is going to put into
practice here
and he's thinking see I like what he's
doing he is using the clock as a weapon
but after B2 is like let me be accurate
here because Rook takes G6 check allows
King to F5 and the F4 Pawn will drop you
cannot afford if to lose the F4 Pawn if
you want to win this game so Rook takes
B2 he just played it the black Rook
slides over but now after Rook B6 check
where is the final infiltration going to
come from
it's gonna come from the seventh rank
he's gonna go Rook Beast I thought he's
gonna go Rook B7 check and then Rook to
g7s instead he goes H5 and I think this
is also winning he just has to sidestep
the lateral checks by the black girl and
he can do that using the F1 as an
umbrella he can zigzag around to the G
file and eventually black is gonna have
to play GH Robert and when black plays
GH white gets the advanced and connected
passers that should decide the game
maybe Martin can try G5 here and he does
he is fighting to the last drop of blood
but look at that Rook F6 check and then
F5 because otherwise Rook F4 check would
have won the F5 Pawn that's not a pawn
that white wants to give so F6 is that
two connected past pawns and I I think
this is a really instructive end game
that H5 move it goes to show that we
think about Chess as okay well I'm up a
pawn but I think it's important to look
at end games as white was up two pawns
connected and then black would have been
up a pawn because you want connected
past pawns the end game this is
completely over Mama Jones with the two
and a half and a three but that's how I
often look at these positions that if I
can get two connected past part of them
essentially up two pawns that's what
white is up two pawns here and black is
up two Pawns in the hng file
yeah you have to section off the board
you always like to divide the board uh
into various parts and that makes the
position a lot less overwhelming to
evaluate that's often the only way that
you can approach certain end games I'm
looking around the horn here there are a
couple of move of games still left most
of them in their end game stage Pablo El
yanov has a pretty crazy time scramble
here against Alexander castenuk who is
trying to avoid losing her Queen and she
is being successful here this might be a
draw
yeah Don was the queen don't want us the
bishop and they're connected with one
another by the way Alexandra at one and
a half of the two both these players are
about Pablo but a 2700 level not much of
a surprise for Alexandria we know she
can punch up but a one half out of two
star for her is fantastic and right now
it's one of these positions where oh I
either side can win this game it should
be a draw but you see them sort of both
prolonging this game and that King on D2
I feel like that's a great piece
especially if the Queens come off the
board
and Pablo is the one declining the
repetition and I think the reason is
because Black's King is just more unsafe
so it's likelier that Alexander blunder
something along a diagonal but she's
playing very carefully keeping her Queen
and her King close in order to avoid an
unexpected skewer and that Queen on D4
Robert was dominating all of the
potential checks by the White Queen
that's what she's trying to do she's
trying to eliminate the possibility of
any checks and as long as she can keep
her Queen active I think this one should
be
should end in peace although you never
know maybe Queenie one shot oh Queen C5
would have won the pawn wow wait Queen
B6
oh that's scary Queen B6 is definitely
something that was overlooked and I just
want to note that Alexander krsenic beat
Parham muksulu in the first round so
she's already beaten one super GM why
not make it two uh but look at this
they're both sides a bit nervous here
white is down under four seconds and
needs to be careful one second he's
gonna move and he's making moves with
one second left on the clock he gives a
check on e4 pinned pieces protect you
couldn't have taken that Queen But Here
Comes the black king
and she might win that a pawn and if she
wins the able
oh she's allowed it
oh my gosh and that's a win for Eliana
if you mentioned this idea before she
completely overlooked it and El yanov in
a mutual time scramble takes the point
and moves two and a half out of three
no way and Robert the earlier instance
of Queen B6 wasn't quite as deadly
because black was actually able to block
with her Queen but with a king sitting
on a different color Square Alexandra
had to take the queen and moreover she
couldn't even give the bishop up for the
B Pawn because if she had been able to
do that as one Robert Hess would point
out why does the wrong color promotion
Square for the h-man bad luck if the
pawn was on A5 black would have had
Bishop A6 and would have been able to
draw the game but that's just the way
the cookie crumbles when you're playing
Super Grand Masters you always don't
seem to catch that last break what a
heartbreaker yeah that hurts and she was
playing a great game she's had a very
nice tournament thus far and she'll look
to recover in the next one I just
watched rude makarin he rudic makaran
but um just the comments just rud for
short he won his game with black against
uh nasuta from Poland so yeah this round
is coming to conclusion and that means
we're about to get into round four and
Daniel know I'm glad that we're not
there yet but I just want to be honest
with the audience that coming up in a
few rounds people will start making very
quick draws
for sure and that's understandable given
the tournament situation these players
primary Allegiance is to qualify to the
top group that they can so they're going
to make whatever decision maximizes that
potential and we won't uh stick around
in case a game ends in a draw we will
always find a combative game on the
lower boards and that's often why on the
last rounds Robert and I've pulled up
the last remaining game here a rook end
game that's very likely to end in a draw
we're not a Terry incredibly household
name at this point he's gonna hold this
position against Aram hokobian but
there's always a game to look at there's
always somebody who has to win in order
to qualify and so that's the great thing
about these Swiss tournaments there's
never a shortage of combative games but
your point is we'll take we're on move
115 at the moment and I want to give
Ronaldo a shout out because this guy is
an IM on paper only thus far in this
very event as he looks to draw against
Grandmaster Ram Jacobian he's already
drawn for ruja and then he beat Jordan
Forest so uh you look I am title how is
he doing so well uh he's pretty darn
good he's well known in the quicker time
patrols here on chess.com and he's
having a great day this far and he
should not lose this game with best play
but I think the one concerning element
is that white Pawn is very far Advanced
and if this white king starts dancing up
the board I could see possible positions
where black gets a little bit nervous
and goes wrong
and there's a method behind Renata
Terry's madness here he's keeping his
Rook largely on the C or D files and
that is exactly the reason why it's
because in response to King D3 he would
be able to check with the other rook and
then quickly zip back to A8 so it's
amazing how the Rook on a actually does
play an active role in the defense we're
gonna see him go Rook C7 here working G6
sticking on these two files in a ROM
he's trying everything he's trying to
move up through the center he's trying
to lure black stroke out of C7 but thus
far he hasn't been successful
oh until now he can play Rook A1 oh he
could have ladder checkmated oh ladder
check me in this okay that is hard to
see because white is just clinging on to
that passer on A7 but you know
especially when this game concludes we
can probably show that variation yes
that was an absolute nutty Miss and
something super hard to spot when you
yourself only have 10 seconds
yeah and it's not only because of the
time situation you're just so fixated in
your mind on winning due to the A7 Pawn
that even thinking about Checkmate here
is very very hard we see the eval bar
that immediately primes us to look for
something decisive but Aram is focused
on not losing on time and he's focused
on getting his King past the Rubicon of
the C file I don't think he's going to
be successful that might have been his
last chance Robert we're 141 moves in I
feel like we need to open up the record
books what is the longest uh what is the
longest chess tour game thus far this
might be among them and it's a drop yeah
go back to that position Donya just to
show everybody of why the evaluation bar
freaked out and this is really hard to
spot but the evil bar shot up which
means that the Rook should shoot back
and help deliver a ladder checkmate
because in response to Rook takes A7
first to check on the G file if black
had King 88 that would have been a draw
but as it stands black is unable to
block the check with his Rook all the
black can do is go Rook C5 in order to
block a check on the G5 and now white
actually has to find Rook to B3 aiming
for B8 black has to go back and now you
go back to G1 Robert this is incredible
chest geometry Rook F3 and look at this
Rook F3 Rook G7 Rook D3 Rook C3 and only
now do you pick up the Rook on C7 how on
Earth did a robin would probably miss
this with 10 seconds on the clock I
think we need to kick him out of the CCT
right here
and right now what an easy tactical spot
I mean how could you not find that
enough that is one of those things where
the eval bar alerts us as commentators
but when you're playing you're not
expecting that tactic to exist maybe
with a couple minutes on the clock you'd
find it but not with a couple seconds
and now we are right in the thick of
round four we see Fabiano caruan taking
on Ralph momentov and Donna you told me
that this would be the matchup I would
expect this exact opening
yeah Rafa Madoff has like just played
the Sicilian since he was two years old
probably on a car one has played the
Russell limo since he was three years
old and so we have a sicilian rosalima
Ralph loves fianchetto openings he plays
the king's Indian he plays The
Accelerated Dragon anything with a
bishop on G7 Ralph will be first in line
and what I love about the rosalimo
Robert is how multifaceted it is within
the same opening you can have Ultra
tactical positions uh if black plays it
with E6 and you can have very positional
struggles in the line that Ralph
lamettov has chosen with a lot of
subtlety in the center like when does
black play 85 there's the answer right
now Wendy's white try to Counter-Strike
with F2 F4 maybe also now but so much
understanding underpins uh successful
rosalimo play for both colors here and I
remember during the world championship
match in 2021 when I was commenting
alongside Fabiano and Denny uh there'd
be times and we'd just be hanging on the
Airbnb and Bobby was working on some
chess and he works very hard on this
opening it's not something that he
prepared for the world championship
match and then forgot about and you
they're always little things that you
could look at and the best players in
the world even if the move the is
rejected by the computers they're like
oh this is terrible sometimes it helps
you come up with a good idea and right
now fobby's playing some great ideas
he's preventing black from casting
kingside in the near future and what
Ralph is doing is he's keeping more
pieces on the board this knight from f8
will likely go up to E6 but the big
problem piece from the black side of
Russ limo is the light Square Bishop
where is that Bishop on C8 going to go
what diagonal will be useful I'm not
really seeing anything just yet but I'm
also struggling a bit to see what
White's plan is
but that's such an instructive point
because a lot of people when they think
of a bad piece they think of a French
Bishop they think of a piece that's
hemmed in by their own pawns but bad
piece doesn't necessarily mean a piece
that literally has no squares it can
also mean a piece with no prospects a
piece that can't find a concrete job and
if you think about a black Bishop which
sits on E6 not only will it stand in the
way of the Knight which really wants
this Square as a Transit point and it
does go out to E6 but now the bishop
it's just kind of awkwardly sitting
there like you know a kid at a middle
school dance it what is it doing right
where is it gonna go Bishop A6 white can
just play B3 and prevent C4 and that is
a long-term problem that Ralph
definitely has to deal with but right
now he is dealing with executing his
main plan of increasing essential
control and Robert I'll pass it back to
you but just wanted to give a quick
shout out to Nicholas rosalimo himself
after whom the line is named one of the
most interesting characters in 20th
century American chess he was a French
immigrant who worked as a taxi driver
and actually owned a bookstore a chess
bookstore in New York City and that
bookstore was apparently the site of
some really really interesting chess
drama uh between all of the characters
of 1950s and 60s New York chess so
definitely very fittingly named
variation so would you say he's your
second favorite Taxi Driver of the 20th
century after Robert De Niro or oh
wait I'm trying to remember that Robert
De Niro phrase from Taxi Driver is it
who am I talking to
you're like very good Robert yes I'm I
am giving you a round of applause right
now as we speak
you talking to me
oh you're talking to me yes you talking
to me
you just hurt myself that's the one I
was looking for you asked the question
you had the answer to the question but
you just ask it in like a slightly
different phrase so it was like one of
those painful like you know what you're
talking about but you just happened to
misstate it but what in the I don't know
what we're talking about in this
position yeah what is happening here
like these Knights on G4 F5 and E6 the
bishop is kind of trapped on H6 Dania do
you have any explanation for what's
going on
well if Bishop is trapped on H6 but it's
it's like a Norwegian prison like that
Bishop is not actually that poorly
placed it's controlling some squares
it's hurting the coordination of Black's
King side okay is either side
threatening anything like what does
White's next move and what does black
snacks move the top engine move is Rook
A8 to A7 which I think tells you a lot
about Black's inability to improve his
position my inclination would be to
stick this Knight on F4 but if we could
bring up an analysis board Knight F4
apparently doesn't do anything either
white can simply improve his position
with a move like her ke1 and the big
problem is that black can never take on
F5 because both Knights are reinforcing
the bishop on H6 and if you make the
mistake of opening up the e-file well
obviously this is going completely in
the wrong direction for Ralph lamettov
so what makes this position so crazy
Robert is that there's so much going on
and yet there's nothing going on yet
neither side can seem to easily improve
their positions which makes it pretty
infuriating to try to find a helpful
move yeah and Rook A7 not easy move to
spot but does make sense now that you've
mentioned it because the bishop on C8
doesn't have anywhere good to go it's
probably going to stare at the 99 F5 at
some point and today goes Bishop h8
which gets the bishop out of the attack
I still don't see a follow-up for black
but I'm also not entirely sure what
White's plan is like what should white
do in this position Rook a to E1 I don't
know what you're threatening you're just
putting your Rook behind your own Pawn
so is there an active plan for white or
is Bobby just gonna Shuffle
I think Fabi might start shuffling I'm
starting to become a little bit more
partial to Ralph's position I really
like the look of this Knight on F5 I
think fabi's last move is a really good
one very alert he prevents the move
Knight D4 which would have really
shattered the coordination between
White's minor pieces and if Ralph plays
Knight F4 prematurely white could even
consider in some cases blowing up the
center with D4 because something we
haven't talked about yet is the king
position as long as the center remains
closed wax King is more than happy to
chill in the center if the Center opens
White's pieces are well positioned to
rip the king to shreds so Ralph I don't
know what he's gonna do now maybe Rook
A7 Rook D7 he does play Knight F4 but he
has to be so so careful Robert about
allowing this Rook a to D1 followed by
D4 plan
also g3 at some moment because if you
take on H3 the King goes up the G2 and
your Knight's trapped over there so uh
it's a closed position which means that
Knights often are better than Bishops
and we're seeing that right now the
bishop on h8 is a pretty miserable piece
the Knight on G4 defending H6
pre-impression E5 to 9 F5 is also in
enemy territory so Bishop A6 was played
and I think G3 is a good move because if
you take on H3 with check your knight
gets trapped over there if you take on
D3 I believe and here he plays it that
the wow White Queen will slide away from
the D file and there will be a pin along
the line and I just really heard that
that Knight on D3 could get trapped as
well
and if black plays C4 it's not all about
winning this Knight you have induced the
move which makes the bishop even worse
Black is stuck in mud here the queen
aiming at the B6 Square so white can
just continue improving his position
slowly with a plan like Rook D2 and
maybe preparing B3 maybe even H4
chipping away at this uh Pawn that
sticks out like a sore thumb on the king
side Bobby with filigree Precision here
and the speed with which he's making
these moves I think is really really
impressive hey he's just a monster and
then the fact that Knight just dropped
back means that the worst is sort of
behind Fabi he doesn't have to worry so
much and now he can slow play this like
I play Queen E3 Rook D2 Rook D1 and not
only is there Rook come to D1 Dania
potentially you could play for B4 I'm
very focused on the move d4 and all of
Black's forces are aimed with that
square but B4 is another Pawn break
especially a black Castle's Queen side
which I think is about to happen that
you can consider the move B4 to blow
that side of the board open
frying pan into the fire right black
finally gets his King out of the center
and boom the moment it does so white
blast open the queen side with B4 as
impressive as this Pawn structure may
seem it's also very susceptible to moves
like before because it makes contact
with a lot of Pawns at the same time so
Abby might have to find a different
purpose for these minor pieces if and
when black skin gets out of the center
but he's got more than enough Firepower
on the other side to support a rapid
fire attack on the queen side what a
rich and interesting positional game and
he goes right away I mean he's found his
purpose and B4
just chipping at that pawn structure the
eval bar doesn't like it and I'm
guessing he wanted a slower approach
your H4 move Now is really sinking in
with me you can't do it right away
because the ng4 was loose but maybe
there was a way to put F3 to defend the
Knight and then H4 just to try to open
up the king said unfavorable terms but
B4 played hardly can complain about that
in the sense that it's a rapid game
you're opening up the black king but
maybe he should have waited until black
Castle queenside before playing before
yeah before playing P4 and if you played
before before black Castle's King side a
queen side that is
what is the additional option that
you've granted to Black well one could
argue that black could much more easily
take twice on B4 you would do that with
a second thought with the King sitting
on C8 but with the King still on E8 you
can allow the queen side to get opened
and then maybe close down the diagonal
with C5 after White's Queen recaptures
then you've guaranteed a potential
Square on D4 for your knight so zero
Clarity has been reached in this
position in the last 10 minutes I feel
like they're making moves but with every
move that's being made I'm understanding
what's going on like less and less yes
and the eval Bar says Oh Black is now
slightly better the players don't know
that this is a really complicated
position and Fabi is a minute ahead the
clock and has the safer King and I think
that's going to be true for a large part
of this game the white king can't be
attacked the black king stuck in the
center and whoo whoa he castles into it
and if he's hold on before first in your
a ffair is Fabulous As Ralph momentov
wow shocking literally what a decision
that was and I guess his point is after
B takes C5 Knight takes C5 D3 is loose
A4 is loose but the Knight on E6 is
doing an important job of defending the
G5 Pawn as well so I'm not sure how to
assess this resulting position but there
is a lot hanging in the balance
there is and there's literally a lot
hanging in the position I think Ralph
might have forgotten about the G5 plan
if I may quickly show this line BC well
okay black and grab the pawn on D3 but
then white can take on B6 Intermezzo
move hitting the queen so Ralph might be
making on Knight take C5 but after
Bishop G5 Rook D3 it looks very
impressive or black it looks like the
queen cannot maintain contact with the
bishop but it can you can drop back to
C1 very calm move and if black continues
to pursue the White Queen look at this
Robert Queen C1 to A3 and suddenly it's
blacks pieces which are experiencing the
brunt uh of the problems after Rook
takes G5 why does it have to be fancy
takes takes you can even play Queen
takes B3 and When the Smoke finally
clears this is the ultimate positional
problem you've got this dud of a bishop
on h8 so black cannot afford a bunch of
pieces to get traded like this because
you're gonna be sitting there playing
essentially down a minor piece
and as I say that Abby with A5
my goodness gracious every time Clarity
is about to be reached things just get
more complicated well I think one thing
that's going to be clear is the bishop
on h8 is going to be terrible and the
bishop on A6 is likely about to be awful
when you play Pawn to B5 at some point
first training Rooks and then B5 the
bishop run A6 stares into its own Pawn
so I think the knights are really
shining the Bishops are struggling and
that's what Fabi is aiming for and he
has a nearly two minute lead on the
clock I think it's much more difficult
for black to play than white White's
King so healthy on G1 and Black's piece
all over the place right they're
discombobulated the bishop 186 is not in
rhythm in sync with G6 the bishop on h8
and the non E6 they're not really
coordinated so I feel like white just
has things under control here and the
position is getting increasingly
difficult for Ralph
I love that every one of fabi's games
thus far in this tournament has had a
different signature right his first game
against gawaine Jones making something
out of at one point would seem like a
worse end game his second round
brilliant tactic against Alexander
Romanov just smashing through the gates
in the center and then this fourth game
super complicated but I see that you're
surprised Robert B takes A5 might just
have made matters even worse no no it's
not about this I was looking at the the
top pairings and this position
apparently evened up but I saw that
Eduardo e turizaga is three out of three
but we looked at his game before he was
down a full piece
and I looked won that game I looked to
see how he won kovalenko had 45 seconds
to eat cherry zaka six and he hung his
Queen in one move like he moved his
Queen to a square where he turns out
took it in a completely winning position
so I was just shocked to see a tourism
at a perfect score then I was even more
shocked to see how he won that game so
hey Eduardo doing well happy to be a
three out of three but Fortune it's on
his side today
origin seems to smile on the best Blitz
players that is a heartbreaker for
kovalenko that's crazy we thought that
was totally and completely over this
game is clearly far from over Fabi in
the driver's seat but he might have just
made a mistake by taking on A5 but
Robert I wanted to take a quick visit at
a different game the board 2 game
between two players that we haven't
spotlighted yet it's a mean top of the
buy against Alan picho there is a white
knight that's on G7 and just that fact
alone should be appealing enough to look
at this position what on Earth is
happening in 95 no
oh
wow E5 not Knight takes D5 but his point
is clear there were many pieces in front
of the black king let's start trading
them off one by one if you take on D5 I
take on G5 then I take on G7 we actually
have even material there at least in
terms of pieces I have to count the
pawns it seems like white is currently
upon ahead but at least the black king
won't get checkmated
geez and then the D5 Pawn in the ensuing
position is going to be a major Target
for black spaceship so let's dig in for
a second after Bishop takes C7 let's say
that white starts with that move
I assume Lex gonna recapture with the
queen because if you take back with the
Knight Knight H5 robber creates very
unpleasant threats against these dark
scores Queen F6 is threatened you're
shaking your head so is alonpi show and
he has in fact taken on E7 with the
queen but in white simply trade Queens
go Knight H5 and say I'm up a pawn and
you've got
holes on both sides of the board and
it's exactly what I mean by said that
I'm upon and you have holes on both
sides the board and I mean just crossed
2700 briefly and then he dropped back
below but he's about at that Super Jam
level he's somebody that I don't think
we talk about enough and the World Cup
is about to start he made a very deep
run two years ago in Sochi so a means up
and Dubai he's improving it seems like
every single event every month and right
now he's steadied his position he's up a
pawn it's seven on six the bad news is
the Double B Pawn so certain positions
they can be vulnerable but for now Dunya
this looks like a very clear Advantage
for white
it most certainly does and the advantage
is growing he's got the three on one on
the king side he's got a potential
Target in the form of the C7 Pawn you
might see him go Rook a to C1 and if
black sticks a knight on D5 White's
Knights are so mobile but not only are
uh they active where they currently are
but they can combine with one Knight
jumping to F6 and if you get a knight
versus Bishop situation that Bishop on
B7 all that it's doing is threatening to
take on F3 but if White's King moves
away from the G file that's going to be
a dud of a bishop as well I would even
consider throwing in the move King F2 so
that you never have to worry about
tactics down the G file this should be a
technical win for white although two
minutes on the clock for both sides
we've seen crazier things happen in this
very tournament
there's no Queen to blunder here that's
true all the pieces can be blundered
though and I just wanted to quickly
shout out Nicholas theodoro who goes a
three and a half out of four uh Jana
Pomchi at three and a half before we
surely will focus on his games in future
rounds Yuri Cruz above the Ukrainian
Grandmaster at three and a half and
alireza farouza somebody who drew Renato
Terry but won his other three games so
he drew round one and now has won three
straight but uh I was about to call you
Fabi because I was looking at
game of fobby here look at that Bishop
on f8 it was stuck on H6 for so long but
now that it's reached the f8 square
there are problems for black he could
have gone Knight E7 check Fabi and won
the exchange but he understands that
Rook on G6 isn't that valuable let's
Rush that pass Pawn up the board and
then maybe this Bishop's coming to C5
and there it is Pawn to A7 next and
yikes
I don't know how you're picking out
relevant details out of this position
but I was thinking what to compare it to
maybe like a Hieronymus boss painting
like you know Garden of Earthly Delights
where there's seven million things going
on and it takes an expert to really call
out to tease out the relevant details
and I think that the big relevant detail
is just that again that Bishop on h8 as
we were pointing out earlier you really
can't play a position this tactical with
a piece that's doing nothing so there's
that then there's the pawn on A6 which
is restricting Black's King White's King
is completely safe so ultimately Robert
I think the most important factor and it
might seem like the most primitive
observation but it's the king safety
it's the fact that black has struggled
with his King for the last 15 moves but
where's the Finishing Touch it's
probably not to take twice on D4 because
that allows the bishop to get
reactivated
yeah I would not free up that Bishop I
think that keeping it stuck in the
corner is worth more than a pawn and
Fabi agrees an excellent move such a
high class move he's just reinforcing
the Knight and F5 but also the knight in
G4 no longer doing much so maybe this
Knight will now go to C4 because then it
gets to B6 and he goes Knight C4 blacks
in a world of hurt and if you take on C4
that's one of the critical Defenders of
the black king that's coming off the
board the C3 Pawn suddenly becomes loose
Fabi is playing a phenomenal game right
now they say that for good basketball
players the basket is like an ocean
right the net literally expands and I
think for great chess players you see
something similar where it's like the
way that they shuttle their pieces from
one side to the other it's like the
board itself is bigger that Knight was
on G4 one second ago literally now it's
on C4 it's threatening to jump to B6 and
if black is forced to give away his
light squared Bishop I think his
position collapses in the span of two or
three moves Robert because you won't be
able to hold C3 you won't be able to
rely on your other Bishop obviously and
the Knight on D4 is going to start
losing its support I think Fabi is
completely winning here and I'm looking
at the clock Bishop F6 Knight B6 yeah
Bishop F6 is one of those moves like I
just need to do something everything
looks bad but Knight B6 check that
forces the king over to B8 I don't know
if A7 yeah wins the game on Usher There
hmm
there's the crusher there is it weenie
six and Bishop D6 no that's not
convincing because black and giveaway is
Queen
so it's just 4k1 oh that's simple very
well on Fabi I mean come on
every move with purpose and now
what is the finisher because I want to
move my knight D4 Knight D5 and A7 sorry
to cut you off
so why do I need to take on D4
oh it's because black s Queen takes a
six now
oh wow
so I'm still confused what the exact
difference is
but yeah Bobby wasn't expecting this but
can he just take and play Knight takes
F6 here and he's then take on A6 and
you're up a piece
and I was worried about C2 in that final
position Robert but I I guess you're
stopping the pawn with Bishop A3 how do
you stop the pawn
if blackplay's Rook takes F6 maybe you
need to actually take this other Knight
first so that when you drop the bishop
back to A3 lock is unable to chase it
with the Knight and Ralph trying to stir
complications up with Knight cb3 Rook
takes A6 everything's hanging black can
take on C5 and suddenly the Knight and
the Rook are both hanging and that c
Pawn still lives and that can be
dangerous so Knight D7 check
protects the bishop on C5 he goes Rook
B1 Bishop C4 quickly what is happening
Knight back to E3 right C2 though
deflects the Knight
and black is still alive yes C2 Knight
C2 Rook takes F6 oh my gosh this Knight
comes back Bishops are both hanging
there's Knight A1 at the end and you win
the Knight on B3 what a move and Ralph
sees it he moves his King away to the
side which is the only way to stay alive
what and the bishop on C5 and the Knight
on C2 are both under attack Rook takes
B3 Bishop B3 Knight A1 you get two
pieces for The Rook oh my gosh Knight A1
is crazy ghost Bishop B4 Fabi panicking
here he wants to go Knight E3 Robert
he's thinking forward but the bishop has
a beautiful Square to drop back to and
it's equal
black might be better well Rook b a
check and Bishop takes E5 I don't really
see how black is better here but maybe
black is holding on no it's a scramble
this game has been exciting from the
start and right now fobby needs to get
moves and he's not under 10 seconds
yeah I exaggerated there slightly but
when the game turns like this you can
actually feel like you're losing the
threat of the game a great move by Ralph
trading away the knights he is very
close to holding this position together
he could still lose this because white
is more active
but compared to what it was about five
moves like oh he missed that five F5
shoes F5 oh okay F5 would win The Rook
because Rook 86 Bishop F4 rookies and
Rook B7 check and he's still much better
his five minute car one of these one
upon right now and this is what I said
before white is up two Pawns in the
center black is up upon on the C file
upon the H file E6 check Bishop b68
check would have won a piece
and black could have won that back with
Rook F1 but that e-pawn would have
promoted at the end Abby plays it now
but it's too late
and Ralph is gonna get a theoretically
drawn position but will he be able to
hold it with no time on his clock
this is not easy to do when you're down
under 20 seconds but the two second
increment you get two seconds out of
your clock with every move that should
help and usually what players do in
these positions is they eventually win
the pawn but they want to perfect the
squares of their pieces like look Bishop
on D4 Rook on d8 oh but now he's just
allowed to draw yeah that's it Rook C8
C5 and white has to take in order to
give away his Rook that's it what a Hold
by Ralph momentov
absolutely ridiculous Ralph deserves so
much credit for finding tactic after
tactic that kept him in the game there
were mistakes it you know the evaluation
swung from equal back to winning for
white that's what happens when you're in
a scramble but he really deserves so
much credit for not just losing that
game
and this was one of the last clean wins
that Fabi had this is already after they
traded Queens he could have played F5
right away Robert and a great Point by
you it's not about pushing the pawns
it's about trapping The Rook because if
you go back to H7
I was gonna make the whoop sound but my
voice is going so rugby seven wins the
rook and if you play F5 Rook G5 still
Bishop F4 and again or even Bishop takes
F6 apologies for that it's Bishop F6 and
you are winning because of the connected
passers you can even trade Rooks after
Rook G8 and the pawn is the right color
that actually is the most important
factor in this entire position what an
incredible game that was a joy to watch
yeah that one it was very close and
Ralph was borderline lost I mean he was
losing but he found those tactics and he
survived so they both moved a three and
a half out of four and look who's at the
top Frederick smone and Amin tapatibai a
perfect four out of four thus far and
done I think we have a few games left in
this round including Dimitri on draken
who is down at peace against Casper
dresdovsky
and he is and he's got some pawns for
that piece but rustovsky is dominating
them with his Knight on Drake in with
his last seconds he's losing everything
here and no stalemate the King has H7
what a win for Casper and he's the not
so friendly ghost and unfortunately
dropping at one knife out of four I
don't think he'll have any chance to
qualify for the top division today but
there's division two and three to work
his way towards
it's just so brutal right you lose a
game early on you play somebody like
druzowsky who is a great Blitz player
and just such a good opportunity for
lesser known players to score some
amazing upsets I'm still my hands are
still shaking Robert from that Ralph
moment of Fabiano Cara won a game but
ultimately it's not a tragedy for Fabi
who's on three and a half out of four
and still in excellent position to make
his way into the top division
yeah if your main complaint is oh I'm
not four out of four I'm only a three
and a half shows that he's still having
a good day and well the players they're
gonna get set for the fifth round of
action Donnie and I will take a quick
break but when we return it is another
round here at the Julius bear generation
cup playing here in the championship
store we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
Benji the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chess board
watch out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
ponchick learned chess from his dad GM
Lavon aronian he has never lost to
another dog at chess and certainly won't
lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
foreign
[Music]
thank you
shout out to Meetup with over 25 000
members and still growing head over to
meetup.com chess to find a local group
or organize a chess Meetup of your own
while the chess has met the board here
in the Jules bear generation cup we have
seen some players two in fact go to four
out of four a means Habit to buy and
Fredericks funny done it perhaps names
that people didn't expect to be the only
perfect ones remaining but there they
are strong Grand Masters making a name
for themselves in a field with many
superstars
and Frederick swannai made a name for
himself in round two defeating a very
obscure uh chess player with a short
resume named Vladimir kramnik and then
not even looking back we've had some
crazy games we obviously have Fabiano
caruan and Ralph who were the stars of
the previous round their game ends in a
draw and one thing I really like about
these middle rounds Robert is when
players with a perfect score drop down
to play the highest rated player with
half a point below so we might see
Fabiano caruana Ralph momentov and
others play those players at the top and
they really really want to win to stop
these perfect runs okay well you know
we're starting at the top why not a mean
top of the by Frederick Swanee the games
are getting underway so why don't we
Dive Right In to the action as we see
the players they have played just one
move per side
did they make it no thankfully not I
thought they made a draw already and I
was about to lose my mind
yeah maybe I mean deciding between a
king's Gambit a center game or deciding
what move he's playing in this position
I mean plays the Italian he plays the
real Lopez
oh gosh am I seeing what you're seeing
Berlin
that is also what I'm seeing and I think
I mean is legitimately deciding if he
wants to force a drop now as the higher
rated player with the white pieces I
think it's a good chance for him to play
for a win if he could win this game he
takes a lot of the pressure off of the
subsequent couple of rounds you really
can't post your way to division one he
will need to win at least one more game
yeah we had the same exact thought he's
taking a safe approach where white is
slightly better but the position is
symmetrical a white gets those pawns a
little bit more advanced and I think
this is a wise choice Dania I I don't
think it was worth just risking too much
but you're in the white side of this
position only one open file no real risk
to speak of
yeah rookie one is the kind of move you
play if you're okay making a drop but
you don't want to get you know uh your
door knocked on by Angry fans who feel
like they deserve an actual game so this
isn't just a dead draw right you can't
compare this to the repetition line with
Queen E4 Queen D4 there is chess left to
be played here you even see decisive
games at the very top level because as
symmetrical as the position looks Robert
White does have the space Advantage
white has this nagging Pawn chain that
really restricts Black's Bishop so I
never like playing positions like this
from the defending side but I think a
couple of careful moves separate black
from uh a likely peaceful result
okay so let's go around a bit just in
the early stages of this round this game
uh will be either a draw by agreement at
some point or a long battle just because
it's a position that doesn't have
tension in it at least not yet so you
pulled up the game between Diego Flores
and Fabiano caruana uh where early
stages there it looks like Fabi getting
his Bishop out to G4 getting active but
nothing really too major has happened
yet nope pawns or pieces traded so why
don't we just keep looking at games just
so we can get more names yeah in front
of the audience draw their game early on
as de mamadov and kazubov so we'll skip
those two games but alireza farouza and
Nicholas theodoro are on a very
combative path
oh okay so we see the black Kinks still
in the center the white king safely
castled but that Bishop on C2 I've never
really been a huge fan of these types of
variations even though I used to play it
myself and maybe that's why I'm not a
huge fan is I'm like I look at that
Bishop on C2 and I know eventually it
might see the light of day but for now
I'm like no that piece doesn't look good
but I like opening the a file and I like
that I've castled but black is very
solid I guess I just don't really know
how to weigh the different dynamics that
are happening here
it's a very kind of amorphous position
like you've got a lot going on and yet
it's hard to say what's going on in the
center you have two sources of tension
now one source of tension black pushes
the pawn up to B4 and one way to Garner
prospects for the light score Bishop you
see this in the real Lopez as well and
actually this position has a lot in
common with certain Roy Lopez structures
is for white to play A5 and actually
stick the bishop on A4 very often that a
pawn is Untouchable for various tactical
reasons uh such as the discovery along
the a file but top priority for alireza
is to complete his minor piece
development and another thing Robert
that we have in common with three Lopez
you very often see why it's night
traveling from D2 to F1 to G3 assembling
your pieces on the king side because
very likely wax king is not going to
stay in the center forever black is
likely to go Knight G6 and Bishop E7 and
then of course he's going to Castle
kingside
and I guess white also can throw in the
move d4 at some point especially with
this Knight already on D2 and the bishop
on C2 that I was complaining about
suddenly it will have an open Avenue
aiming towards the black king side so
the lack of development for black that
means that perhaps something like Knight
G6 to get the dark Square Bishop in the
game might be necessary but Theodore is
spending a bit of time here alireza with
a minute lead on the clock keep being on
the Rizza probably happy about the start
of this game
and what move you want to avoid in in
such positions is D5 D4 I think some
players would have the temptation to
close down the center eliminate the
potential tension down the e-file but
the medicine is worse than the disease
there because D4 allows whitesnite to
jump into this Ultra juicy C4 square and
from C4 it has access to dark squares in
the center and on the queen side so I
think Nicholas has to just bite the
bullet here and as unpleasant as it is
to allow a move like he takes D5 I think
he's got to go Knight G6 I don't see
another way for him to untangle his King
side pieces I guess you could go for the
fianchetto with G6 but man I would be
ultra terrified of weakening all these
dark squares
and yeah I guess after Knight G6 you
have to cover it is Pawn takes D5 going
to be annoying yeah he puts his Knight
on A5 so he's playing on the rim and I
would be tempted to just play D4 in the
center my opponent's playing on the
flank like this but I'll raise a you
know he has many things that he could do
he could take on B4 first sometimes you
do that I I wouldn't go about that right
now uh my eyes are on D4 but I know
sometimes in these Russell Amo positions
done yet you play H4 because Knight G6
is the idea and then maybe you can play
H5 to kick that pony out of there so
many possible plans
H4 is a very instructive idea I like it
when that move is played before uh
Knight G6 but I really think we should
alireza glass to White's opening play in
this game he's got a great position and
um I'm just gonna pretend I didn't say
anything just now I like that I mean
that was okay that was a good one no I I
approve of that message because yeah I
don't really have a glass to raise I was
looking I just have a water bottle so
yeah I got nothing it's okay I do
I promise this is coffee in it though so
you know
all right well 95 played here why don't
we continue to look at other games uh
honestly a game that really is catching
my eyes the one between Levon aronian
and Aiden suleimani Levon has the black
pieces and well Lavon is three out of
four so he probably needs to start
winning if he wants to qualify for
division one once again but look at this
position Donna isn't white just full
steam ahead playing G5 next
and I don't understand why there's a big
bad question mark next to the move G4
it's as natural as one two three white
threatening G5 Black's Queen is actually
going to be trapped after HD Bishop G5
and wait a second G5 yeah what G5
what is Lavon intending maybe some sort
of G6 to complicate The Narrative on the
king he said yes but white can actually
take twice on G6 and I think the check
on F2 that Levon is banking on doesn't
do as much as he thought it would after
King H1
and maybe he's trying to invoke fear in
his young opponent saying I'm Lavon of
Roney and I'm a super GM 28 35 if I'm
not mistaken at his Peak but I think
you're right you can just take twice in
G6 and the black King's in trouble Donna
go back a few moves before G4 I think I
know what the Miss was and he used the
right square but with the wrong piece
that Rook G4 threads Bishop takes H6
winning a pawn and you're gonna deliver
a Checkmate and if the king steps to the
H file to avoid the g-pawn being pinned
the H Pawn is now pinned and Bishop G5
wins the queen
yep not F4 93 Knight D2 not H6 but G5
and that's it can't take with the pawn
and you can't play G6 now right that was
the more or less Saving Grace in the
game but here Queen takes H6 Jack and
look at that Bishop protecting the queen
attacking the enemy Queen Rook G4 would
have ended the game that's a great catch
Robert instead I think solomonly has a
lot of hurdles left to cross because
this might be winning according to the
e-belt bar but hey right evaluating that
position yourself against Levon aronian
after takes takes takes and queen F2
apparently white is winning here but how
exactly do you continue attacking Robert
after a move like Rook F7 do you drop
your knight back to H4 do you play G
takes H6 I think there's still a lot of
Chess left to be played and when you
miss a chance like this against someone
like LaVon how many times have we seen
that right a lower rated player has a
clear-cut win they miss it the position
remains winning objectively but when you
give these top players another life they
tend to exploit it so I'm starting to
get a little bit worried here about
Aiden solomonly
and he did just take once on G6 and now
he's gonna think about taking twice uh
but it's a scary position it should be
good for white but things could go wrong
and another Super GM in a very
interesting battle is Anish giri Anish
only a two and a half out of four is a
plus score but he's going to have to get
some victories if he is going to make it
to division one he's somebody who hasn't
played much in the champion chess tour
this season so we're glad to have him in
the playing right now but I think in
this position Dunya from the white side
he's looking at this B6 is a target F7
is a target this is a French without a
light Square Bishop that's the good news
but the bad news is White's attacking
everything on the board
no the bad news is that it's a French
that's the extent of the bad news you
don't really need to say anything more
than that and uh it's funny black has
traded that French Bishop which is
usually a very good sign but there's so
many other minuses in Black's position
of course centered around the very weak
King on D7 and black can try to or why
could try to exploit that King by
dropping the queen to D1 Robert and
using the queen side to its fullest
extent right the B6 Pawn is under
pressure and if white can double on the
C file you are going to be threatening
an infiltration to C7 Geary does
something very similar with Bishop D2 I
think he's preparing Rook C3 but the
eval bar wasn't a fan of that move was
it because you left the D4 Pawn exposed
Knight C6 back apparently not the
correct move so no these positions are
quite difficult to figure out they're
locked and so the Knight does defend A5
and tax D4 and now Queen D1 so second
time is the charm Anish realizes that he
can go to the B file and he's gonna load
them up because that's two ropes behind
it he's got the alakons gun
I didn't even realize that Queen B1 is
an idea so he's got Rook C2 on the menu
Queen B1 on the menu and if you can
force black to play Knight C8 we talked
earlier about using both sides of the
board you could also run an F Pawn up
the board and add even more pressure on
the king side this is pure misery or
Mikhail demidov yeah and I thought you
could say full board awareness the queen
on B1 might go to H7 if you're not
paying enough attention because that
hits the Rook on G8 and the pawn on G7
so a queen of B1 is super powerful it's
getting ready to win the B6 Pawn it's
allowing you to go over to the C file
with your Rooks it's also uh F4 F5 and
queen to H7 so many ideas in this
position for white and frankly I see
very few for black and I am seeing that
Demi offered a draw at some point and
Denise was like no way oh come on make
that draw and you you know what to do
with it I didn't mean to tell you and
the queen has moved on to B1 you have
built the alakine gun but one very
instructive point I was gonna say you
don't necessarily want to rush Rook
takes B6 but I think the move Rook B5 is
what's attracting a niche to play that
move if you were forced to trade twice
on B8 yeah you have an extra Pawn but
who cares right it's it's an extra a
pawn and your a pawns are doubled so he
didn't take on B6 to win upon he took it
in order to open the B file and Rook B5
is a co-linear move
black can never take this rook and allow
the pawns to undouble
maybe Anish can start playing a little
bit more positionally now and slow down
a little bit maybe bring this Knight
away from H4 but I'll put it this way
they're still worked left to be done in
this position for white the game's not
over well Knight F3 E1 D3 C5 is what
first comes to my mind you you know the
night on HR isn't doing all that much
right now uh but that is quite a trek
and I love that move Rook B5 because you
get to keep the tension on the B file
you trade on your own terms if black
takes a B5 a6b5 that looks terrible
because you've handed white a past Pawn
that can then be defended and so he does
go Knight to F3 which to my eyes looks
like a very natural move and well I
think demidov wants to kind of counter
play with a queen H4 check at the right
moment so I would play King G1 right now
game G1 is a very circumspect
prophylactic move and then when you play
91 as you're saying Queen H4 no longer
comes with a check so you're dropping a
piece on B8 there's a crazy tactic here
with Rook B5 takes D5 checks sacking The
Exchange and recapturing the Knight on
F5 with a big attack but that's a hard
position to evaluate I don't really
think that's an a niche Geary type of
move especially with three minutes on
the clock you don't want this position
getting too tactical you largely want to
keep the status quo structurally and
that's kind of what a niche does he goes
you for he kicks the Knight out of F5
forces the trade and now with the D4
Pawn reinforced by its colleague on E3
you can continue your plan
but you still have to watch out for
Queen H4 uh this is fantastic play from
Anish he can go King jitu bring the king
up to G3 to take away uh those points of
entry and also he was Queen on situ and
says what is your move demidov because
well Rook takes A5 is a threat now that
Knight is pinned so he goes Queen f8 to
get the A3 Pawn in its sights but I
don't think that black actually has a
threat because Queen takes A3 drops a
piece to Rook takes B8 and the king is
dislodged from its defense of the Knight
on C6 so I just think that deminov
doesn't really have options here
and I still think we're gonna see King
G2 by a niche and he plays it and one of
the reasons is that after Queen takes A3
and after white captures that Knight on
C6 with the King still on H1 Robert
Queen takes E3 would have come with
Tempo and you know how those positions
can get right there can be a Perpetual
that Knight isn't a very good Defender
with that no longer being a worry Anish
can refocus his attention back on the
queen side and ultimately I think he
still wants to get this Knight around to
C5 I love the patience with which he's
handling this position it's very
instructive and what's also instructive
is this quiz on B1
with the C2 and then B3 if the king
decided to go back to C7 he would put
his Queen on C3 a better defensive
Square threatening the same ideas but he
goes Knight E1 Knight D3 Knight C5 and I
just don't see how black can possibly
defend this I trust a niche in this
position I don't know about you I'd be
happy to go elsewhere or to see him
conclude this game
I think we can entrust the the rest of
the conversion to him I'll keep uh you
know I peripheral vision on this game if
if something interesting happens but I
think we should pay a visit back to our
top boards we've got that by Swanee game
with uh the two four out of four players
perhaps we could check into that game
really quickly where's that I mean
has been making very steady progress in
that rookie one Berlin and he's been
making progress on the board and on the
clock I think he's a couple moves away
from ending this game
if we just quickly go back to around
move 16 and that's just a nasty shot
this game is I mean yep it's all right
it's over crushing uh you're about to be
up a couple pawns but in this moment
here look at the move that white played
you're on the open file he plays the
move a subtle move just look at that
Queen D1 it looks like it doesn't really
do anything but the queen is better
placed on B3 which is where it goes
after Black's next turn and now B7 and
D5 are in the queen sites and white was
able to pick up a pawn and then you saw
the live position he just cruised from
there
and black just loses after Queen takes
B7 because the entire Queen side
structure collapses and an even bigger
problem is that you can barely defend
the A7 Pawn Savannah didn't defend it I
mean took it black got a little bit of
counter play but that pawn was just way
way way too strong and look at this move
A6 with the idea of just sliding the
queen over to B7 and the pawn is
completely Unstoppable the bishop on F1
doing a great job by the way of keeping
the king protected so I'm gonna go back
to the live board which features this
position that is going to be the final
position of the game robber what a
positional display by mean and queen D1
Queen B3 definitely the game-winning
maneuver
yeah I mean that was just easy after he
stole the pawn he never looked back so
me and tap to buy a perfect five out of
five and so he is in the only perfect
scorer left and that's great for him
because we were saying you can make a
draw but you're not going to be able to
Coast because those super jams they're
gonna fight you down the stretch he now
goes to five out of five he can afford a
loss as long as he's able to secure
enough points to land amongst the top
eight
and that was a great win by amine he's
on five out of five speaking of great
wins speaking of great moves I went back
to the suleimani Iranian game because I
couldn't take my eyes off of what Aidan
suleimani just did with 16 seconds
Robert Rook E4 takes the pawn on E5
clearing the path for his Bishop to
travel to D5 and the queen making
contact with the Rook is what makes this
combination work white is completely
winning I think Lavon is out of
defensive resources here what a move
I think I would try Rook F2 is black
just because it looks scary for white to
do it I don't see an immediate Checkmate
against the black king but I do see 16
seconds left for white so Donna you are
a bullet Beast you just made it to the
top four of the bullet Chess
Championship it's one of those types of
moves that just scares your opponent
maybe there is some kind of like Rook G
one but I'm already thinking about
exchange sex on G2 to try to go after
the white king and expose new diagonals
yeah Rook F2 is a great practical move
that's totally what I would play
the other problem is that you can't snap
this Knight off the board in that line
because Rook takes H2 and queen F2 is a
very easy mating construction to miss
you might say oh well the G2 square is
defended it's easy to forget about the
other mating Square Rook F2 is on the
board and with 10 seconds cancel them
only keep his composure and find
a win that I don't see off the top of my
head Robert
C5 and what's this follow-up five
seconds three oh rookie workout five
five oh another
oh my gosh
that's really nice
gotta try 97 if you're Lavon
Knight E7 and bring your knight back to
G8 and hope that you can somehow not get
made it
lamb up into a little ball I apologize
that was not that was not played but
Brooke F5
what a game from suleimani
oh not over yet three seconds left he's
taken on F2 and just takes on D7 mm-hmm
and if Queen H4 this queen d8 check
because you can't block with your knight
as the queen on H4 would be loose
beautiful Rogue G8 another attempt by
Levon if you take that Rook you allow
Perpetual check but another accurate
move this is incredible
absolutely brilliant game from suleimali
a teenager from Azerbaijan he just
and he's shown this this game is sick
this is something I would be proud to
find Robert in a classical game he found
all of these moves with less than 10
seconds on his clock and he's driven the
king out on F6 and he's gonna Checkmate
it on F4 Levon resigns but Queen E6
Queen E4 would have been a very fitting
conclusion to this incredible game
wow so suleimani goes to four and a half
points and not a name that maybe a lot
of people are familiar with he
checkmated the black king but tsumali
has a big tournament Victory to his name
and he won the Air flat open several
years back when he was even younger he's
still very young he's a teenager but he
was like
13 14 at the time when he was able to
take that big tournament so let's move
away let's go to another game and it's
Min lay against Igor lecision isn't
white black to move
oh I was like lights up a piece but it's
Black's moves Rook takes D2L has Rook C8
check with a draw
and I missed a pattern like this against
a weak player in the bullet Chess
Championship but he's played Queen takes
C6 did Igor Lisa he's playing for a win
and
is he gonna regret that decision Robert
I'm very surprised he's just worse in
the end game even if white just trades
queens and gives a check on C8 well I
could get checkmated there very easily
yeah Rook CH what are you doing if
you're King H7 Rook E8 will lead to a
quick maiden of King F7 you'll Rook C7
Champion you just pick up the Jeep on
the very everything Rook F3 and Rook
takes G7 white is completely winning
that was total Madness by Igor who might
have been attracted to White's clock
but G4 by men should also win the game
he watched rookie 5 G5 mate
oh Rook ce7
look at that oh it's mate G5 doesn't
help neither is H5
it's made in one Rook B6 is the only way
to stop it but I thankfully can take
your rook and go up a full one of those
so that's game over minlay scores this
Victory so he is going to move up into
our leaderboard but are any other games
going that won't have Checkmate in one
well I will point out that Ali Raza
faruja
has defeated uh Nicholas Theodora so a
big win there
we've got Gareth uh who faces Renato
Terry the ultra solid Renato Terry who
seems to be
ooh you might be losing here
somehow the engine not reacting oh now
it's all now
you evaluate for yourself I know this is
clearly winning uh for white the bishop
has to go back to H7 then you can take
on E6 and get another passer and at some
point there should be Suge file
I mean I guess you actually go the other
way it's tempting to go King F6 and E6
but I don't think you can win unless you
target that A6 Pawn Gareth does go to F6
and that was the wrong way to go you're
allowed to draw absolutely correct the
bishop moves as soon as the King goes to
G6 the bishop goes back to G8 there are
no points of entry for the white king
and that means the bishop will just go
back and forth and as you said it should
and will be a draw
unbelievable we saw how tricky Robert
these end games are to win in the
savannah game you could literally have
two pass pawns on the cusp of promotion
but the fact that one side has a
monopoly on squares of a certain color
makes it so hard to make progress and we
see that here watches uggles between G8
and E6 such an instructive example for
students of the end game to learn
um speaking of end games I just at the
corner I saw Anish giri is not winning
in end game against Mikhail demidov and
he cannot afford to drop half points
like this because he only had two and a
half and a four but he's not winning
this game
King G4 picks up the remaining Pawn
and that to me is pretty hard to believe
he was up on time he was playing a
brilliant positional game but Mikhail
deminov all credit to him we saw him
defending resiliently and ultimately and
each fails to win
surprising to see Anish fail to convert
that huge Advantage but that's gonna
cost him and oh speaking of costing him
was that Knight B5 there was a moment
here where Anish could have played
Knight takes H6
a very thematic night sacrifice and he
could have promoted that H Pawn I
already cut you off there Robert I just
saw this out of the corner of my eye
instead Anish tries to break through
right away with G5 and that allows
demetov to sacrifice his Knight in order
to eliminate White's duponts a huge Miss
there for a niche wow yeah he's going to
regret that one maybe with a little bit
more time on the clock he would have
spotted it but not in each scariest day
here in the playing but for demidov a
nice result with the black pieces
against a super GM so what games still
remain in this round I see just a couple
still going yeah
this one
and justovsky he beat on draken so he's
had himself a good day and he's trying
to hold us with black and I think he's
doing a good job of it
he's doing a great job these are Bishops
of the same color which generally make
onup end games a little bit more
winnable but the problem here is White's
pawns on the king side they're both on
light squares White's Bishop has to
babysit them and so it doesn't have the
time uh to help make progress on uh the
queen side and Robert very important for
black to keep the King on C7 as long as
it's on a dark Square it can never be
checked which means you can never make
ultimate progress with that c pawn and
maybe white should offer a draw before
it's too late before he loses the two
King side pawns and has to grovel for
the draw
yeah we see that it's just even material
here there's no way for volcanov to win
and it's another good result for
drostovsky who is an international
Master but often has his rating at or
above 2500 feet a and at least on
chess.com he's
at the top with all the best Bliss
players so another good result for him
and I don't want to be harsh but Jordan
event Forest is not having himself a
good event he is going to give up
another draw
and another opposite card Bishop end
game I guess that's the order of the day
wait oh this
is this winning
it's looking scary to the King goes to
seat three and B4 but maybe the bishop
gets oh
they're just in time
okay now ideally you would have your
king Robert on oh but the pawn is
actually the right color so
how do you hold this
why is this still a draw okay maybe you
bring your king back to the as you're
saying to the C2 B1 A2
and then you sacrifice your Bishop for
the F Pawn while you throw your H Pawn
oh and any time Black's King goes too
far Black's Bishop is gonna have to
defend the a pawn and like you're saying
White's gonna run the H Pawn up the
board and deflect the Bishop from its
defense of the a pawn and harsh sees all
of this with 10 seconds left until now
or
Jordan made a mistake
yeah you know pushing the pawn to F3 is
clearly a mistake because now the king
sits in front of the F Pawn and there's
no way for the dark Square Bishop to
defend it
I think Jordan thinks he can win that
pawn with his King while keeping F3
protected and that's his mistake White's
not gonna allow that to happen
and there's no way to zooang here like
you know King G3 the King has to go back
to F1 but he's just trying to play this
out a few more moves but it seems like
it what happened
almost flagged yet .3 seconds when he
made that move and he'll lose the game
if he Flags that's incredible exactly
what I was thinking he still got that H1
oh my goodness imagine losing on time
and wait he made that move with
literally zeros
I'm telling you he's in disbelief that
this is a drawn position but such an
instructive Point robber you can't just
aimlessly push pawns especially when you
push them to the color of your
opponent's Bishop that was
a big big Miss and Jordan his chances of
qualifying into the top division are
essentially out the window
and we've seen him thrive in the top
division he beat Hikaru Nakamura in a
match he looked really good and he has
played in two division ones but today
it's going to be asking a lot from him
he'll only need to win every single game
coming up
honestly that's a huge indicator of how
strong these events are it doesn't no
knock on Jordan's lack of playing
strength he's proven himself time and
time again
but the fact that you can qualify in one
tournament and the next you can barely
make fifty percent just tells you how
ridiculously brutal this field is
all GMS and harsh Suresh is not a GM I
believe feed a master a teenager from
India and well on the rise very clearly
holding a draw against a former tats of
Steel Masters winner in Jordan Von
forest and a great result for white and
a disappointing one for black
yeah there's always a point where you
ultimately come to terms with the fact
that you can't make progress that point
has been reached and a half Point has
been split by the players this was the
last game of the round Robert
and now we enter that phase where we
might see our fair share of quick draws
I mean we've already seen our fair share
of quick draws at the top but I mean top
of the buy right now he is the one who
can't be stopped
and you made this point that when there
are a few people with a certain score
someone has to drop down and we know
that amine will have to drop down to
play the likes of caruana or farugia so
it's going to be a tough matchup for him
no matter which Super gem he faces but
if he can hold if he can make a few
draws here there are only four rounds
remaining he's in good shape to make it
into the top eight and have a chance to
play for division one
for sure I mean six and a half very
likely to propel you to that division so
he needs a couple of draws but you
shouldn't think of it that way right you
shouldn't think oh it's okay for me to
lose the game you don't want to enter
the last round or the penultimate round
needing a particular result and Fabiano
obviously is not going to give away a
quick draw with the white pieces we have
a classic anti Berlin structure or white
quickly quickly trying to expand on the
king side I'm always pretty
uncomfortable in these types of
structures with black
yeah I am not a huge fan myself I know
that it's Theory I know that you can
eventually bring your knight to f8 and
up to E6 and stop the and control the D4
square and make F4 less likely but I
just I know the plans you know I still
feel uncomfortable and I'm just looking
at the pairings by the way so we have uh
car wanting this time to buy we have for
version with the black pieces against
suleimani and Frederick svane still
right up there and taking on Ralph
mahmetov so so many strong GMS in the
mix right now all the way down to 13th
place to get people with four points uh
or more and then Renato Terry Daniel in
14th Place three and a half out of five
wow for that International master who as
I keep saying it's an I am in title only
he's a GM strength player for sure
I also think he's got no losses I think
the one and a half points he's given
away has come through draws we saw him
hold that incredibly difficult difficult
end game against Aram hokobian and this
is what we talked about at the start of
the event right we get a chance to
Spotlight players who otherwise often
fly uh beneath the radar although I
think after the bullet Chess
Championship and after all his title
Tuesday performances Renata Terry is
going to be on everyone's radar unless
you're living under a rock
well we can't all be from SpongeBob so
no I don't think too many rocks are
lived under at least for people watching
the broadcast right now Bishop E3 from
Fabiano what do you make of that
decision because if the bishop takes on
E3 will Fabi take with the pawn opening
up the file for his Rook or let's say
with the Knight so he can put F4 later
and keep his Pawn structure intact
that's exactly the question I was going
to ask you right whether this is a good
or bad move right the nature of Bishop
E3 depends entirely on how he's going to
recapture no not on F3 Daniel but rather
on E3 and I think top of the buy was not
willing to ask that question to Fabi
because he was afraid of the answer and
said he keeps the tension with Queen E7
and one thing Fabi is not gonna do is
take on C5 himself because that trades
entirely on blackstorms you're shaking
your head because the Knight recaptures
on C5 that opens up the diagonal and
this maneuver from E6 the Knight can
access F4 or D4 you want to keep this
Knight restricted and awkward as long as
possible so if black takes on E3 my
guess is that Fabi might want to take
with the Knight and quickly try to push
F4 but I really don't know these
positions are hard to understand
F3
he doesn't want to take out C5 that was
clear and look at times by expanding
with A5 that's a good decision but we've
seen this whether it's the rasa limo or
the white side of what started as an
anti-berlin Fabi enjoys playing against
these Double C pawns that is a
commonality between the games that we've
seen thus far against mametov and here
against tablet Dubai so even though the
evaluation says zeros fobby just has
this preference and we'll see can he
make this work I know in some positions
that White Queen ends up on the C3
Square just to poke and prod at the
black queen side but for now I see no
targets nothing to exploit I think that
amine is playing a very nice game
is indeed and as this game enters it's
early middle game there's a game which
has entered and left the Early Middle
game I don't know how to characterize
the phase that that game is in and
that's the game of Yanda pandushe
against Notre back yakuboyev we haven't
looked at Yan's games quite as much this
tournament
now
is white just losing here or is there
something that I'm missing
where's the material count black is up
one new pawns no two pawns what is what
is this like Yan with the white pieces
okay it was Rook B3 that's a great move
that is a fantastic move because
suddenly the black king is feeling some
heat
it is indeed and it's going to feel even
more heat after Rook takes C3 doubling
up on the e-file there's an exchange
sack waiting to be played on E6 and
black has to put very very careful
thought into where he wants his Queen to
live because at least my inclination is
to drop back to F6 but Robert the
problem with that move is that it leaves
these Queen side pawns unattended so the
issue might be Rook C1 at a later Point
coming around and picking up C6 and once
white eliminates one of Black's extra
pawns the D5 Pawn starts feeling the
heat as well so the best move might
actually be to stick around on white
side of the board with Queen C2 but
that's a hard move to play against
anybody when you're facing Yanda
palmnushi you're very tempted to play
with an abundance of caution but
apparently Queen C2 is the only way to
keep a big Advantage here for black and
I could see a nervous player making the
move Queen takes Rook on B3 because
currently black is up a minor piece and
two pawns so Queen B3 the Knight takes
the queen then the Black Knight E3 takes
the Rook and F1 and you say all right I
will have two Rooks for a queen but I
also have two Rooks and a couple pawns
for the queen though my king isn't
perfectly safe he drops back to F6 can
hardly blame him it is a cautious
approach but as you were suggesting
Donya it does seem like white can take
with the Rook on E3 which runs Bishop to
H3 or Rook to C1 maybe it's not the end
of the world for Yan but black is
colored better Blackwell and minimum be
up one Pawn even if C6 drops you're
exactly right and I think that that is
the likely Arc that this game is going
to take now some newer players
um and it's funny if nepo then plays
this move might be tempted by F take C3
it's always Pleasant to deliver a
discovered attack but fe3 I think is
counterproductive because it closes the
e-file it's a one move threat but Jan
just doing young things right now he is
doing classic young things but is this a
one move threat that can be safely
parried with Rook C8 is black in time to
get this King out of the center
I'm trying to figure out what exactly he
is aiming for I mean Rook C8 Rook takes
E3 that Rook on state would be loose
because the bishop on E6 would be pinned
but then black plays Bishop E7 and
Castle's King side very quickly so
maybe there's something to that
somewhere where like if you Castle the
bishop and E7 is loose in some of these
positions but I don't really believe in
it
I feel like there's a little element of
Hope chess in the way that John is
playing right now I think he's
calculated until Rook C8 and he just
hopes that something is going to
materialize as it so often does in his
tactical games but if we just look at it
move by move right Brook C8 okay white
eventually does have to recapture on E3
black plays Bishop E7 blocking the
e-file making Queen takes C in
impossible
I don't see a move here for white white
runs out of ways to keep The Black Gang
tied in the center and if you play a
move like Rook fe1 black Castle's King
side yeah White's probably gonna
recapture the pawn on A7 but after
something like Rook A8 Robert you've got
connected passers in the center and even
if you exchange C6 for A3 black is not
risking Black's got a very compact
Arrangement here on the center and I
think Jan might be on the cusp of having
a technically lost position if black can
get this King out of the center safely
looks really really bad and while Yan
struggles to hold this game I just want
to point out that Min lay won very
quickly and if we can pull up his game
potentially move 17 was a sweet tactic
from wonderful time he had a blast with
that one look at this Donya after this
position oh he's he went Rook FCA that's
the setup move Selena is just playing
like nothing's the matter Rook 8 you
want and bang
Knight takes D4 Mike Breen somewhere is
very happy about that because bang the
Knight on F3 takes Queen H2 delivers a
Checkmate on H1 and if you take with a
Pawn on D4 you lose your queen on C2 so
1964 loses The Rook too it was a one
move shot that was overlooked and then
Min quickly won
wow Min Lee it's just oh and queen A6 I
mean he was on fire this game this
essentially either forces the queen
trade or forces White's Queen back
Salinas ending up giving up another
exchange and didn't take long for men to
convert is to extra rook's big big game
and Min Lee putting himself in great
position to potentially make his way
into the top division very very
impressive
um of the other top games that we have
going which we haven't looked at yet we
have Suleiman against for Russia maybe a
quick look at this game it's not a
particularly enterprising position looks
like Ali is just up a pawn
uh yep your math is correct white king
is in more shape black is Apple pawn and
queen D7 keeps everything together so
this looks very unpleasant for suleimani
so farouza trying to get the job done
that Levon aronian couldn't against the
young opponent but it looks very very
nice for alireza who would love to jump
to five and after the six
indeed he's gonna play rookie eight this
Knight on F6 has tremendous prospects on
the king side if you look at all these
weak light squares then I can jump to E4
it can jump to G4 for attacking purposes
this is the kind of position that we're
so used to the top players converting
regularly so I'll give you uh the wheel
here Robert where should we go from here
we've got the Fabby game which has been
pretty balanced all the way through but
we also have a lot of other top games
that have been very combative we only
have like one or two quick draws on the
top 10 boards I love to see that
yeah no we have fights and it's because
it's still early stages here when
players get a couple more victories they
may think all right I'll sail into the
top eight but right now you don't know
what's going on by the way Jana Palm she
is toast like completely done completely
toast that game let's take a look
it's just crushing for yakubayev and you
know what happened Donya I think I
understand the error of Yan's ways that
he thought he was going to have a an
opportunity to win the bishop on E7 if
we can just very quickly go back to
around 21
just very quickly here so he was Queen
B7
he doesn't even take the pawn
and at this moment after Castle he
thought Rook F3
kicks the queen away
but he overlooked not Queen D4 which
runs into Knight B3 and white does win
that piece but he missed Queen H6 which
hits that Knight on D2 the Knight
doesn't get a Tempo against the queen
you take E7 you lose D2 black is up
material that's such a great spot by you
because without this piece of
information Yan's play makes no sense
right why would he go Queen A6 why would
he help black protect the C6 pawn and it
definitely is the reason after Queen H6
Yan had no choice but to take the bishop
right find take Rook B1 but now you're
just down two pawns and what two pawns
they are two connected passers in the
center and all you could boil has to do
is set those Pawns in motion I think
White's Only Hope here might be the
clock situation John is up five minutes
on the clock I think he's the only
person who's up five minutes on the
clock in a rapid game but the issue is
that this position is so easy for black
to play Rook cde8 very circumspect move
right you didn't want to go D2 and allow
complications with Rook takes C6 even if
black is actually still winning by
moving the queen away to A1 defending
the G7 Pawn why seek these Adventures
against someone as tactically gifted and
as tricky as Yon
yeah because you have to invest a lot of
time just double triple checking Rook to
E8 simply defends the bishop in his
place there's no attack that I can see
if you attack the D3 Pawn with Queen D6
then I slam my Rook over to d8 and I'm
protecting my past pawn and helping it
to the other side of the board you're
ushering it so I just don't see a plan
for nepo here I do think that yakubayev
is completely winning and I would be
very very very surprised if yakubov
doesn't actually secure Victory I would
be surprised as well three minutes is
plenty of time for a player has
experienced in online Blitz as yakuboy
of so a huge huge win this would be with
the black pieces uh by Notre Beck
putting himself in great position for
the final three rounds and a couple of
other top players are in grade position
Frederick savane was leading the
tournament before his loss to I mean
tabara by shell week look at his attempt
to redeem himself
and redeem himself he is not going to I
think
no and if actually if you just go back
like one full move that white took a
Pawn on E5 with his last turn and Ralph
says I actually sacrificed upon there to
free up my Bishop to win your trapped
Rook on e4 if you go Rook H4 the D3 Pawn
Falls and you're just losing all sorts
of material uh maybe not right away in
the bishop E3 check first but the point
is your position is collapsing
yeah top players who seem to have their
pieces on ideal squares at all times
look at the coordination between all of
black spaces and I love the placement of
the queen right it may seem like Black's
worst piece but the queen is just kind
of in the shadows directing the war
effort it's protecting D4 it's
pressuring E5 it's sort of the glue
piece in this position while you know
the minor pieces and the Rooks are doing
uh the Dirty Work of jumping into
White's territory and actually
eliminating the pawns that are holding
White's position together and we do have
Rook H4 and Albert I actually think
black can potentially take on D3 right
away and he already does because of that
Queen on C5 x-raying The Rook I don't
know when you play D3 maybe as early as
in the next two moves just play Bishop
takes E2 and D3 check and can I show an
interesting line after Rook takes H6 I
think Bishop B2 Bishop B2 D3 and if
Bishop F2 look at this idea Rook takes
F2
Queen takes F2 and simply on takes E2
beautiful position Queen takes C15 E1
equals Queen Checkmate my friends
I think in my mind well the bishop was
on F1 in those positions and with the
bishop on E2 while it's clearly just
came over with D3 and as you point out a
temporary Rook sack for Bishop it's all
happening and then it's game over all of
it so Ralph has played an excellent day
of Chess he survived that game against
five in a carwana so not really a
surprise to see him in in the thick of
things he's made it to division one uh
before and he would like to get right
back there
and we see a frustrated Fred xvane on
camera there that is how quickly your
fortunes can change in these brutal
events you're on four out of four top of
the leaderboard suddenly you're on four
out of six and you're basically in the
middle of the pack and the worst thing
is that you're probably gonna play
somebody with a 2600 plus rating in the
next round so once you start backsliding
in this event it's so so hard to get out
of the tailspin
yeah and you then need to score
victories because you still want to
cling on to those hopes of making to
division one but then when you're
playing for wins you're not really being
objective and this position that we have
between Fabi and Amin it's objectively
equal I actually am starting like
Black's position here uh the black king
could find itself vulnerable at some
point but the a pawn is being threatened
directly so is Fabi going to switch to
the D file with some kind of doubling of
the Rooks I don't think you're in time
for that so what is white going to do in
this position
well I guess White's only source of
counter play is the weak black king on
GA you are going to lose the A4 Pawn
just mathematically right black has one
two three attackers and white cannot
involve a third defender on this Pawn
right why does one tempo short if the
Rook was on A3 maybe white could have
doubled on the a file and black is going
to take the pawn with his Pawn in order
to accelerate its progress the B file
will open Robert when black does that so
maybe white can preemptively put his
Queen on B2 maybe something like Rook a
B1 could even be considered in order to
infiltrate the seventh rank in the event
the black takes with the b-pawn but I
feel like that's a little bit
speculative
Bobby goes more mainstream he goes down
Main Street attacking the Knight on D7
but what's his follow-up if black drops
that night back to f8 does he want to go
Bishop B6 and Force black to capture on
A4 with the Rook
yeah maybe his Bishop gets those new
squares B6 or C5 and I in fact went up
to F6 but then finally move his Queen
decent that was a pretty sizable mistake
from time to buy of course entering the
game you'll make a draw with blackens
five behind a car one he just signed me
up but this feels like the title of the
game is turning and it went from Clear
Advantage black to something maybe
blacks needs to be a bit careful as all
those pawns are in dark squares and
white has a dark Square Bishop that can
start attacking them at some point and
Black's King could get unexpectedly
caught in the crossfire even with the
Queens off the board so we're probably
gonna seeking F7 White's gonna take on
C6 and the other Rook could drop into D1
suddenly you have all these annoying
ladder Checkmate threats and one Rook
coming to the seventh the other to the
sixth we could get a very tactical
Affair here with Black's a pawn rushing
down the board and white trying to use
those two or three Tempi that he has in
order to generate threats against
Black's King Rook takes a four
oh and what a move by five you're just
moving The Rook away and saying yeah
congrats you got the a file but you
don't have a past Pawn after all and
after Rook takes C6 I would probably
take white here by a smidge
yeah I mean white has a bishop against a
knight although Black's King is very
safe now Rook B6 Rook takes C3 Rook
takes B5 and that E5 Pawn being on a
dark Square it's just a little bit
uncomfortable to deal with and I think
with ensuing time trouble I would prefer
to have the white side here it's
objectively equal we can see that uh
they're not that many pieces remaining
in fact the fact in fact the fact that
just tripped me up but what I was going
to say is that having pawns only on one
side of the board is helpful for the
Knight but now those Pawns of the queen
side's still on the board that's bad
news for me and he can't take on C3
because Bishop E1 and that's a skewer in
the diagonal indeed and suddenly I mean
is as his hands full he's got all these
issues
and
it's gone Rook C to A4 now he's got this
weird awkward arrangement of Rooks and
his seventh and sixth ranks are open
what's holding Fabiano back is that you
can't move this Rook up from D1 or the
time being because black is going to
drop into A1 and win the bishop on F2
but can Fabby coordinate his Rooks in
time maybe he wants to throw in an H4
I don't know things getting really
heated here as the players clocks
dwindling even further down
and finally brings this King close to
the center and this is what has been
allowing Amin to stay even in terms of
material this Rook A1 idea they're a
back ranked Checkmate threat so Bobby's
Bishop back on E1 the C3 Pawn is well
guarded but how do you get out of this
for White You're Gonna Go King E2 Bishop
D2 King D3 kind of slowly inch forward
and the B5 Pawn is under attack so Rook
B1 is the move that comes to my mind but
I think Bobby's gonna play C4 as a
response and that wins him a pawn
it does indeed
and I mean minute on the clock
how do you defend you might have to give
up the B5 pawn and generate counter play
on the king side that's what he's trying
to do Robert what threat does this move
create it might actually make his Pawn
chain even weaker after Rook takes B5
and it gives white the H4 Square for the
bishop so if you give white two moves
King E2 and Bishop H4 I feel like black
is in huge trouble at that moment so I'm
starting with King E2 Rook A2 check I
mentioned you could play Bishop D2 as
your response white is up a pawn and
playing without risk
playing without risk indeed and so Fabi
keeps extending the game he could have
repeated moves there has no interest in
doing so I will interrupt our discussion
of this game briefly and say that
janapanishi has managed to win back one
uh of the two pawns that he was lacking
it is very close to drawing the game but
I mean is trying to force things and he
just wanted a bishop oh he missed King
E3 completely it's one of those ideas
like oh King takes F3 I'm down upon an
end game I can hold and then you'll
probably plays King E3 as a cold shower
F2 Rook B1 as you've highlighted that
just wins the game for Fabi you can see
the relief from him huge victory for
Fabiano caruana as he'll go to five and
a half out of six with frugia
what a great patient game it felt like
he was getting outplayed but he seized
his opportunity some amazing Rook play a
little bit earlier to prevent black from
getting a pass pawn and can't really
blame I mean for panicking that's just
what these top guys do great tournament
for Fabi and he is knocking on the door
one of his best CCT qualifier
performances yet
and janapomsi survived that game
unbelievable speed right paid off for
him and where to next time I see a few
more games are going Jeffrey Zhang is
playing as Alexander Shimano for example
and what is that game between yessa
Panko and Meyer
your guess is as good as Myers
oh gosh Daniel that was not bad at all I
have to give it to you but this game is
absolutely crazy where I'm trying to do
a quick material count it looks like
white is down a piece
for one Pawn but those D and C pawns are
very dangerous
yeah I mean jeez it's very dangerous
they're gonna go D6 D7 and Shove It Down
Black's face here
black is up a full piece here but it
doesn't feel that way at all he's given
away the exchange why could have taken
that Rook instead he plays the
unnecessary D6 allowing black to give it
away for another Pawn very strange
decision there by Meyer by yes and panko
he's got no time at all
yeah he's trying to get his Rook down to
D7 he's going for the Queen the queen
what whoa whoa yeah rookies
oh and white could have dropped back to
D1 there oh seven Queen F7 he missed it
yeah he had a crazy pieces you could
have taken on F7 and then won the queen
he would have been up in exchange but
now it's all georgmeyer
that was a win on the spot for Andre
essapenko now Meyer is all over him it's
still not completely over but White's
running out of attacking ideas against
Black's King which is completely safe
blanketed by these two Bishops now it's
over
yeah the bee Pawn also I was just pushed
upon the B2 Bishop A2 is a threat that's
not Queen F5 that should get the job
done he goes for that uh move and that's
completely winning for black
amazing how it's so much easier from the
side we see that evolve bar swing up you
see immediately what the winning move
was and it came in this moment E4 both
Queens are hanging you need to look for
Desperado sex and Desperado sex exist
here after Rook takes D6 black can
resign on the spot that's how quickly
Fortune change and what a win for
jorgmeyer with the black pieces again
someone as strong as Andre asapenko
who's defeated Magnus Carlson before In
classical chess and Desperado times if
you take Desperado measures Dania and
that was the Tactical Motif that was not
found in this game
incredible York Meyer wins I think that
might have been
the last game oh there's actually a
couple of games still remaining let's
flip on demidov against sam7 another
crazy time scramble Sam he's been
struggling this tournament but a couple
of wins in the last rounds can Propel
some of the players who are on 50 right
now to a very solid performance and and
make their way into division two don't
miss a fork Mikhail don't go King C3
don't do that oh it's so difficult it's
so nerve-wracking yeah and also this is
a great illustration of what I keep
saying this is not even material this is
black up two pawns on the king side
white up two Pawns of the queen side but
white pawns they haven't moved just yet
maybe it's time to start and he pushes
B4 and black can't play G4 because
Knight F4 is loose
and I really like these lower board
games because you see players playing
such uncompromising chess Savion knows
that you really can't afford to give up
another draw if he wants to make
division two at the least so he keeps
finding ways to prolong the game and
prolong the game and win one of White's
puns yes just Russ
what is the follow-up to that there's 93
checks 93 free King C3 though The Rook
also hangs Rook C4 you can't go back to
B6
oh he went there first then she was made
nice oh
look at that
that is hard to accept but beautiful to
take in that is an aesthetically
pleasing mating pattern
we have the game's still going it looks
like this round has been going on
forever I'm not not complaining because
we got a lot of fascinating end games to
conclude this round one of them is Jones
against Serana I think this one's just a
dead draw
correct me if I'm wrong I like what
Alexi's doing though is he's not pushing
his Pawn to A2 just yet because then
that is a very clear draw so he's
keeping outside chances for his King to
Sprint from F7 up the board but that is
why going Jones not giving any checks he
does not want to allow the black king up
to the sixth rank so yes this should
certainly be a draw if Alaska Wayne
blunders and I wanted a very quick shout
to uh Constantine lupolescu who beat
Vladimir krumnik with black and Luke
Alaska played in the grand chess tour he
lost pretty much every game he played
like he was getting pummeled by the
highest rate of players in chess and yet
he always seemed like he was having a
good time gaining experience and the
experience paid off right here today
where he beat krumnik with the black
pieces so you know sometimes these GMS
they suffer against the hands of the
mighty whoa what what is this Alexi
serrana was flirting with disaster here
this was actually an only series of
moves to win the H1 all right Alexi time
to make that draw yeah now the draw is
going to be agreed to but yeah I just
wanted to finish my thought that uh
lupolescu he had such a miserable
performance against the best players in
the world so to see him just right back
at it taking down Vladimir kramnik
that's pretty awesome
it is indeed and it's never easy to be
in that position of being the lower
rated player he was handling himself
very gracefully and obviously using that
experience positively and harnessing it
using it to play really really well in
this tournament thus far we are in for
an incredibly exciting last couple of
rounds
we certainly are I'm excited I mean look
at the top of the leaderboard here we
have caruana farrugia they have to play
each other with five and a half out of
six each then it means happened to buy
Ralph momentum Min late and do you see
that we're not so Terry has four and a
half out of six
he's won again
and who did he beat he beat
looking for him I'm gonna find him right
now I'll tell you in one second oh my
gosh he still hasn't lost a single game
okay but not only that he hasn't just
made drazy beat kovalenko yeah he beat
kovalenko he beats Serana he beat Jordan
Von Forrest Renato Terry can't stop
won't stop will he be in the matches for
division one now that would be something
I that would be the first time an
international Master is in division one
and might be the only time in chess
history that I am is in a tournament
this strong but people ask me on my
stream why is Renata not a GM and I
never have an answer I don't think there
is an answer to that question yeah
paperwork not playing over the board
enough his strength is clear but Fabiano
caruana is taking on alireza faruja
right now and that could mean we get an
epic Clash between two of the best
players on the planet or at some point
they'll offer a draw because they're
both doing so well so which one will it
be done in
yeah honestly given the opening I feel
like we've got a good chance of a
combative game if Ali Reza wanted to
draw my coach always told me that one E4
although it has a reputation as a more
aggressive opening than one T4 it's also
more forcing and the top players know
all of the most forcing lines they know
how to make a draw in one E4 so the fact
that alireza played the English tells me
that he wants a more open-ended position
he wants to play for a win and he feels
confident that he can outplay Fabby with
the white pieces in a strategic battle
well we'll see if his gutsy decision
turns out to be rewarding and we know
Fabi very well and I've spoken to him
about this at length he doesn't like
taking quick draws like you don't see
that from him with the black pieces if
you're opponent force it sure alireza
himself not really the type of player
who makes quick draws he likes to fight
so in this game it's very early stages
here I think that black typically puts a
Pawn on C6 just make sure that the
Center is nice and well done offended
and also white is kind of threatening
threatening is a little strong but
Knight B5 could be annoying in some
positions so C6 reinforced to the center
takes care of any Knight hops I think
that it's just early stages and if you
find a more fascinating opening battle
please take us there yeah Knight H5
actually making that opening battle a
little bit more fascinating upon
Sacrifice by Fabiano carawan alireza
immediately grabs the pawn on D5 and
says I am calling her Bluff what does
Fabi get in return for the pawn well he
gets the bishop pair and obviously
White's King has been weakened a little
bit by the removal of the Pawn on G3 but
I'll be honest with you I almost called
you Fabby I'm very skeptical about this
Pawn sack Ali razigo Z3 he's gonna
follow up with D4 and really clamp down
on this E5 Square I'm not really seeing
the compensation here for Fabi at all
I don't understand it like he doubled
his opponent's pawns the white king may
have a little bit of air in front of it
but there's nothing to do with it so I
was looking at C6 I mentioned that move
I don't like this decision from Fabiano
I wonder if he mixed up variations or he
just assumed that he would have the
necessary counter play to stabilize but
he's just down a pawn and I think white
is very clearly better
but I've also just been a blunder maybe
he forgot the FR Bishop was defended
right from our perspective we think
that's odd but it's a long tournament
the player's starting to get a little
bit tired and Bobby now has his work cut
out for him and another player who's got
his work cut out from is Yanda pomichi I
want to take another look at his opening
which has been all over the map today
it's been crazy position after crazy
position a king's Gambit essayed by Yana
pop machine opening that he has been
playing religiously in Rapid chess he
did a course on it this is not nepo
fooling around this is Nepal playing an
opening that often gets poo pooed but is
often poorly studied by some of the top
players
yeah and the position that he has on the
board you wouldn't even know necessarily
came from a king and the white king is
jetting out of the center if you allow
me to I'm gonna Castle Queen side just
next and that black king is in some
danger so cast and queen side very
natural here and I think black split F3
you need to tie down some of White's
pieces because the structure is clearly
preferable for white A7 and C6 are split
E6 is a target so I'm playing F3 I don't
know how I'm following it up but I'm
starting with that pawn push
yeah I think F3 is is largely a
no-brainer I guess you could start by
taking on C3 but there's no point in
doing that either White's obviously not
going to play Knight takes D5 here in
fact that would lose the game to a very
instructive tactic Queen takes Bishop
check then black recaptures the queen
and then both the rook and the Knight
are hanging so nepo's gonna move his
Queen where is he gonna put it Queen E4
comes to mind Queen C4 clearing the E4
Square for his Knight I think that makes
sense as well but maybe Frost and I can
stick a bishop on E5 to really take the
sting out of any potential night Sally
yeah Bishop E5 is a very lovely move
Queen takes C6 would run right into Rook
coming to C8 and then it's the white
king in danger but Jan I don't know if
this is prep or he just feels like
making move it moves instantly every
single time just yawn things but it
looks good for white I see the eval bar
suggesting it's level I don't have that
same sense because I I do think that the
black pawns despite having a passer
they're more vulnerable
yeah I don't have that sense at all
because
even if black plays F2 I'm with you that
pawn looks menacing but White's Knight
can maybe travel from A4 exchange on B2
and eventually make its way to D3 and
the moment black loses the F Pawn that's
the pride of his position Black's gonna
be left with you know a bunch of dead
pawns all over the position so Yan can
continue improving with Rook de1 maybe
you can slide the king over to B1
although then you're allowing Knight
takes with checks so no I think you
should move the Rook away from the D
file yeah makes sense to me and I just
want to quickly I know it's a player we
want to watch Young Department I want to
look at a means Habit to buy against
minlay because I mean lost to Fabiano
caruana but look at his position right
now against Min and Min won a very quick
game in the previous round against
Salinas but look at this it's horrible
for black Black's not even up any
material and the King on H7 is in huge
trouble
a mean against men
okay well I mean this does look pretty
bad for black white is
yeah not up a pawn it looks like white
sup upon but he's not the problem is
just the long-term safety of the king as
you're pointing out Robert and one plan
involves dropping the bishop back and
then moving this queen not like a knight
but rather like a bishop and then like a
rook over to the H file the Knight on F3
can jump to G5 really on demand there's
nothing the black can do to protect that
square so I think the key for Amin is to
make sure that his Bishop stays alive
because that is really the glue piece
that's ensuring access 24-hour access to
the G5 square and he puts the bishop on
that square
I think he's then gonna put his Knight
on E5 which is an alternate Arrangement
uh that's very very effective this this
is losing or mean what a disaster
yeah Minton is just
me
I was being pretty mean to him you were
but I know you and men are great friends
Mindy such a wholesome streamer uh
really just a fantastic player uh has
been proving himself well in the match
against Magnus Carlson the bullshits
championship but right now it's not his
game and I know we're jumping around a
bunch but the game between Fabi and Ali
Reza that has become increasingly sharp
where at first we were wondering what
Fabiano was doing but when you drop
pawns you clear lines and that Rook on
A8 is now on H6
and his position has improved
exponentially continues to improve
autographs is kind of tilting away this
game he's just played the move F5 in
order to slice off the black Bishop but
that's created another Target Bobby with
Queen H4 he can play G6 Robert and try
to reopen that diagonal and once the
bishop lands on H3 you're dealing with
potentially Unstoppable mate threats
also what hurts white is that that
Bishop on B4 guards the E1 Square so I'm
envisioning a scenario where if White's
gang makes a run for the center its path
toward the center has been narrowed even
further by Black's control over dark
squares on the queen side G6 is an
excellent move and I just want to do an
instant replay to show how the Rook got
over there because it was a pawn dropped
in the center and we'll just go through
the moves we don't have to analyze them
but it's fun to note that that Rook came
from A8 he went with his Pawn to A4 and
The Rook decided to slide up to A5 and
then swing over to H5
and I love that he played A3 first
that's such a super GM move first you
induce some Kings some dark Square
weaknesses on the queen side then you
swing The Rook over to H5 and the rook's
not done yet it Parks itself on a safer
Square then look at the play on both
sides yeah eval bar calls this move a
mistake but I like it sticks the bishop
on the weak Square Ali Reza losing the
threat of the game and G6 is on the
board by Fabi he's on fire and the way
that he was able to manufacture threats
against Dwight's King from what looked
like a no compensation position is so
impressive he is on fire this tournament
playing super super well I think from
what we've seen yeah there was some
positions that were even that he end up
winning like against I mean Tabitha to
buy and then against Ralph momentov he
was better and he couldn't convert that
Advantage but five and a half of the six
with the black piece against alireza
faroo is a huge Advantage for him and
another tactical point in this position
Dania is that the Knight on e4 kind of
needs to they put because if it moves
Knight takes E3 is available to Black
and then G3 Knight is loose
yeah I don't see a move for white I mean
you can't really play F takes G6 we've
determined that that's completely out of
the question you have to keep this Pawn
on F5 because at the very least if black
takes on F5 you buy yourself one more
Tempo but that's all you get Robert
because that pawn is going to move on to
F4 and kind of throw itself into the
waste basket in order to open up the
diagonal for the bishop White
is knocking on the door of just losing
this within a couple of moves so maybe
you do have to play Knight C5 so that at
least G takes F5 doesn't come with tempo
right but after Knight C5 I'll probably
take your knight on C5 and
if you take the queen then I take on F5
with the pawn and I continue my attack
and if you take with the pawn on C5 I
was thinking then I go for my knight
takes E3 idea where black I think must
be better in those positions because
White's Pawn structure is so weak
indeed and after Queen takes G3 the E
Pawn will be hanging the H Pawn will
also be capturable by the black Rook
wow this this might just be game over
Red Rover within a couple of moves here
and farooza needs to dig deep right now
he needs to find a concrete plan because
if you continue to flounder Bobby's plan
is simple take on a five play F4 take on
H3 deliver Checkmate it's really that
straightforward
it really is and he's now building up a
time advantage and ic5 has been played
apparently the only way to keep chances
alive and Knight takes E3 straight away
by Fabiano very tempting move but this
is a very important resource for alireza
bringing the Rook up knocking the queen
back to G5 and buying himself one more
Tempo that he can use to maybe try to
generate counter play on the other side
against this hanging Bishop on before
really not sure
yeah the spawn F5 is now vulnerable you
the queen need to move first but if you
take on G6 which you just did I'm not
sure if I take with the pawn and he's
paused this is not the first time today
we have seen super Grand Masters in
moments where I would have pre-moved
h6g6 without question let me fix my Pawn
structure capture toward the center
that's what my coach taught me he might
take with the Rook on G6 and go for a
pin along he doesn't I mean Ed great
call just super instructive stuff from
him where now alireza is trying
desperately to defend to bring all his
pieces to the king side and you can't
take on H3 just yet but maybe there's a
place for this queen to drop to like
Queen H6 so you can play Bishop takes H3
move later
and of course you have the both
attacking and defensive idea of tucking
the king away on h8 bringing it to a
safer square but also vacating the G8
Square for the rook and increasing the
massive pressure on this G2 Bishop I'm
totally with you some of the recaptures
in this tournament have been Ultra
impressive the pauses knowing when to
pause sensing hidden moments when you
can make a really good move and then
actually acting on that thinking and
resisting the temptation to play a move
that as you said I would have played it
automatically a lot of players would but
that's what makes Fabi Abby and this is
not what makes Fabby Fabia I'm surprised
he's traded Queens maybe trying to play
a little bit too cautiously here maybe
looking at the bishop pair as a huge
Advantage but the pawn structure is bad
for black now I want to pull my Rook
back on H6 and put my Pawn on G6 if
you're going to trade Queens I would
like to have a better Pawn structure
show for it
it feels like it's very incongruent what
he's done on the last move and what he
did on the move before that if you're
playing where it takes G6
I'll be honest I thought Queen H6 or
queen H5 was a no-brainer I thought the
choice was between where you're
retreating your queen not between
retreating your queen and trading and it
doesn't even feel like white is that
much worse to be honest anymore I like
the bishop pair that's what I'll say for
black but I just don't like the pawn
structure at all and this Knight will
eventually go back to D3 that frees the
bishop to go back to a square like E7
but rerouting the Knight could be a bit
annoying for black to deal with so the
good news for Fabi is he's not in danger
the bad news is most of his Advantage
has been thrown away
and a big sigh of relief by alireza
farouza as Fabi decides to take the
Queens off the board they will keep
playing this end game
and I'm kind of looking around the horn
we have a couple of peaceful results
Ralph momentov draws uh top Spanish
latasa
we have that nepo fresenate game which
seems to be headed in a peaceful
direction as well yawned with seven
minutes to his opponent's one but
there's only so much you can do when you
play this fast and it looks like Jan he
had some chances at some point but I
think Laurent is going to draw this with
a minute on his clock and fresenane beat
Magnus Carlson the last time I was
watching uh him play in these events so
he's
experienced in these Champion chess tour
plans and if he is able to secure the
draw which he should be able to do he'll
go to five out of seven and he's got a
puncher's chance of winning some games
down the stretch and making it to the
match play for division one
and a lot of very impressive
performances in this tournament thus far
Alexander bortek my good friend is doing
super well he draws Eduardo rizalga on
board five so he keeps himself in the
loop but let's look at Renato Terry
because this kid is amazing
and unfortunately for Renato it looks
like his amazing run oh it's not coming
to an end he still has two more games
after this one but I think Lavon is
knocking on the door of a big win with a
black pieces and levonis struggled a bit
he lost that game in suleimanley and you
know what his reward was after losing
Aiden Aiden played kareel lexenko he
beat alexenko but can you imagine to
losing to suleimanley I think okay I'll
get maybe someone 2400 no you get
another 2700 there he beats him now he's
ahead against Renato Terry and Levon is
back and you see by the scoreboard if he
wins he goes to five out of seven and
that puts him into the top eight
Lavon not resisting the temptation of
threatening Rook takes H2 oh we're
seeing white screen oh my God
Queen sack please oh no my queen where's
Eric Rosa now oh blundered is Queen
blundered is Rook wait The Rook is
defended the queen is indirectly
defended
and now I think it's time to trade
queens and smack on H3 move to H2 move
to the other side and start hunting down
these vulnerable queenside Pawns looks
simple he could also play Rook G3 Rook
takes G1 he is of a pawn but I wouldn't
go for that
yeah you never know right allowing this
outside passer White's Knight is in very
good position to jump to B5 and pave the
way for a potential a pawn to move down
to A7 so I'm with you I think he's gonna
go Rook H2 but again Levon taking his
time these players they're so good at
identifying when the critical moments
occur and you can assess that by their
thinking patterns it's Fabby when he
played Rook takes G6 and alaban not
making an automatic move knowing that
the decision he makes now will have a
direct bearing on how easy it'll be to
convert this advantage and Rook H2 is
the result yes the right decision he was
probably looking can I calculate this
game to his conclusion in which case
Rook G3 takes G1 might be it but why
trade look at this position he is well
ahead he can trade Rooks a bit later if
he wants and he can just go after the
hanging white pawns but Knight B5 that's
an annoying move because that protects
A3 and you can't kick the Knight off
that square
yeah that B4 Pawn acts as kind of an
umbrella right you can put the Rook on
B2 but where do you go from there I
think the key to the kingdom here is to
involve the king side pawns right you've
got a four on two on the king side as
one Robert Hess would say you're two
pawns up on the king side one Pawn down
on the queen side but White's pawns
aren't going anywhere the moment white
plays A4 black is gonna put the Rook
behind the pawn and all you're gonna do
is lose the only source of potential
rescue that you have so Renato
might want to go Rook G2 you might want
to try to activate his Rook via G4 until
it's too before it's too late
but I mean with 50 seconds left I don't
see him holding this Tanya my jaw
dropped and the reason why is Yonder
Palm she won that end game
Jan won it's it's the club no way the
clock is I don't look at that game
you know it just wasn't enough time for
freshina to figure things out and he
ended up into a lost rook and pawn
versus rook and pawn ending
yeah this moment was uh when refreshing
they could have forced to draw with the
Rook B5 but 50 seconds you're playing
yawn he let the king get a little bit
too active that's just what the punish
he does and he wins a huge game
okay so he is in the mix as well I mean
top of the boys still hasn't won his
game but I think he is about to against
minli who's been struggling really since
the first moves of this game yeah an
extra exchange for white a very safe
King for one side and it's not Min so
this looks like it should be mop up Duty
with the lead on the clock as well so
where else should we turn to I mean so
many big battles in this field Fabi
against faruga still going on
where do you want to turn
yeah Fabi farusha is really interesting
we have Meyer Oparin on one of the top
boards but that's a pretty
straightforward game let's go back to
Abby's gaming inspiration let's see how
that end game is doing because both
sides are now below two minutes on the
clock really raises the Intrigue of this
end game Knight F4 has just been played
by faruga what do you make of this
position
at first I think that white should be
better because I like White's activity
Black's pieces The Rook on G6 under
attack uh the bishop on C8 is at home
but the A3 Pawn is defended and it's
pretty much a thorn in white side
because at some point you have to be
very careful not to allow like a bishop
E6 takes B3 some end games that look
just like a draw are even better for
white you miss a tactic like that that
past pawn it could be a runner so Rook
H6 is a good start you need to keep your
Dark Sword Bishop of your Fabi but I
don't necessarily see a plan for either
side and considering wearing blitzed on
you that means it's quite likely that
mistakes are gonna happen
they're definitely going to start
happening and your point is very well
taken about Bishop E6 Bishop takes B3
that's not just a speculative idea I
think Rook trades are in Black's favor
precisely for that reason the more
pieces are gone the easier it is to
clear the traffic and just go Bishop E6
and threaten the sack on B3 so in the
event that Fabi moves his Bishop away
from C8 which is very likely I would try
to keep everything on the board I would
go back to A5 and keep a very close eye
on this A3 Pawn but Bishop yeah Rook A5
is good because Bishop F5 is also an
idea to go Bishop B1 so oh the residents
need to be very careful for instance if
you play Rook A7 thinking that you know
you've stopped that Bishop from moving
because B7 is loose there is an
opportunity to think about Bishop I'm
not sure it works because the black king
is in some danger but the point is
Bishop F5 Bishop B1 that at least has to
scare you and frigid now down to 47
seconds and he plays Pawn to E4 which
you know is getting active but he's
loosening up control as well
and of course black cannot take on e4
because you dropped the bishop on C8 and
that pawn is gonna run it run its way up
to E5 ferrugia using the limited
resources at his disposal to generate
active counter play and in the blink of
an eye Robert both sides are now below a
minute
it's going to be scramble time and I
think that Fabi he needs to find a plan
right now because in the bullet Chess
Championship and other scrambles we have
seen him struggle whereas farugia we
know what he's capable of he beat Magnus
in the BCC but Bishop B7 great move you
said it Rook trades favor Black
and they do and we've got one pair of
Rooks off the board the other Rook is
awkwardly placed on H6 but it is
controlling a couple of important
squares on the sixth rank will alireza
bring his Pawn up to E5 well the
drawback of that move is that it reopens
the pathway for Black's Bishop from F5
to B1 as you pointed out and so farouza
adopting a more defensive posture but it
feels like Fabi is taking over the
initiative and maybe now is the time to
reinvolve the rook and make it rejoin
Society oh and you want Rook takes B3
like 10
first now how is he gonna
increase the pressure Bishop E6 watch
out Bishop takes P3 doesn't work because
Rook F1 at the end for white but that
Rook can't go to F1 now because H3 is
loose so it looks like
white is dealing with a lot on both
sides of the board
for sure and when you're in a Time
scramble like this you want to set up
potential threats yeah Bishop takes B3
is not possible now but it's so easy to
forget about this move a little bit
later and Fabi just filigree Precision
moving the Bishop from the inside to the
king side F5 F5 yes chip away at the
center and that pawn on D4 was loose
there but he goes Rook H6 he wants to go
over to F6 it would see him and he look
at that move I love Bishop C8 you're
under attack just defend B7 now bring
your Dark Sword Bishop back and he's
just creating problems for white move
after move
the Bishops are like a slinky moving
back in concert and now moving forward
again that Bishop on E6 is now firmly
entrenched it can't be chased Away by
white spawns because White's got this
big big hole on D5 or we should treading
water but can Fabi take on H3 here he
can because he can his Bishop H4 he
finds it Rook H1 looks like it wins
material G2 but oh Bishop G2 wins the 90
for a good point by you I thought Bishop
H4 was necessary but you are absolutely
right Bishop takes G2 so we see The
Bishop's off I'll raise it down to two
seconds and uh
oh and Fabby can just move his King up
he's got this beautiful path along he's
got this red brick Yellow Brick Road
along the light squares and instead he's
forcing The Rook trade uh no he's just
gonna win A2 oh there is it he thought
I'm just dead lost so the Rooks come off
the board but he's also completely lost
with the Rooks on so Fabi as long as he
doesn't blunder he should take this one
home
this is an incredible performance by
Fabiano caruana yeah he traded queens
that was a mistake but then he outplayed
farrugia from scratch in this end game
banking on his Bishop pair and I think
he'll take the Knight and start running
that H Pawn up the board too much going
on on both sides of the board this is
what they call trousers in Russian chess
literature two past pawns either side
not enough pieces to stop them and D5 A
desperate attempt but H3 H2 happens too
quickly and that means Fabiano caruana
is about to move to six and a half out
of seven what a well played game from
Fabi
incredible and he's just finishing it
off with one accurate move after another
like we said he's been topsy-turvy and
time scrambles but you wouldn't know he
is this is just perfect play by I mean
look at this A1 rookie one and H1 or you
can start with rookie one that's the
final move of the game and you see a
smile on fabi's face it must feel really
nice for him instead of collapsing in a
Time scramble to get that win over
alireza farisa who looks like he's ready
to go play a pickup game of basketball
that looks to me like a jersey
but you know alireza that was a tough
one that could have gone either way uh
but you know he's still right in the mix
towards the top of the leaderboard but
it's been fobby's day what a game that
was
it's gonna be a really interesting
conclusion to the tournament Abby's
going to be most likely in first along
with uh I mean Tabitha Bai
and I flipped on one of the last
remaining games Jose Martinez we haven't
talked about it much but he's having a
pretty decent event he's playing
Ukrainian GM Vitale bernatsky and I
think this one is going to end
peacefully
I covered division three of one of the
previous events and bernotsky was in it
he moves so quickly in Rapid games
spending no time at the start and he was
just completely obliterating some of his
opponents so bernowsky he's really
really strong he needs to hold on to
this game where it's okay just give up
your Knights for the pause that's what I
would try to do immediately and he goes
right for that and this should just be a
draw unless Jose can swindle
yeah very wise decision I think by
Vitality to just give away the night for
the pawn get the king to the promised
land and that's it after king h8 or King
F7 you've got
uh no no chances to win he wasn't born
yesterday he's obviously not going to
take that night and allow H7
he's gonna go night before f8 anything
draws but I'll be honest I really
dislike playing players in like the
Iranian mvl school where they play
incredibly fast because you think on the
one hand there's no way they can play
this fast and avoid blundering but when
you're sitting at the board and your
time is dwindling down it's just such
pressure to have to figure out moves
fast against players like mvl like
bernatsky I think that's a pretty good
rapid play strategy actually
I'm with you and playing very quickly
can just make your opponents nervous and
bernowsky and Jose two of the quicker
players that we have I see some games
are still remaining not too many of them
uh I see chronic is still playing
pronouns
on the ground again this one's gonna be
lasting for a while
Buckle in folks we're on move 100 right
now so I don't know how much longer this
game can go but kramnik up a bishop this
is a theoretical draw but he should make
his young opponent prove it
and what's interesting is that the rook
in Bishop versus Rook end game has been
the subject of much historical debate so
as early as the 1700s villador was the
first to tackle this particular type of
end game in his book and he claimed that
the side with the bishop should win
um with best play by both sides and then
the first person to dispute that claim
and claim definitively that rook and
Bishop versus Rook is a draw is actually
Howard Stanton
um in the the 1840s he spends over 50
pages in his book which I have analyzing
rook and Bishop versus rook and he found
a lot of the ideas that we now take for
granted there is also a philador
position so you know these guys in the
17 and 1800s they uh you know they had
their moments
and they had to work very very hard to
figure that out because they couldn't
just check with an engine they were
studying these end games deeply and now
we're in the Cochrane defense in the
rook and Bishop versus Rook end game
where the Rook pins the bishop uh from a
distance and then the King goes to the
other side of the black king so your
king is able to run away and now you see
The Rook cuts off the black king from
trying to help deliver a checkmate and
you threw in such an instructive point
there about the king going the opposite
way you never want opposition in this
position because then black an inch
forward and threaten Checkmate on the
back rank as long as you stay to the
other side of Black's King you're never
allowing a backright maintenance kramnik
is making backward progress here this is
excellent defensive skill by Sean
sarcion who's also keeping enough time
on his clock
but where does he go here with his Rook
he plays Rook A2 and he's kind of
Shifting his defense over to another
side of the board
right and chronic giving a check I don't
know how many moves are left before this
game is drawn with a 50 move rule but
now it's a bit awkward you have to
realize that you know the Cochrane
defense was behind that Rook was in the
eighth rank now you're from the side so
you've turned the board around and that
can be confusing for players even though
it's the same exact position you'd have
to look at it from a different angle I
think sometimes we just get oh in our
own thoughts and that's when we make
mistakes you know what's a good uh
analog where that becomes very pertinent
is Knight and bishop checkmate like when
you learn the W pattern and then you
have to rotate the board and Checkmate
on the side it can be very hard to
translate
um about you know the the access of the
eighth Rank and I struggled with that in
math class when we had to you know do
translations and rotate certain graphs
and I struggled with that on the
chessboard as well but you know somebody
who is not struggling with that is not
certion
yeah he's got this completely under
control it seems like he knows the
drawing mechanism without fail and that
game is drawn at only 137 moves
yeah not a pretty not a not a very long
game not very combative the players just
kind of pre-arranging 137 move draw
Vladimir kramnik he started hot but
unfortunately it's a nine round event
Robert and you have to keep your foot on
the gas pedal and as we've talked about
once you lose that first game it's so
easy to get into a tailspin yep and we
now know who the players competing for
the top eight there are many of them but
five minute carwana he is in the lead I
mean top of Dubai is close on his Tails
but so many other players have a shot
with two games to go in the Swiss and
the players they get a break which means
Donnie and I will do the same but when
Returns the final two rounds of the
Swiss portion here at the Julius bear
generation cup playing you'll not want
to miss it to see who will play for
division one in The Knockout see you
soon everybody
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
whether you're a long time chess player
or a fan who just got into the game
you're going to be very happy about this
news POG Champs 5 is back 16 of the
world's biggest creators will go head to
head in the greatest event in amateur
chess brought to you by chess.com and
pogchamps Legend Ludwig watch your
favorite creators like cutie Cinderella
Sea Dog VA and I did a thing fight for
their share of a 100 000 prize fund and
the ticket to the live finals in Los
Angeles use the command POG and chat for
all the details right now we are in the
heat of the battle for the top eight so
they can face off for a spot in division
one of the Jewish bear generation cup
Dania we've had seven exciting rounds
two more to go do you think Fabi alireza
who else is gonna get the job done
I mean it's honestly fabi's Resurgence
has been amazing he's playing with such
confidence such Poise every game has a
different narrative every game is a
different Arc he's won some middle games
he's won a game in the opening as early
as round two doesn't that feel like it
was last week and in the last round he
beat alireza farusa in a complicated end
game that Bishop play was incredible
it was it's nice to have a bishop paired
usually the top players like that oh
gosh but you know he did not have fun
fending off that position and I think we
are off in the eighth round so we are
getting into the action here uh
oh wait what action
draw
what action were you talking about
Robert what are we off about you you
know what's funny is your left actually
sounded like fabi's laugh so that was
really well done by you an accidental
impression but um I say this all the
time I don't blame the players it's good
for them why would Fabi not make a draw
it's going to make sure that he's in the
top eight
wait say that again
I thought my headphones stopped working
for a second gotcha clear as day yes yes
let's band The draw first so we don't
see this but let's go to a different
game uh we are on different game
otherwise against Amin type of Dubai and
this is an interesting matchup for many
different reasons he is The Prodigy the
Superstar the former 2800 where to call
someone to former anything when they're
just 20 years old but they're also
former
compatriots for the same Federation
right alireza used to play for Iran I
mean Saba Dubai was his teammate in the
Olympiad now only raise a place for
France I mean to have a divide recently
in the live running across 2700 for the
first time dropped just back below it
but now with the black pieces I mean
he's got his hands full the eval Bar
says he's better Dania but in this type
of position I feel like you know white
really has the safer King and I feel the
better chances
agreed and I'm more experienced from the
black side in these types of uh Italian
positions this plan with h65 has taken
the Chess World by storm it used to be
completely obligatory to Castle kingside
dutifully when White Castle but in the
last couple of years a lot of players
have been keeping their King in the
center expanding on the king side and
that gives you kind of a blank check to
attack the way that you want to on the
king side because as long as your king
remains in the center you don't really
care if the king side opens up but
obviously this plant is associated with
a great deal of risk because if white
can beat back the initial kingside
attack and then blast open the center
with a move d4 which Robert I think is a
very reasonable follow-up on the next
move then Black's King could get caught
in the middle of the crossfire also you
rarely want to play a takes B5 because
the open a file favors white with that
Bishop a Sitting Duck on A7
and now white threatens the win upon at
some moment B takes A6 black will not be
able to take back because the Rook gonna
eat is loose over there so you're a
bunch of things that Amin has to worry
about and by the time expenditure thus
far I feel like alireza is still well
within his preparation and at least the
the framework of it and for a tablet to
buy you you want to play Knight G6 you
want to play H5 but you aren't certain
it's the right decision because once you
push that pawn to H5 it doesn't go
backwards and I think white can play
Pawn H4 to challenge on that flank
I think you have to try though that's
Black's only source of counter play I
was really briefly flirting with the
possibility of C6 but making these
tempting one move threats actually hurts
you because it creates new sources of
tension it weakens the D6 square and it
reinforces the idea of D4 but as I say
that amine does play C6 and he's just
annoyed by the presence of this bishop
he feels that he has to kick it away
that'll give him buy him a little bit
more time uh to generate King side play
so I get it I get his logic
logical the fact that far Asia when
Bishop A2 that quickly I still feel like
he knows exactly what he's doing I mean
he is playing with clear purpose uh this
bishop on a two very strong aiming
towards F7 the black Bishop on A7 kind
of lurking over there aiming towards the
white king and that's why the king
slides on over to H1 these types of
moves you have to know when to play them
and your D4 push at some moment it could
spell huge trouble for black
and I think we're gonna see H5 I also
think black can start with the move G4
and then chase the Knight away and then
play H5 but when I I would be terrified
here with white I'll be totally honest
I'd be terrified over the move H5 but
top players just go H3 and they seem not
to care about the possibility of G4 and
H4 somehow they Retreat their pieces in
the right way and black suddenly ends up
uh at a dead end but what exactly is
White's response going to be uh against
H5 Robert is it in fact just to play H3
and is alireza not concerned about
creating that hook on the king side
yeah this uh looks scary I agree with
you but the black king will it really be
safer than whites and as type of bike
calculates tries to considers options
why don't we go to the George Meyer game
against Ralph Mama because these two
players have five and up points and by
the way we did see Fabi apologizing in
the chat oh he'll be forgiven eventually
not right now I'm still a little upset
with you uh but thank you Fabio we know
you always fight but you are doing the
right thing for your tournament and this
position this is the most georgmeyer
position you could possibly ever imagine
yeah literally ever jorgmeyer has a
Pictionary entry it's this position
right here no risk slide Edge in the end
game and I feel like your Nars opponents
always have at least one isolated Pawn
like that's just the rule of all of
gorgemeyer's positions with the white
pieces and every game is a Catalan it
doesn't matter what it doesn't matter
what his opponent plays opponent can
play king's Indian York Meyer will still
play a Catalan
well you're right that he likes these
little advantages what he thrives in is
positions where it looks like it's just
even and he outplay his opponents and
it's a huge skill to have he's playing
in many of the best players because he
was invited to those Dortmund series
back when he played for Germany now he
plays for Uruguay I believe he's half
German half Uruguayan and now he plays
with the Uruguayan Federation and for
Georg I mean slightly better position
with white healthier Pawn structure but
Ralph mammerov has had an excellent day
of chess
I think he's going to be able to
stabilize wait my headphones glitch
there for a second uh Uruguay is he not
playing for Germany anymore
no he plays for Uruguay
no I said Uruguay is he not playing for
Germany anymore
like why like I said that Uruguay is he
not playing for Germany no no we're
gonna move on I'm gonna move on both
from that that pawn and this game my GPA
just go down below two points one second
I you know I don't talk to you very
often Chad I want to vote what did you
think of that pun good or bad let's hear
it and let's go to a different game
you're making a mistake Robert that's a
miscalculation because Chad is always on
my side see you're uh not factoring that
in
I don't think this one is going to be
good for you hey your friend Bortnick is
playing against Sam Sevin so this is a
matchup that is quite exciting outside
of the top 10 players in the world like
we've seen from Bobby and Jan and furuja
we see some other great players taking
part in Dania semi-open a file send me
openf file double pawns for white but
open lines for the Rooks a good position
for Sasha and he can solidify that
weakness on Asics with a move B4 you see
that move very often uh with this type
of structure and as I say that I think I
know Bortnick too well he's gone before
and will black try to Counter-Strike in
the center with D5 Robert is that
counterproductive how would you go about
trying to hold this position with black
maybe Knight G7 and queen E6 but
I guess uh they're thinking like the
commentators which is never a good idea
you want activity and B4 is loose so for
white now the question is do I take on
D5 that opens up the C file I don't like
the look of that so much but can I just
play the move C3 is that available or am
I missing something
no I think C3 is completely acceptable
and I think it should be played after
Pawn 6 E4 Queen takes E4 white has a
direct line of fire on the C6 Pawn so
very pleasant position here for uh
Alexander portugu who probably has to go
one and a half out of two to have a
chance at the first division 50 probably
gets him into the second one
yeah you know fighting to be in the
second or if you lose their match you
can do the third uh so with so many
players fighting they're clawing their
way towards the top of the leaderboard
bornick plays C3 and the position just
looks nice for white because A6 is such
an eyesore in this position at some
moment white can play Rook A5 other Rook
to A1 pilot pressure and if you're ever
worried about your D3 Pawn if the D5
were to open you would push your pod up
to D4 and protect it that way so I do
like important Exposition but seven is
also handling this quite well
is indeed we'll keep an eye as this game
unfolds it's has quite a bit of bearing
on the tournament standings if we may
come back for a second of the farugia
top of my game because the G file has
opened black has made a move that the
engine calls a serious mistake and the
eval bar continues to move up in White's
Direction but again I'll be totally
honest
I would be terrified here of like
um getting checkmated can I be blamed
for that
no I I certainly won't blame you for it
but maybe there's a tactic here Knight
takes E5 Queen E5 Queen F3 your knight
on F4 is pinned
and he plays it and the other night is
going to come out to E2 in order to
finish off the attack on Black's night
someone did their Puzzle Battle
together with our Honey Nut Cheerios
this morning
I'm not sure is the only cereal I have
in my apartment wait is that actually
the case yeah that's the only cereal I
have right now well we're on the same
wavelength you know that
I mean who doesn't love a good yeah well
this is not an advertisement behind the
chairs but I know I'm getting really
hungry so thank you for that and all the
reason I was hungry so he took a snack
on the E5 Pawn in the center and queen
F3 next and I feel like this is just a
one-sided Affair I'll show this on the
analysis board after Queen E5 which is
very likely because black has no other
move after Queen F3 the only way to
protect the Knight is Bishop B8 and now
you can play Rook takes B8 but an even
more clinical way to pick up the Knight
is just a simple Knight to E2 and a very
important detail Robert black has this
cute move Queen to H5 and this does get
out of the pin but after the trade you
literally go from the frying pan Into
the Fire white recaptures on B8 and that
open B file finally serves to reward
white all these moves later
Holly Reza how long did that take him to
find five seconds ten seconds he's got
seven minutes on his clock he's playing
this Jana Palm Nutri Style
uh he's dominating this game and every
move with purpose this pieces all have a
function and that Knight on A5 right it
went over there to attack the light
Square Bishop but it hasn't been able to
get back into the game so Rook takes B8
is another attack though I was thinking
about but then I remembered that a
couple things one the queen can take on
B8 but there are tactics on F7 as you
pointed out but also there's a funny
tactic I just want to show very quickly
that's a rook B8 rookie Bishop before
does white have a Black Album of Queen
F6 is what I'm wondering
oh that's beautiful and you might say oh
that doesn't work because the queen is
protected well what's protecting it
Knight what's aiming at the Knight he's
called The Rook that's so easy to miss
from a distance honestly
yeah and you lose the queen
I was just wondering about where The
Knockout was going to come from so Rook
takes B8 was attracted but 92 uh you
point out that variation I think that's
just clear that you are able to put
pressure on the pin piece but you do
lose sight of the H3 Pawn which Maybe
not immediately but at some point could
be nerve-wracking so that's why fruge is
slowing down
and that's been a theme of the day right
I'm gonna be a broken record here for a
second and say that we like to highlight
things that top players do consistently
that often aren't talked about as much
because they're not as sexy but one of
those things is knowing when to pause
right knowing when to pause for a minute
and a half two minutes even longer in a
10 minute game and this is one of those
moments how many people would just
automatically play oh take speed a
bishop takes out four that's a pin
against the queen Arusha stops he knows
that there are two candidate moves here
and he's gonna take as long as he needs
to until he's confident that he has
found a clear path and he's checked for
sudden tactics
okay so far Asia on the clock he is
doing the right thing by calculating and
making sure that he is accurate and we
were talking about Georg Meyer earlier
in his technique I just want to quickly
bring us back there because York is
somehow up a pawn
and has an advantage in this end game
and black has just made a serious
mistake is panicking trying to generate
kingside counter play but it's had the
opposite effect Robert I think you might
have relied on King E6 a couple of moves
ago but now the bishop comes up to be
three orking the rook and defending his
own Rook You're Gonna Lose F6 here
and I think you're can just well he can
recapture on H4
but he can also capture on F6 because
black has to move the king down to keep
the C6 Pawn protected yeah I like Rook
takes F6 the one thing you'd be
concerned about is that the Rook F6 is
our King E7 and will the black h-spawn
suddenly become a queen I don't think
the answer is yes he just takes back on
H4 and it gives away most of the
advantage apparently but I don't see why
well apparently it's because of this
mysterious move Bishop to C2 essentially
forcing a bishop trade but that's a
weird kind of amorphous move Ralph just
kind of keeping the status quo I think
Rob's move makes the most sense from a
human perspective what he's trying to do
is ensure that King to D5 is possible in
response to Rook takes F6 and I think
we're likely to see that path
yeah that Bishop C2 move is not very
human at all no just trading and losing
upon with check and not getting
um all that much that I could see for it
but this Rook B2 move was very natural
although Rook F6 check King D5 I guess
that white a pawn isn't really going
anywhere thanks to the bishop on D3 and
that's what Ralph is relying on so Georg
it was an even position he of course
gets an advantage like he always seems
to do and now he needs to find a way to
increase the edge and play for a win I
like Bishop F3 a lot yeah although I
honestly think Ralph has good practical
chances uh to hold the drug given
how Ultra active his pieces are so I
would estimate this at 50 50 between a
white win and a draw
we've got a lot of other top games that
are continuing to heat up not all of
them are in the end game phase artemia
theodoro is a board five matchup that we
haven't looked at yet shall we have a
brief gander
I say yes so let's go right in
okay looks like artemia is squeezing out
a positional Advantage man I've never
said that before artemia positional
Advantage with the white pieces he never
really does that kind of stuff does he
this looks horrible for black right I'm
looking honestly terrible
and I'm just like it's I get the
material is level but Knight B3 to C5 or
taking A5 is about to happen uh you can
play C5 for white if you want but I
don't think releasing the tension is
very smart like d takes C4 is never
going to hurt you so starting with
Knight B3 seems to be the most accurate
I think a lot of players when they look
at this Pawn structure are biased
because black is a space advantage in
the center right you've got this
menacing looking Pawn on e4 but we're
looking primarily at the queen side and
in my surprise our Tamia did close down
the queen side with C5 he's going after
that A5 punt but is he not worried about
his pieces kind of getting tangled up
and is he not worried about tactics with
Knight takes C5
I guess Queen takes C6 is on the docket
even if if you don't play Knight takes
C5 I'm still gonna go Queen takes c66 so
you might as well play Knight takes C5
so good a tactical spot by you but
artemiev says I'll give you the C Pawn
trade I'm up in a pawn oh The Rook on B1
is nice
but I think the tactics might be working
out for black and I was gonna make these
moves on the board Nicholas Theodore was
gonna do that for us Knight takes C5
yeah Queen takes C6 and I think after
the trade black can actually snag that
pawn on A3 but artemio definitely saw
that I think what he might have missed
is that Bishop before there's this crazy
team of Rook A3 tip B3 hitting the rook
and saving the Knight
can can I start with Rook B8 check
though and then play Bishop B4 there
oh and can blacka like Rook a one and no
that's way too speculative gosh could
that be it though Rook a one and F4
that is
wild but it makes a lot of sense and why
could lose that
and this is happening
gosh
this is a big moment Bishop B4 Rook B3
is
not a draw White's still better because
of the long-term weakness of the D5 Pawn
but this is not what vladis love artemia
was looking for oh he could have won a
pawn and been happily pressing for a win
now he's gonna try to press to win from
an equal position or sorry and even by
material which is not equal because
white is slightly better by the way
theodoru has one bar of connection from
what I see but Tammy is the one who
isn't moving he's trying to figure out
how to maximize the potential of his
position
yeah Nicholas really closing the door on
White's winning chances essentially in
20 seconds or vladislavartame who's got
a big decision to make Robert Rook b a
check is a three result game so if he
wants to play with no risk I think he
should go Bishop before trade the Rooks
and
probably admit that this game is going
to end in a drug he takes a third path
he takes on C5 I wasn't this was not on
my radar at all
but
doesn't have connection I'm looking at
his one bar oh man internet and so that
would be a oh he's back okay as soon as
I said that he's back so maybe I'm being
misled and I don't think Nicholas
Theodore is going to struggle at this
point he is just hunting down the pond
and white could lose this game black is
D4 in Donya and then the bishop enters
the position the F2 Pawn is a target I
feel like White's King could fall under
threats
I would venture to say that black is
definitely not worse objectively but
practically Nicholas has to figure out
where he's going to tuck this bishop
away and what he's going to do against
Rook B8 and I think the answer is just
Rook takes C5 and suddenly everything is
protected Robert and if white goes 96
intending to bring this bishop back to
Asics The Rook goes out to C1 that buys
black the tempo he needs in order to
unpin his Bishop
right I don't think why is the time here
Knight B7 you can just bring your Rook
back to C6 and I don't see how you win
the piece at least not yet
yeah or even Bishop E5 here Intermezzo
hitting the Rook first and covering the
D6 square and he's found it immediately
super nice move really really nice there
and two seconds artemio is no time he's
entering an end game that is clearly
worse for him
how is this possible he was all over
theodoro that's what happens when you
get low on the clock he's got to try to
trade a knight or one of the Bishops I
think that would increase his drawing
chances but Nicholas is not gonna allow
that he's going to play Bishop A7 and I
think black's plan is so obvious get the
king to E5 and then either push D4 or F4
given the time situation Nicholas should
be able to win this yeah huge shovel for
artemia down a pawn down on the clock
and Black's plan being very simple but
white really does not want to do is uh
see this past pawns go forward and black
really does not want to see
this trade's okay you have to take on A6
now but I was gonna say do not take on
C5 you do not want opposite color
Bishops that's immediately a draw
for sure Nicholas is going to take on A6
and he's taking his time here I am still
a little bit worried about
the connection but after you take on A6
maybe he's thinking about what he's
gonna do afterward but that's kind of a
no-brainer you have to bring your king
up
I feel like this might be a little bit
premature Robert because you can always
play D4 maybe it was worth bringing the
king to the center first
and you need to leave black with an
h-pawn and take away the other three and
then it's immediately a draw so that's
why white does have pretty decent
chances to hold this game or attending
down to nine seconds and a win in this
game would have been huge for either
player so if Theodore could win he goes
six out of eight which is really great
news because wait is that Wesley's
Soul's name oh Bishop D6
sorry sorry what are these standings uh
sorry everybody we note that these are
some old standings for some other events
like people Wesley's not playing Magnus
isn't playing we'll make sure uh to get
that fixed but yeah this Knight is
trapped on A6
that was such an instructive blunder
Robert Knight A6 trying to get the
Knight back and forgetting that the
bishop can dominate The Knight this is a
worthy construction to remember Black's
winning plan is so simple you just bring
the king up you hit the Knight and white
will not be able to get his King to the
center soon enough to start eating up
Black's Pawn
huge huge win in the making for Nicholas
theodoru and that Knight cannot move the
king comes up to C4 the king go back to
B5 and grab that
it's all over I think our Tammy will
resign within a couple of moves
he's trying to eliminate Black's pawns
but you can just play FG take the Knight
and you've got plenty of Pawns the only
thing to avoid obviously is to have that
H Pawn because it is the wrong promotion
Square
yep so Bishop H2 Bishop F4 and then the
rest is over very simple
okay yeah lattice Love Is Gonna resign
momentarily here I don't know why he's
playing to be honest oh he wants a
stalemate trick with King H3 look at
that okay no never mind yeah he doesn't
even allow us to laugh about it anymore
but ferrugia won his game and board Nick
and Savion they're in mutual time
trouble but it also looks like no
progress can be made here
yeah they draw their game more time
scrambles in the game between Jessica
and Martinez both of them down to their
last couple of seconds this game a lot
more combative
oh and you see the F6 Pawn is weak that
would be an extra Pawn for white So
Yesterday takes it and apparently
there's a oh that's a nice move
where's The Knockout though
Martinez kind of curling up into a ball
there and obviously he's got his own
counter play with a check on D1
Rook D1 King H2
barely any time look at the clock Jose
is five six four so does Andre
Queen F6 is now a huge threat so many
squares the black has to keep tabs on
and he is
maybe Queen B6 no that blender is a rook
yeah that's that's an easy piece to drop
there and watch out if the Rook leaves
the back rank Queen f8 is actually
Checkmate so don't play that's beautiful
Knight F6 Queen E7 Jose still holding on
will we see a queen trade yes we will
but this gives black definite drawing
chances although apparently going past
it was not the way I wonder if it's like
Rook of fate or something but hear the
night coming to B4 that's bad whoa whoa
and if the pawns get liquidated that
should be a draw although honestly with
two seconds left
I feel like Andre will find a way to
trick Jose yeah it does seem that way
and the Knight goes into D6 watch out
for Rook G3 Knight F7 made
no way Andre
that's Jose
how about pushing the kingside pawns
like can white use them as attackers
that's definitely what you should do I
feel like you should milk this position
down a little bit try to go Rook C5 Rook
C7 and if you fail to win the H7 Pawn or
you fail to Fork black then you start
pushing your Pawns
and he goes King F7 because King E6
would have been met by Rook H5 this
looks very unpleasant for black
extremely and it obviously is a draw
objectively in a classical game Jose
would hold this position
pretty handily
and Andre has to be careful about a
repetition he's also got to be careful
about getting skewered
oh and he's threatening Knight G5
he plays it whoa King G6 walking into
the same line no good discoveries a
great play from Jose
and suddenly he's got a near Fortress
he's got Rook A3 is a very nasty idea
Rook H1 oh
don't blunder checkmate
reminds me of that or per chess chess
League Tech Mahindra game you know
between Berry and yakuboya where a mate
was blundered in a very similar type of
end game but look each ride's about to
fall so be very careful King G6 The Rook
will move out the way and there's like
95 to oh my gosh eye out on
that H2 maybe and then Rook G5 takes H5
but look at this The Rook moves and Rook
G5 check and then 95 oh there's no 95
the night covered wow now it's winning
Rook takes off seven and 95. it's
winning and Knight G5 too many threats
that's it Well Done by yessa panko I
think the king and pawn and game is
winning for whiteboard
oh and he missed Rook G4 oh
missed it both players
oh
my gosh and G3 now what was that
that was just nerves and time travel
oh my gosh that was a golden opportunity
for Jose and this is a huge half point
to lose
yeah I mean yes a panko now suddenly
maybe he can claim a chance for the top
eight and yes goes super dangerous we
know he beat Magnus Carlson in tata
steel chess 2021 I mean he can really
play
and you can tell Jose is upset how by
the fact that he's playing this out
right he's upset he's mad because he
came oh so close he had a chance King G3
terrible blunder Rook G4 check instant
drop both players forgetting about that
square this is what nerves do to you
right and I don't mean this critically
we understand you've got five seconds
for the last 50 moves you never know
when this drawing opportunity is gonna
randomly manifest itself
and we do have the last round about to
start and Fabiano caruana plays against
Eduardo iterizaga and you know what's
interesting in matches like this where
Fabi the hybrid player he beat iterizaga
in The Knockout of the aim chest rapid
first round opponents uh Fabi is the
stronger player between the two but he
only needs a draw right and he agreed on
the drug very quickly I was just
wondering if ferrugia could LeapFrog him
because five moves a seven and a half
and if arugia wins his game he'll also
get the seven up but first already made
a draw so it's a totally Blue Point
it is indeed and the only other top game
that hasn't ended in a draw theodoro and
Min Lee also agreeing to a draw we've
got top of the buy who I think is
actually going to play this out against
jorg Meyer believe it or not a
Rubenstein French I know that's a very
new opening for georgmeyer
and you know what happens now right is
that the fans all root for the players
with six to win so that the players who
made quick draws uh get knocked out for
the right to play play for division one
so you can see the top eight they will
play matches where one gets to choose
first one through four could choose
between five and eight one chooses first
two second and so on from the opposition
so Fabi he has earned the top spot he
will get to choose his opponent we'll
see later who that is going to be but
it's not a guarantee that the top eight
that we have right now for example Min
late tie breaks are very bad that even
with some of these draws here oh
oh my gosh
all five of the top boards have already
agreed to a draw
your
great positive surprise I know you were
thrilled about this you are you are so
happy that you are speechless yours of
Joy are streaming from your face
yes exactly and
interestingly enough we are having some
forced fights because pava El yanov is
playing Levon aronian and levana's five
and a half points so he needs to win to
compete for a division one so sometimes
you have to play because your opponent's
not just gonna make a quick draw with
you
and I almost feel like some players are
not playing as much to compete in
division one like Nicholas Theodore for
example he knows that likely he's got
bad tie breaks it's very likely that
some player with six wins and LeapFrog
Sim but he wants to get into the top of
division two because the money in
division two is also really good so I
think for a lower rated Grandmasters
they aren't necessarily willing to throw
caution to the wind in order to give
themselves a chance to get to division
one they want to secure a good
tournament showing and sometimes they're
winning to hedge their bets in order to
do that
I get that but you still have to play a
match right for division two or if you
lose division three if he lost the final
round he still would have been in the
same match for division two or division
three like I don't actually think
there's a benefit to making a quick draw
because if you lost you'd have the same
outcome so I just think that uh it's
possible that the tie breaks improve
reminded everybody that the tie breaks
are based on opponent scores so if you
know Nicholas Theodore's third round
opponent happens to win the last game
that's really helpful for him but you're
relying on others and yep there's only
so much you can control and I feel like
I'm not blaming Nico Theodore I don't
know here's the name that you'd
mentioned but for men in particular he
had his very bad tie breaks if he lost
his last round he still would be playing
for the same division two division three
match
that's totally fair that's a great point
and
yeah this is really the remaining top
game we've got macarian against
yakuboyev oroni and ilyanov and
obviously for these players it makes
sense to play for a win because you
never know somebody with five and a half
would conceivably have good tie breaks
and could LeapFrog people who were in
front of them before the round started
that's just how high breaks work when
they depend on opponents results I
really like levon's position here by the
way I think he's off to a great start
yeah Lavon is one of those players with
pretty good tie breaks so if he can win
this game and get to six and a half he
may knock some of the others uh out of
the matches for division one so I I'm
with you his position is better his King
is safe and look at this Eliana decides
I'm not going to passively sit here I'm
going to strike but that makes the E5
Pawn a bit more tender so I would want
to open the e-file bring my Rook to E1
so e takes D5 followed by Rook E1 speaks
to me but it does hand black the huge
Center
it does and it's a committal decision
and Lavon pausing here for a moment what
are the alternatives to e takes D5
because Eliana obviously is threatening
to take twice on e4 so the move Queen C2
comes to mind but it does
feel a little bit awkward and I actually
think after Pawn takes E4 White's Queen
is overextended it's protecting both the
bishop and the pawn so I suppose you
could drop your Bishop back to C2 but
I'm with you that feels too passive I
think we're gonna see he takes D5 and we
do
big moment here from Lavon he but as
soon as you said it and Rook E1 makes so
much sense he plays D4 to start with and
now this is going to be a fight because
E4 for black it's an attack on the king
side in the making but white saying look
at this Pawn on D5 in particular that's
stuck in place I have two miners
attacking it maybe I can remove the
guard
and speaking of removing the garden
chipping away a Black's Pawn chain you
often see this move F3 uh which is
particularly sensible because the Knight
on E3 is really pining to get into F5
and if you can open up the f file you
make it a lot more feasible for the
Knight to jump in but Rook 88 walked
right into a very thematic move on the
other side of the board this is
brilliant I think you would use the
phrase whole board awareness I love
honoronium
great stuff the B7 Pawn you don't
usually think of a pawn like that as
being overloaded but now it's under
attack and covering the fork on C6 so
Eliana kind of walked into it you can
hardly blame him he was trying to defend
what we were just talking about as a
weakness and if you take on E5 then the
pawn takes back and it looks like
Black's position is on the verge of
falling apart so this position very good
for levana Ronin he's ahead on the clock
and he
desperately wants to get to six and a
half points
the side that controls the pawn breaks
controls the position and white has
three of them one of them was just
carried out A6 he's got C4 he's got F3
it's always nice when you can go chip
away at the base of the pawn chain and
at the tip of the pawn chain so as
imposing as these pawns look they're
actually very tender and I think Lavon
displaying great knowledge of typical
Italian ideas it seems to be a rite of
passage or any top player to have
complete Command
um of Mainline Italians and Lavon really
displaying that here will we see F3 is
this the time to trade on G6 and
liquidate a couple of minor pieces and
maybe then strike with C4 or F3 I think
lots of appealing options here for
aronian I'm mainly curious how quickly
Lavon makes the decision here because
you point out Knight G6 trade darks or
Bishops and play for a move like F3 that
looks good F3 right away looks good he
takes on B7 and row A4
wow that was not approved of
by our silicon friend or fiend
because I'm looking at this position
it's ridiculously complicated he wants
to go Rook B4 where is that Queen going
to go next that's not entirely clear and
what he's doing is he's putting pressure
on the queen side Shore but also on the
clock he's making quick moves they may
not be perfect moves but that move makes
Black's life difficult
well this may sound obscure but one of
my worries would be that the queen drops
back to C8 and if black can stick a
knight on F4 then Bishop takes H3
becomes a very serious counter chance
white can't fall asleep on the safety of
his own King so maybe that has something
to do uh with why the computer isn't a
big fan of Rook before on the other hand
I'm looking at the position after Rook
before Queen C8 and in that position you
have to reckon with tactics involving
Rook takes speed and Knight C6 so I
actually think lavon's time advantage
and his speed of play is gonna come in
very very handy as we enter the second
stage of the middle game here
I'm with you and Bishop D6 was the
choice and the advantage back up to
White so Bishop D6 stops Rook before in
extremely natural move and we'll see if
Lavon does break the tension of these
Knights take on G6 take on D6 uh White's
Pawn structure looks a little bit
healthier but black does have
counterplay down the B file and I I did
want us to you know keep note of the
game between rudic makarian and Noir
Becca
because the winner in that game
both of them those notary bags are super
strong one I know it's a bit higher than
the other but both are great players and
you see in this position it the bar says
equal
I'm looking at this like I'm I like
Black's position healthier Pawn
structure as white has two isolated
pawns the queen side
yeah this is one of those
weird positions where both sides have
weaknesses and
white obviously has to be very careful
not to blender a fork
and that's a blunder the A3 Pawn but you
can get away with Queen B1 here because
Rook takes A3 obviously runs into Bishop
takes Knight the bishop on B7 hangs so
I would call this a positional situation
but there's a lot of tactical details
that hide beneath the surface such as
the possibility of Knight G5 which could
be played even if it comes with a pawn
sacrifice because securing the bishop
pair in a position like this could be
potentially a great asset
right I'm with you and that Bishop on B7
not the best piece so I would be looking
to go Bishop a six maybe bishop C4
protect the pawn from the front uh these
positions are quite complex and I think
that H6 is an idea for black just to
stop your knight G5 uh threat I'm with
you that the bishop pair Magnus has been
doing that a lot where he gives away a
pawn just to secure the bishop pair
doesn't always work but it is an idea
that you need to keep in mind so this
one it looks like a position with
chances for all three results are there
any other games that have significant
impact on the standings anyone with five
and a half will have a shot to get to
six and a half and LeapFrog some of the
others I mean we've got some pretty weak
players that we haven't spoken about
thus far quite as much because they've
had pretty decent performances nihal sir
and I'm looking at Chakra mamidyarov but
maybe that is below our minimum rating
threshold of the games that we're
willing to look at in all seriousness
let's have a quick look at shocker yards
position against Dr bus them and what a
crazy position it is I think Robert that
shocker has five and a half out of nine
but uh out of eight but don't quote me
on that five what is this like oh he's
got five they're these two players so we
won't stay here long because it doesn't
impact good fight for the type of vision
but they have five and eight and they're
playing each other
true
brutal
it's never easy
let's go back then shall we go back then
to aronian's game I feel like of all of
the top games that are still going it's
probably the most meat on the bone in
terms of the position that they have
let's go to it because you'll like how
the go back because you you would think
you put F3 and it was captured he didn't
play F3 he put F4
so how is the pawn captured then is
there a rule that allows that pawn to be
did he play g-take so far yeah magic you
know
whoa he cheated
first for everything he hacked into the
into the server man yeah complained to
the support team uh that's the most one
of the most frequent complaints they get
is an opposite being illegal
well he's a computer science major so
totally uh totally understandable I
still remember all these years ago there
was this video where Peter swindler and
Gustafson are eating chesty beginners
yeah and I I think
Peter was trying to illustrate a
situation where odd passant is illegal
right like the pawn moved to one square
and then it moved another Square he's
like so here you won't be able to take
onpassan and of course the move executes
on the server and they're just like
dying laughing do you remember that that
was going around oh yeah I absolutely
remember that where it was A4 and there
was a Pawn on B4 and it wasn't supposed
to be able to take it but it is a3a4
yeah yeah Bishop F6 played by Levant he
keeps a one minute lead on the clock uh
the Evo bar suggesting that black is
really doing okay and I like Black's
control of the B file but when is Lavon
gonna turn his attention fully to the
king side that's my big question
well he might have to turn it to the
queen side because Rook B8 hits the
bishop and if the bishop drops back
I think black's gonna eat that pawn on
B2 and threaten to take on C3 so Lavon
better have something cooked up on the
king side because he does not have
forever maybe Rook B4 is his idea but
then Robert the queen moves away and I
still feel like LaVon is really saddled
with a lot of problems along the B file
what about Rook A3 here just to keep the
A7 Pawn in its sights to protect the
bishop on B3 I'm not saying I enjoy the
look of my Rook sitting there but at
least I stop Black's immediate threats
I really liked that that would have
bought your bought you at least two temp
people I could have sent that Apon down
the board but that would have given you
one more Tempo that you could have used
maybe to reinforce the bishop or to
involve the knight in the attack as it
stands
I don't know if white can afford to
allow Rook takes before and I feel like
LaVon
maybe I'm underestimating his position
but it feels like he's gone a little bit
astray on the king's side yeah so you
get that set of six I'm with you in
Bishop one of six it's in enemy
territory it looks threatening let me
get a queen on G7 for that Checkmate but
that Bishop can be captured at any
moment and it can't escape so the
Houdini act that was on passant it
doesn't work with Queens on D1 landing
on G7 and that means that black should
be doing just fine and also lavon's
advantage in the clock is no more so
good news for Eliana and he's got a good
shot right if he is able to take this
game then he will fight for division one
I feel like white is one inaccuracy away
from his position falling apart so maybe
you should start with the Rook takes B8
but black then threatens you know he's
got Rook takes B3 and Knight D2 ideas he
can take on F6 on demand which means The
Rook is completely tied down to F3 and I
was thinking maybe you can drop the Rook
back to F1 and pave the way for Queen H5
but that just feels so slow it gives
away the G3 square and
I probably would prefer black at this
point and as you said a great chance
here for Pavo the stake a claim and
potentially even make a serious push for
at the very least top of division two
you know it's a problem though is if he
draws the I'm looking at his tie breaks
they're bad so if he knows his tie
breaks he may think I'd rather win this
game right I'm okay losing but I can't
make a draw I need to win to fight for
division one other people as you said
they're fine playing division two like
you make a draw okay but both players
need to win to fight for division one
and that often creates interesting
scenarios
yeah because neither player willing to
compromise in any way
and it literally affects the moves
played in the game and as we speak Lavon
has allowed The Rook to be captured on
before Pavel reinforcing the H6 Pawn
moving his King to safety and is it time
for Lavon to start taking some pieces
off the board with Bishop takes E4 and
potentially later on the d-pawn and move
up to D5 and bother this bishop on E6
the that looks good because the bishop
on F6 looks very powerful the Black
Knight will likely hop into F4 at the
right moment so the knights they have
squares for Pavel and it's a Lavon Who's
down a minute on the clock and they both
need a win here that's what they're
aiming for but I think Levant needs a
little bit more and he's feeling the
pressure in the position
you most certainly is taking his time
here you can play Bishop takes E4 I'm
still partial to the idea of bringing
the Rook back to F1 maybe you can do
that preemptively so that pawn takes E4
doesn't come with Tempo but it's crazy
that Lavon is now down a minute on the
clock as he does take on e4 Pavel very
likely at some point to plant a knight
on F4 that also prepares prevents the
White Queen from reaching H5
some attacking chances for white here
and for black it's looking reasonably
stable
who would you take which with the time
as it is which position would you take
honestly and I don't know exactly where
I would critique pavel's play the last
couple of moves but
five moves ago I would have taken black
now I would take white because well
opposite colored Bishops they favor the
attacker and I think Levon illustrates
that with his last move H or undermining
the G5 pawn and I would definitely take
white if Black's only way to protect
that pawn is with the King
I think it is because Rook G8 I think
you get checkmated hd5h5 Rook takes F4
with Queen H5 mate so you can't defend
with Rook G8 which means that you kind
of have to play King G6 which is a scary
scary move to be forced to play
and you also can't play Knight D3
because the moment the White Queen lands
on H5 the game is over White's just
gonna play H takes G5 exactly the same
way that white would Checkmate uh in the
line that you Illustrated so process of
elimination really helps it doesn't
matter if King G6 is good or bad you
know it's the only move so you have to
play it and the sooner you play it the
more time you leave yourself for the
subsequent defensive task I just think
Pablo is clenching his teeth right now
and it's just a very very hard move to
play in time pressure because white has
the simple Bishop E5 right I just get
out of your attack I'm threatening to
win a Pawn on F4 the white king is very
safe on G1 the Knight on E3 blockading
blacks passer and staring over it to the
D5 Square where you know you want to
push your Pawn I think that you're right
that somewhere Pavel lost control and
even though the evaluation bar tells oh
it's about zeros only point one better
for white no not in this position this
isn't a rook and pawn and game where
White's King is slightly better than his
opponents this is a position where
there's a king on G6 so he finds the
best move but I really believe that
Pavel is in huge trouble
this is a very minor Point Robert but I
like the fact that Lavon didn't take on
G5 first when you're facing your
opponent's time pressure you want to
keep as many sources of tension on the
board as possible and you never know
maybe at some later point you would want
to go H5 check and knock the king out of
G6 maybe you're saving H takes G5 for a
rainy day and every one of these small
sources of tension force black to
dedicate a little bit more time time
that he simply does not have as Pavel
shifts his Rook over to d8 kind of a
semi-waiting move I guess just trying to
pass the turn to White and preventing
Bishop takes F4 I guess that is or at
least discouraging white from taking
twice on F4 which now runs into Queen
takes D4 and a quick note that I think a
lot of people would want to get rid of
this Knight by playing G3 but that walks
right into a fork with Knight H3 checkup
the white king were on H2 G3 might just
like win the game because the Knight is
uh being booted and the white Rook is
about to hurt the black king so you
can't play G3 that's not available King
H2 that's you know one attack I'm not
going for that maybe Queen F1 here
because I'm thinking about an exchange
sack on F4 Rook takes F4 Queen takes F4
just getting in there with the queen
that's absolutely brilliant guess what
the decision to keep the pawn on H4
could be rewarding if Black cover plays
Queen E7 right he won't have the move
Queen E7 to G5 covering a potential
check on G3 which adds a lot of appeal
to that exchange stack I think Queen F1
is a brilliant move good call
he plays it he's played it wow oh my
gosh Queen to F1 played by Lavon aronian
and how does black defend this because
there are so many threats here at F6 I
was gonna say but now Bishop takes F4
and he goes H5 he kind of rushed that
move apparently the winning move was D5
or sing Black's Bishop to step in front
of the queen on Rook so that Queen takes
D4 wouldn't come with the same effect
that's super nice but even this position
still looks shaky for both sides I mean
white can definitely lose this game but
that was a rush decision as you're
saying he wanted to keep some time look
he's under 45 seconds but how does black
play here because Queen G3 check might
be annoying he just simply I love this
move yeah slide your king over make
waiting moves don't be afraid to do
nothing and Lavon down 20 seconds on the
clock it's totally a three result game
and Robert what you said earlier is so
important now a draw might be out of the
question for one or both of these
players which means they're gonna make
crazy decisions that they normally
wouldn't make if they believe that a
draw is tantamount to a loss now 20
seconds for Lavon who's running out of
effective attacking ideas
G4 now that is a risky move but he's
playing for a win he does not want to
draw this game and queen goes to E5
centralization now Levant down under 15
seconds I think he needs to figure out
how he can improve his Knight but the
Knight has nowhere to go
what would you do here I think he's
playing for a loss you might have to go
Knight F1 he goes Knight G2 but there's
a nasty check on D1 that would drive
White's King to H2 where you have to
self-pin your Rook
but Pavel playing a little bit too
cautiously here maybe
a repetition of moves
Pavel has six points entering so he'll
go up to six now for the draw and he
does not want to go for it yeah Brave
chest from him
E3 if E3 ends the game
oh my goodness yeah what a find
because the Rook on F4 is loose
can't take with the queen because black
trades queens and takes on F4 and Pavel
he didn't take more than 10 seconds to
find this move he's gonna win this game
and that means he's going to end up in
the tie for a second with farrugia if he
can secure this Victory he's playing
extremely well that pawn is just pushing
up the board The Rook on D4 still can't
be captured in fact pava El yanov wins
lavon's time has elapsed and that means
Eliana if you see him about to show up
he's going to be tied for second place
and probably in third behind furuja
unbelievable and on-demand win against
Levon aronian with the black pieces and
the pivotal moment came a couple of
moves ago LaVon in this position had to
find the very difficult move D5 can't
take the Knight you gotta take the pawn
and after Rook takes F4 it's the same
type of position Robert but completely
different particulars right the queen is
passive both pieces are blocked in by
your very own Bishop black has to enter
complete passive defense and Levon I
think would have finished Pavel off
that's what these games come down to
that is how narrow how razor thin the
margin of Victory is
yes and we still have some games going
on that are very important yakubayev is
playing against macarion and a win for
either of those players would get them
to seven points but this end game has
it's
we catch up to the live position no
yakubayev I've seen a different position
than you and the game has actually just
concluded in a draw
okay so that game ends in a draw ignore
the zeros
on Black's clock we also have seven
against yessipenko
on one of the top boards the last move
is B4 it here's that
yeah it appears that some of the the
moves of sub have stopped coming in but
this also looks like it's pretty close
to being a draw
yeah no this position even material and
Bishop that's not a very good piece on
F6 but there gives us some potential
because the pawns on the Queen's excuse
me the king side it's weird because the
kings are on the queen side but the
pawns are on the king side now my head
is thrown through a loop but the G3 and
atrial pawns aren't dark squares which
could be good for a Dark Sword Bishop to
go after
yeah pretty interesting unbalanced end
game here and it doesn't matter what the
position is when the time is low the
players will find a way uh to raise the
entertainment value of any position
and we've got sort of a smattering of
games on some of the other boards we've
got two Bishops against two knights here
but it does appear
Robert that some of the moves here have
stopped coming in and we will try to
address that very promptly yes and these
games
um they don't actually impact the top of
the leaderboard because those players
did not have enough points to hop up
into the top eight where they would
compete for division one and really
that's what everyone enters the
competition for they're trying to make
it to the top eight and that's what's
coming up so let's just talk about that
a little bit Donna we will confirm who
our top eight players will be and who
has a a chance to play for division one
but we know it's gonna be Fabiano we
know it's gonna be ferrugia we know it's
gonna be Pablo El yanov those are three
big names and in particular El yanov I
think he deserves the spotlight right
now because everybody knows Fabiano
everybody knows fuja people may not know
El janov who was 2760 Plus at his Peak I
mean the guy is such a beast at chess he
still hovers around 2700 and he could
take anybody down
and I think it can be annoying when some
chess fans are too quick to jump on the
oh he's watched bandwagon it's hard to
remain at that level it's hard to remain
at 27.60 and even when some of these
players get a little older and drop I
love it when they show that they can
still compete with the top of them they
still have it in them uh to put in a
performance at a 2750 level and that's
exactly what Pablo Eliana did this
tournament I'm so interested to see how
he fares playing these crucial mini
matches or qualification to the finals
yeah we'll elaborate more on the mini
matches they're gonna be two game
matches but for now we are going to take
a break and win return we'll talk about
the top eight and much more so don't go
anywhere this is the Julius bear
generation cup plan we'll be back soon
[Music]
foreign
so I loved puzzles I loved solving any
puzzle you put in front of me so chess
was unnatural for my brain it was the
unsolvable puzzle it wasn't one of those
things you just looked at here is the
puzzle what's the solution it it was a
puzzle inside of an enigma right inside
of a mystery like what is this game and
there was so much to it the more you
learned the more there was to learn so
that puzzle solving uh gift that I had
or desire wish you know I would do
crossword puzzles back in the day as
well as a little as a high school kid
fell in love with New York Times
crossword puzzles had to do one of those
every every day that the puzzle came out
in the paper so I always was a puzzle
solver and I think that that made it
easy for me to to transfer over that
skill set to chess
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
apologies everybody we are of course are
sorry that this is happening there are
some technical difficulties that are
being worked through but the Swiss
portion of the Julius bear generation
cup the playing stage have concluded and
Dania it was a very fun nine rounds some
of the players were able to Coast at the
end others had a win in the final round
just to get to the top of the standings
but we saw some great shots
so many amazing individual performances
Robert really headlined by Fabiano
caruano who had a wire to wire
performance could have looked a lot
different if you didn't win that first
round against gawaine Jones but he did
and then he won the second round in 15
moves and then he beat alireza furuja
and as you said coasting in the end but
he definitely deserved two quick draws
in the final rounds but Eduardo terizaga
you pointed him out at the very
beginning of the tournament and he is
one of those dark horses who squeezed
his way into the top eight and I'm so
Furious to see how these lower rated GMS
do against the top dogs when you know
qualification is on the line
yeah well of course wait for that as you
know play cannot resume just yet but you
know the format of the matches is
different than what we just saw in the
Swiss so when we get back to the chest
we will see a different Dynamic
altogether instead of being able to make
a quick draw and then hope that you keep
doing that uh we will see matches where
four players will advance to division
one 16 players will make it to division
two 32 get into division three and 20
players unfortunately don't have any
spots remaining they will be eliminated
and the players that are already in the
top division for the Julius bear
generation cup because of their
performance in the ancientious Rapid or
Magnus Carlson Wesley so no dear Beck
Abdul satorov and Dennis lazovic and
Dennis lasvik one division two there is
certainly no shame of being in division
two those events are still super strong
super GM level tournaments with double
elimination formats so no matter where
you look there are stars to watch
and I think that's the beauty Robert of
this format really the fact that yeah we
Spotlight the players who are in the top
eight we Spotlight the players who fight
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura and
others in the final but there's so many
cash prizes to be won by GMS who don't
have as much of a chance of finishing in
the top 10 and they also get their
moment in the sun they get to fight for
big prizes and they get practice
fighting in situations where a loss
essentially knocks you out so this is
invaluable experience particularly for
younger players in the 25 to 2600 range
and there are a lot of super GMS in
division two and even in division three
so even the players who didn't quite
make it into the top division do not
have an easy path nobody does if they
want to win a big cash prize
that's true here it's also true at the
upcoming World Cup where you play these
matches so it's this format that's about
to happen in the next stage of the plan
it's 10 minutes and two seconds per move
we know that and the matches consist of
just two games much like the World Cup
one that points wins the match
but the interesting part of this is that
players one through four get to choose
their opponents from five through eight
so if you're Fabiano has the one seed
and you say well that one player is the
lowest rated of the next punch you
probably choose them and of course match
play the results of which will determine
the division placement for the Julius
bear generation cup so Dania it's always
interesting to see you know which
players choose uh maybe a little bit
higher rate opponents but someone whose
style is easier for them to manage it's
a difficult choice because everyone is
super strong but you have to choose and
you have to choose wisely
and you have to realize that the player
who is chosen first isn't necessarily
the weaker player of the bunch
it's kind of like choosing who you're
playing one of your what 1v1 basketball
against is it gonna be LeBron James or
Michael Jordan or Stephen Curry right
had to make a Stephen Curry reference
after all and I think a lot of players
they make their decision not based on
the rating of their opponents because a
lot of the ratings are approximately
similar but just who they think they
would fare the best against and if
there's somebody under 2700 feet a yeah
they're probably going to be chosen
first but guess what then they're going
to have a chip on their shoulder and
they're likely to play better because
someone like Eduardo torizaga can say
listen you chose me first I am going to
make you regret that until your last day
so it adds a little bit of that
interesting psychological component
where the lower rated players and the
ones who are chosen first are trying to
prove their worth
yeah no definitely the case and he's
Terri zaga made it to division one last
time he won by milliseconds against para
maxoodloo he beat levona Ronin in the
aim chess rapid uh so Eduardo is one of
those players who may be lower rate on
paper but they can punch up and we do
know our top eight finishers the players
who will have a chance to compete for a
spot in division one five in a carwana
he won the event seven half out of Nine
the Swiss portion Perugia and elianov
had seven points and if the next batch
had six and a half but janapamnashi he
was with the best tie breaks of that
Bunch Alexi drev Amin topic to buy Ralph
momentov and Eduardo etorizage what's
super fascinating about this is that the
left four well Eliana and tapa to buy
are about the same rating but the left
four players one through four get to
choose their opponents they're the
highest rate of players So Daniel as you
look at this you know who do you think
Fabiano is going to choose
well I think Fabi is going to be
choosing between Alexi drev and Eduardo
itsurizaga and I think he's going to
choose Alexi Drea then I think alirez is
going to choose I mean those are the two
players who are under 2700 and Yana will
have a very unenviable choice because
Ralph mama
is just one of the least Pleasant
opponents to play in a knockout match
remember he knocked out janapamnushi in
RCC matches he has a very good pedigree
and very good performance in knockout
situations so my guess is that Ralph
will be chosen last you want to stay far
away from ahmedov as possible well
Wreck-It Ralph can't get the job done
you don't want to choose him because
then he'll feel that chip on the
shoulder that you mentioned but it's
never easy to choose from those list of
players I don't know how they're going
to do it we are going to take an
extended break as everyone all the
engineers everyone at chess.com works
very hard to get the site back up and
running and when it does get back we
will be back with the matches the stage
of the plan for the Julius bear
generation cup hopefully we return
shortly see you soon everybody
for 10 seconds yeah yes yes
why to play and draw
oh but this this I'm pretty sure I've
seen
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either H2 H3
yes my feeling would be
definitely not H2 because H2 then maybe
eat one night that's really a problem
yes so I have to go to H3 H3 Knight F4
PH2 my G4 check
then kh1 Knight F2 check
okay H2 E1 Knight and Knight F3 Knight
F3 King G3 yes very nice
very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's when the three nice so King H3
Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 Knight G4 Chuck Knight G4 King
H1
yeah very good
um
okay let's
start with the King H2
kind of have to like this
um H2O would probably go E1 I
oh is this case stream of E1 light and
Knight F3
well yes but King H3 I will go Knight F4
okay now I have to go to H2 Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
okay King H2 E1 light
and uh
oh Knight F3 Knight G3 yeah yeah
Knight F3 Knight takes a three King G3
very nice
I knew this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one
yeah I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 look at
seven Knight six easy yes yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle why
the move
because you you saved the simplest one
for the last one this this is Queen G7
over here yes yes
haha
wow
how did you get in here
so Queen G7 okay 796 mate yeah yes
that's it we saved the easiest for Less
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
and we sincerely apologize for
everything that has been taking place it
is not up to us it's unfortunate to
happen but the matches will be postponed
until tomorrow we know what the specific
matchups will be Unfortunately they
cannot take place right now chess.com
has tweeted about it you can read more
there but we are going to focus on the
matches that will take place tomorrow 2
p.m eastern time so right after the
first title Tuesday the matches will
commence and Donya you are pretty spot
on here with your predictions Fabiano
picked drev as his opponent otherwise
affiruja has itarizaga Pavo El yanov
takes on Ralph mama and janapamshi
against Amin tabith to buy so when you
see these four match-ups which one
catches your attention most
well first of all Fabiano's match is far
from a walk over Alexi drev is an
incredibly experienced Grand Master when
you have two game matches the margins of
Victory are so thin all it really takes
is one mistake you lose a game and then
suddenly you're in a must-win situation
so I'm definitely keeping an eye on
Alexi Drea can he make this top eight
finish count and obviously I mean top of
the bike he was leading the majority of
this tournament so I'm curious how he's
going to fare against John nepalnyushi
really all four of these matches Robert
are a treat for the eyes and I'll look
at the bright side at least we get more
uh Champions chess tour action tomorrow
we get to extend the joy over multiple
days that's right people can play in
title Tuesday then right after that they
may have matches to qualify for division
one of the Julius bear generation cup
and while this event will continue
tomorrow an event coming up very soon is
a super exciting one one you will not
want to miss it is POG Champs five and
it is back it starts Late July it
features some of your favorite streamers
Sea Dog VA cutie Cinderella I did a
thing and many more and they will be
announced shortly all the contestants
it's going to be an exciting event POG
Champs 5 with a live finals in Los
Angeles yes you can yourselves attend
that live Final in Los Angeles that will
be in August but the event starts Late
July on that note I think we are going
to call it a day we apologize once again
to everybody you know not up to us
unfortunately these things happen but we
wish you all well we hope you continue
enjoying chess and we will see you soon
for more chess action on any event that
is covered by chess.com so for now we
say goodbye and thank you for stopping
by for the Julius bear generation cup
plan until next time have a good one
[Music]
thank you
foreign